Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
So alles bla bla bla ist das doch.
Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Alles bla bla bla? Ja wirklich? Das werden wir jetzt feststellen in diesem neuesten Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Hakob-Ost, ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und freue mich sehr, dass ihr den Weg zu dieser besonderen Rasenfunk-Folge-Episode gefunden habt. Besonders nicht nur, weil wir über Fußballpodcasts reden werden, also eine schöne Metadiskussion führen werden, sondern auch, weil es noch nie mehr Gäste, die parallel zugeschaltet waren, im Rasenfunk gibt. Und wir haben alles an Audioqualität mit dabei. Von hervorragend zu herausragend bis hin zu Telefon. Aber wir wollen ja kein Internet-Shaming betreiben. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich begrüße in der Runde. Beginnen wollen wir mit der einzigen Dame, Anna Stecher, von der Kommunikationsagentur Kooperative Berlin. Sie macht den Podcast Fußball und Macht zusammen mit einem ganzen Team auf dem 11-Millimeter-Fußball-Film-Festival. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Außerdem mit in der Runde Oliver Leiste von 120 Minuten et Ersatzbank auf Twitter. Hallo Oliver.
Super, auf jeden Fall ist mir von Anfang an sehr positiv aufgefallen. Genau wie man auch im Textilvergehen zum Beispiel auch mit der Steffi immer wieder eine Frauensstimme hat, das ist eben noch so eine Sache, die sehr fehlt, auch in dieser Runde. Wir haben es schon mal thematisiert, aber umso besser ja, wenn es keine Reaktionen gibt, weder in das eine noch in die andere Richtung, denn so soll es ja eigentlich sein, einfach eine Normalität. Du René, mir ist eine Sache aufgefallen, als ich mich noch mal ausführlicher mit euch beschäftigt habe. Ich höre ja immer wieder rein, weißt du ja auch, ich finde die Folge eins nicht. Liegt es daran, dass du nicht mehr möchtest, dass man die hören kann?
Ne, sie müsste eigentlich noch da sein, aber aus irgendeinem Grund hat die Seite sie letztens irgendwie gefressen. Ich habe keine Ahnung und die ist jetzt relativ lange her, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die da noch irgendwo rumliegt. Also zumindestens müsste sie auf der Seite eigentlich noch zu finden sein.
Okay, also dann hat das keinen tieferen Grund. Ich werde auf jeden Fall mal reinhören, wenn sie wieder verfügbar ist. Ich habe da nämlich schon, da wurde ich schon misstrauisch, denn ich würde ehrlich gesagt meine ersten Folgen gerne verschwinden lassen.
Also gelöscht wird hier bei uns nichts. Und im Zweifelsfall findet man auch noch ganz alte YouTube-Clips von uns. Wir haben am Anfang ja nicht nur Audio gemacht, sondern wir haben auch irgendwann versucht, mit diesem Thema Video da irgendwie zu hantieren und haben zumindestens in der ersten oder ich glaube in der zweiten Saison so ein paar Video-Folgen gemacht. Also im Zweifelsfall findet man da noch ganz altes, merkwürdiges Bildmaterial von uns. Unter anderem ein Video, wie Alex Michael Skibbe interviewt.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen, stark!
Ja, dann guck mal auf dem YouTube-Kanal, du wirst den da sicherlich verlinken.
Absolut, das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken. Jetzt ist der Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast und der Millern-Ton. Das sind jetzt zwei Vereins-Podcasts, die wir hier auf der Shortlist für den Fußball-Podcast des Jahres haben.
Da darf ich noch mal kurz Mike-Franz-mäßig dazwischengrätschen.
Logisch, du machst das viel eleganter als Mike-Franz.
Ja, aber er macht das mittlerweile auch so. Ich hatte ihn ja im FCM-Podcast auch schon ein paar Mal begast. Also er fragte immer, darf ich mal bitte dazwischengrätschen? Wer weiß. Nein, Eintracht Podcast. Was ihr vorhin angesprochen habt, mir geht es auch ein bisschen so, dass ich Eintracht eigentlich auch erst seit dem Pokalsieg cool finde.
Erfolgsfan, was?
Nein, weil mein Bruder seit 1,5 Jahren in Wetzlar wohnt und da bei einem kleinen Kreisligisten spielt und da alle Eintracht-Frankfurt-Fans sind. Deswegen habe ich da so ein bisschen jetzt, dass ich auch Eintracht zumindest nicht mehr ganz so scheiße finde wie früher. Und irgendwie habe ich es mal geschafft. Ich bin der Twitter-Beauftragte von diesem Verein in Wetzlar geworden. So und dann weiß ich jetzt nicht, Eintracht Podcast, wie gut Kontakt habt ihr denn zur Eintracht selber, also zur Mannschaft?
Das ist so ein bisschen schwieriges Thema manchmal. Also sie wissen, dass es uns gibt. Sie nehmen uns sehr wohl wahr und an so manchen Reaktionen merkt man auch, dass sie durchaus die Folgen hören. Wir versuchen immer mal wieder so ein bisschen die Kontaktaufnahme, aber die Reaktion ist dann doch eher so nicht vorhanden.
Okay, das ist schade, weil mein großes Ziel war, als ich diesen Twitter-Account vom RSV Büblingshausen übernommen habe. Die dritte Mannschaft ist Ende der letzten Saison Meister geworden. Und das große Ziel war natürlich, das Super Cup-Match gegen den amtierenden Pokalsieger zu organisieren. Aber die Eintracht auf Twitter hat nicht geantwortet. Und deswegen dachte ich, frage ich einfach mal euch, ob ihr entweder die Eintracht vorbeischicken könnt oder selber mal zum Super Cup vorbeikommen wollt.
Ja, selber mal vorbeikommen ist natürlich in dem Fall einfacher, als die Eintracht mal eben da vorbeischickt. Also das ist ganz ehrlich so ein Ding, was in den letzten Jahren nicht wirklich besser geworden ist. Also in den ersten Jahren war das so ein bisschen einfacher. Und dann ist das irgendwann so ein bisschen ruhig geworden. Also wie gesagt, da haben wir leider auch nicht so viel Kontakt oder nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit, wie wir sie vielleicht gerne manchmal hätten.
Na ja, dann müsst ihr euch stellen. Also gegen den Bass, die euch ja selber schon gespielt, ich denke, das ist ein Niveau, mit dem die Jungs seinen Wetzler umgehen können.
Ja, dann schicke ich ihn vorher noch mal ins Trainingslager.
Und Wetzler, nettvergess Wetzler, sage ich an der Stelle nur, was du bestimmt auch noch nie gehört hast, Oli. Aber wie ist denn das, wenn wir jetzt schon über das Verhältnis zum Verein gesprochen haben, wie ist denn das mit den Frankfurter Medien, René?
Ja, wir haben ja den großen Vorteil, dass Marvin, der ja einer von uns ist mittlerweile, als freier Journalist beim HR tätig ist.
Der Mars durch die Institution.
Genau. Von daher, da sind die Kontakte eigentlich relativ gut. Die Kollegen von der Rundschauer kennen wir natürlich auch. Da gibt es jetzt aber nicht so viel Zusammenarbeit. Man kennt sich, man grüßt sich, aber dann war es das auch schon wieder so ein Stück weit.
Und kannst du dir das erklären, warum der Verein, also warum die Medien ihr eigenes Ding machen? Ist ja klar, den geht es ja erst mal um sich selbst. Aber warum das Verhältnis zum Verein so, nicht schwierig, aber erkaltet ist, wart ihr besonders kritisch? Wurde euch da mal was gespiegelt? Denn eigentlich ist es ja etwas, was sich ein Bundesliga-Verein sehr gerne auf die Fahnen schreiben könnte, dass er schon so lange einen sehr treuen Podcast hat. Und andere Bundesliga-Vereine tun das auch. Also der 1. FCU Berlin hat zum Beispiel das Textilvergehen ja mit der Ehrennadel ausgezeichnet, also ihnen einen Preis verliehen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, oder das jetzt genau belegen zu können, dass das natürlich so ein bisschen die Schwierigkeit ist, dass man so ein Medium dann auch gerne irgendwie kontrollieren will und sehen will, was dann da irgendwie passiert. Und wir sind nun mal nicht so, dass wir da jetzt irgendwie zurückhalten sind oder uns verstellen. Wir sagen halt, wenn wir mal was Scheiße finden. Und wir tun das auch noch zum Teil auf sehr andere Art und Weise. Und von daher weiß ich nicht, ob das vielleicht so etwas ist, was da so ein bisschen negativ ausschlägt. Und wir haben natürlich auch im Verein immer relativ viel kritisiert. Ich habe ja am Anfang gesagt, wir sind so ein bisschen Therapiestunde. Also alles das, was die anderen Fans halt auch so ein bisschen unschön finden oder wo sie sagen, das ist irgendwie gerade blöd gelaufen im Verein, das sprechen wir halt auch an und kriegen da halt auch viel Zuruf. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das irgendwie so ein Thema ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite, klar, hast du recht. Ich meine, wir machen für den Verein halt dann an der Stelle auch so ein bisschen die Arbeit, dass wir halt auch versuchen, das so ein bisschen einzuordnen, was man an anderer Stelle vielleicht eigentlich auch selbst ganz gut tun könnte. Es gab immer mal wieder Gerüchte, dass sie irgendwie in einen Podcast starten, dann ist dann da doch irgendwie nichts draus geworden. Ich glaube, man hat sich da sehr stark einfach auch auf dieses Thema Videomaterial irgendwie fokussiert, was ja auch so ein sehr beliebtes Thema ist. Aber ich glaube, da kommt man auch irgendwie so gegen gängige YouTube-Geschichten und so weiter nicht unbedingt irgendwie an.
Man muss halt auch dazu sagen, es gibt natürlich für so ein Bundesligisten eine Million Anfragen jede Woche. Und wenn dann ein Spieler gesagt bekommt, hier willst du zum Eintracht-Podcast, und dann wird er gefragt, wie lange dauert das? Und dann sagen die ja so zwei Stunden, dann sagt der, bist du bescheuert? Das mache ich nie im Leben. Und Freddy Bobic oder so, die werden halt auch lieber in so ein Setting wie Sky90 gehen oder in Kicker Talk, wo sie zwar zwei, drei vielleicht auch etwas kritischere Fragen bekommen, aber wo es doch immer sehr gesittet zugeht. Also, die tun sich ja alle gegenseitig nicht weh. Und wenn du dann einem erzählst, du musst jetzt zwei Stunden da mit irgendwelchen Fans reden, dann haben die da keine Lust drauf.
Ich glaube, es sind ja nicht nur die Fragen, sondern es ist dann ja eher noch mal das Nachfragen. Also eine Frage stellen und die dann irgendwie mit so einer Marketing-ähnlichen Antwort abbügeln, ja, aber wenn es dann halt noch geht, dass man dann auch noch mal nachbohrt. Ja, und die Länge ist natürlich auch noch so ein Ding. Wir haben ganz am Anfang mal so ein Video-Interview mit Christoph Preuß gemacht. Da war er dann gerade mit seiner Spielerlaufbahn so mehr oder weniger durch und ist dann da in die Geschäftsstelle reingegangen. Und damals hat man halt gesagt, du, wir machen ein kurzes Video mit dir, 25 Minuten. Das war dann halt auch wieder so eine Frequenz, die irgendwie okay war. Ja, aber Podcast ist halt so lang, wie er halt lang ist.
Ja, aber die Länge ist natürlich ein Argument. Also ich hatte mal Giovane Elber, da war auch natürlich wichtige Vorgabe, nicht länger als eine halbe Stunde, hat er keine Zeit. Und bei Summer und Henkel gab es damals auch eine Vorgabe, die ich dann bis zum allerletzten ausgereizt habe und da sehr viel drauf gesetzt habe, dass die einfach zu höflich sind, um zu sagen, jetzt müssen wir aber wirklich gehen. Allerdings war Friedi Brobic ja auch schon mal im Immer Härter Podcast. Also es kann auch funktionieren, wobei es da auch persönliche Beziehungen hat.
Ja, aber das war ja auch eine knappe Stunde nur. Und er und der Moderator kennen sich ja auch schon seit vielen Jahren. Und das ist dann natürlich auch nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte, als wenn jetzt irgendwie Marvin, Basti oder ich da halt einfach mal irgendwie anrufen und sagen so, übrigens, wie sieht's aus? Und im Zweifelsfall gibt es auch noch eine ganze Menge ehemalige Spieler, die ich einfach auch ganz gerne mal drin hätte.
Naja, was nicht ist, kann ja immer noch werden. Jetzt geht das schon seit acht Jahren so, dann kann es ja auch noch 18 Jahre so gehen. Und wer weiß, wie weit das dann gekommen sein wird mit dem Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast. Wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, auch schon indirekt ganz, ganz häufig gesagt, warum man bei euch reinhören sollte. Wenn die Hörerinnen und Hörer sich jetzt noch nicht dafür interessieren, dann ist ihnen wirklich nicht mehr zu helfen.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage an euch. Gibt es eine Folge von euch, in der ihr euch in den letzten Monaten mit einer möglichen Fusion von Eintracht Frankfurt und dem ersten FFC Frankfurt beschäftigt habt, die man hören könnte?
Also wir haben viele Folgen, die man hören könnte, aber mit dem Thema haben wir uns in der Stadt noch nicht beschäftigt aktuell. Von daher kann ich dir da in der Richtung leider nichts bieten. Ich kann den Marvin morgen mal freundlich anpieksen, vielleicht fällt da was aus ihm raus.
Dann schicke ich gleich noch eine Frage hinterher. Ich habe am Wochenende vernommen, dass einer möglichen Fusion, die Eintracht Frankfurt-Mitglieder zustimmen müssten. Kannst du das eventuell bestätigen?
Das kannst du weder dementieren, noch bestätigen.
Die Frage ist ja, wenn der Verein fusioniert, dann müssen die Mitglieder zustimmen. Das ist klar. Das ist so.
Okay, alles klar, wunderbar.
Das ist aber meines Wissens nach Bestandteil des deutschen Vereinsrechts.
Das war mir jetzt so nicht bewusst, da bin ich nicht so bewandelt.
Auf jeden Fall, wie Sven das hier gleich zu Recherchezwecken verwendet, dieses Zusammentreffen und hier für Lottes Erbenen die nötigen Informationen sieht für die nächste Folge. Also der Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast. Hört rein, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und reinhören solltet ihr ebenfalls im Podcast Fußball und Macht. Anna, ich habe dich vorhin schon vorgestellt und habe gesagt, die kooperative Berlin, bei der du arbeitest, wäre eine Kommunikationsagentur. War das denn überhaupt richtig? Was ist denn überhaupt die kooperative Berlin?
Genau, es ist nämlich eigentlich gar nicht so ganz richtig. Also die kooperative Berlin ist eine digitale Mediengesellschaft. Und was wir sind, naja, wir sind breit aufgestellt. Wir machen digitale Beratungen, wir machen historisch-politische Bildungsarbeit und viele verschiedene Formate von Podcasts bis Video auf Portraits und Reportagen. Und hauptsächlich arbeiten wir für die öffentlich-rechtlichen Träger sowie Bundesstiftungen, Gewerkschaften und Vereine.
Und in diesem Rahmen habt ihr dann auch den Podcast Fußball und Macht produziert in Zusammenarbeit mit dem 11-Millimeter-Fußball-Film-Festival, der jetzt eben auch auf der Shortlist für den Fußballpodcastpreis des Jahres steht. Wie kam es denn zu der Kooperation und was war so das Ziel dahinter, hinter diesem Podcast?
Ja, also erstmal, ich bin ja beeindruckt, in welchem illustrem Kreise wir uns hier befinden, denn unser Podcast ist ja tatsächlich jetzt im März 2018 entstanden. Vielleicht was man dazu sagen kann, also das 11-Millimeter-Fußball-Film-Festival, das in Berlin im März stattgefunden hat, hat so derzeit zum 15. Mal stattgefunden. Und wir kennen einige von Brot und Spiele, also dem Verein für Sport und Kultur, die das ja immer wieder auf die Beine stellen. Und die stellen ja in ihrem Filmfestival das gesellschaftliche Phänomen Fußball in der Vielfalt der verschiedenen Filmgattungen eigentlich da. Und das hat uns dazu gereizt, mal mit denen gemeinsam eine Film- und Gesprächsreihe zum Thema Fußball und Macht zu entwickeln. Natürlich anlässlich der WM in Russland.
Und warum hat sich da das Medium Podcast für euch angeboten?
Weil wir es, glaube ich, zu schade fänden, wenn wir nur die Gesprächsreihe gemacht hätten vor Ort für die natürlich zahlreichen Besucher des Filmfestivals. Aber das wäre so eine verflüchtigende Angelegenheit gewesen. Und mit dem Podcast war uns natürlich klar, dass wir damit viel mehr Leute erreichen können, die vielleicht auch nicht in Berlin sind und sich trotzdem natürlich für Fußball und Filme und vielleicht auch das Thema des Politischen im Fußball interessieren.
Jetzt hast du schon erzählt, also die Kooperative hat viele andere Dinge auch schon gemacht für die Bundeszentrale, für politische Bildung, für funk, unterstützt auch zum Teil den Deutschlandfunk in strategischen Weiterentwicklungen. Kannst du uns mal erklären, wie ihr da im Team gearbeitet habt? Denn ich glaube, das unterscheidet sich am deutlichsten von vielen der anderen hier versammelten Podcasts, dass du bist Projektleiterin bei der Kooperative. Was war denn zum Beispiel deine Funktion?
Also Projektleiterin war ich bei diesem Projekt tatsächlich nicht. Das war Oliver Baumann-Gibbon und wir haben uns mit Birger Schmidt von 11mm zusammengesetzt und haben gesagt, es wäre so toll, eben zur WM in Russland uns mehr mit dem Aspekt des Politischen in Fußball auseinanderzusetzen. Und man muss dazu sagen, wir wurden gefördert von der Bundesstiftung zur Aufarbeitung der SED-Diktatur, was uns natürlich ermöglicht hat, dann eben zu dieser Gesprächsreihe verschiedene Gäste einzuladen, die dann nach Berlin gekommen sind.
Und dann sag uns mal, was kann man jetzt finden? Es gibt jetzt neun Folgen. Du hast gesagt, ihr seid der jüngste Podcast von denen, die hier auf die Shortlist genommen wurden. Was waren so die Themenschwerpunkte und womit würdest du vielleicht auch neuen Hörern und Hörern empfehlen zu starten?
Ja, also im Fokus stand ja das Politische im Fußball und das oft kritische Verhältnis von Fußball und Macht. Und wir haben uns ja immer wieder mit Formen und Grenzen der staatlichen Einflussnahme und dessen Instrumentalisierung beschäftigt. Und ich glaube, was interessant ist, dass wir wirklich ein sehr breites Spektrum an verschiedenen Ländern haben, die wir uns auch anschauen, also von natürlich Russland mit Should You Be Afraid of Russian World Cup, bis hin Nordkorea, The Game of Their Lives und Jeshel Kirmeset zum Beispiel, ein Film über die türkisch-kurdische Situation in der Osttürkheit. Da haben wir dann natürlich auch ganz viele historische Themen, also die DDR mit Totem-Verräter über Lutz Eigendorf und WM78 in Argentinien. Also wir sind recht breit aufgestellt. Es fällt mir wirklich schwer zu sagen, mit was man anfangen sollte, denn jede Episode steht eigentlich für sich. Man kann sie immer kombinieren, dass man im Internet häufig auf YouTube oder auf Links sich Filmausschnitte oder die ganzen Filme anschauen kann. Ich glaube, ich würde zwei persönliche Highlights nennen, einmal Offside, ein Film über die iranischen Fußballzuschauerinnen, die aber kein Fußballstadion betreten dürfen und sich für uns die Frage gestellt haben, wie es mit Frauen, Fußball und Macht eigentlich die Regeln sind und welchen Wandel man heutzutage im Iran erwarten kann. Zum anderen finde ich Yashil Kyrgyzmize sehr beeindruckend. Da geht es um einen Fußballverein, der seinen Vereinsnamen in den kurdischen Namen Amet Zbor umbenannt hat und seitdem Anfeindungen, Repressalien, Gewaltandrohungen und so weiter erlebt hat. Die Frage ist, wie geht Erdogan, die Türkei oder die türkische Regierung mit seinen kurdischen Mitbürgerinnen um? Und was können vor allem auch demokratische Staaten wie Deutschland eigentlich tun?
Hochspannende Themen. Dennoch würde mich jetzt mal die Meinung von allen anderen interessieren. Denn ich führe mit der Podcast-Show ja eine Liste der deutschsprachigen Fußballpodcasts. Auch ein paar Fremdsprachige sind sogar mit drauf. Deswegen habe ich immer einen ganz guten Überblick. Und trotzdem ist mir euer Podcast ausgerechnet, Anna, ist mir durchgerutscht. Obwohl die Themen zu 110 Prozent in meinem Interesse liegen und ich jetzt auch schon mit großer Freude in die eine oder andere Folge reingehört habe. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie es den anderen dagegen. Sven, du sitztest bei mir im Büro. Kanntest du den Podcast, bevor auf der Shortlist war? Oliver?
Nein.
René? Nein. Rüdiger? Leider nein. Klaas?
Natürlich.
Und Mike? Da frage ich mich, Anna, was hätten, haben wir einen Fehler gemacht oder seid ihr vielleicht nicht in den Netzwerken aktiv, in denen wir vermehrt unterwegs sind? Also wir haben heute schon viel über Twitter zum Beispiel gesprochen, da trifft man viele von uns täglich an. Kannst du dir das erklären? Was kann man daraus vielleicht auch mitnehmen? Also ich will jetzt überhaupt kein Fingerpointing betreiben, sondern mich interessiert es tatsächlich auch für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die vielleicht selber mal ein Podcast machen wollen. Wo muss man sein, damit so Leute wie wir jetzt, die alle nein gesagt haben, bis auf Klaas natürlich einen neuen Podcast finden können?
Also das finde ich auch wirklich sehr spannend. Wir haben natürlich über unsere eigenen Kanäle viel gepostet. Wir haben natürlich auch über 11 Millimeter viel Werbung gemacht. Aber Soundcloud und iTunes und unsere Website reichen da vielleicht einfach nicht aus, wenn man natürlich als Stichworte Fußball und Macht hat. Also das sind einfach so schwierige Worte, um die bei Google überhaupt nach oben zu bekommen. Besonders zur Zeit der WM in Russland. Also das ist uns auch aufgefallen und das fanden wir auch sehr schade. Umso schöner natürlich, dass wir bei der Shortlist dabei sind. Wir hoffen natürlich, dass, falls wir nächstes Jahr wieder mit 11mm eine Filme- und Gesprächsreihe machen, dass wir da dann vielleicht es doch schaffen, dass man auf die vorherigen Episoden hinweist und da ein bisschen mehr Leute erreicht. Aber genau, Überwerbung würden wir uns natürlich sehr freuen.
Genau, also vielleicht ist das so ein bisschen das, was man da mitnehmen kann. Es ist schwieriger geworden inzwischen bei iTunes, dass man gefunden wird. Ihr seid bei iTunes, das wäre so der Weg gewesen, über den ich euch hätte finden müssen eigentlich, denn ich gehe das regelmäßig, die Liste der neuen Podcasts durch, um die Podcasts zu aktualisieren. Da seid ihr nicht aufgetaucht und das muss dann mit dem WM-Hype und ein paar Dingen, die sich sonst so verändert haben, zusammenhängen. Das zeigt aber auch, dass wir alle, die gerade nein gesagt haben, noch ein bisschen mehr die Augen und Ohren offen halten können und dass wir vielleicht auch unsere Rolle als zum Teil ja reichweitenstarke Influencer in der Situation nicht richtig nachgekommen sind. Denn das Thema ist hochinteressant. Ich würde meine Hand dafür ins Feuer legen, dass es den Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörern zum Beispiel gefällt, Fußball und Macht und deswegen hätte ich das dann auch weiter tragen müssen. Und Klaas darf uns jetzt erklären, wie zur Hölle bist du auf Fußball und Macht aufmerksam geworden, du Streber?
Na der Kollege Ronny Blaschke, der heute ja schon ein paar Mal Tee gemacht hat.
Also holt euch einfach Ronny Blaschke in eurem Podcast, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr selber einen macht.
Den teilen wir uns ja alle, ne?
Ja, also beim Deutschlandfunk wird er ja auch mit den Themen, die hier auch angesprochen wurden, war er ja auch, wir haben auch eine Podcast-Serie zum Beispiel zur WM in Russland mit ihm gemacht, Football Politiker.
Der nächste von Klaas.
Man muss, ja, aber es hat auch einen Grund, warum ich das sage, weil ich glaube, dass man mit solchen Themen ganz schwer durchdringt im Fußballbereich. Also natürlich kann jetzt jeder sagen, ah, geiles Thema, Menschenrechte und dann diese Geschichten zu hören von Betroffenen, das klingt alles super spannend, aber wenn es um den Sport geht, das merke ich auch bei meiner eigenen Arbeit, ist es schwierig, Leute dafür zu begeistern, sich mit solchen Themen zu beschäftigen, weil Sport dann doch oft als eher Unterhaltung gesehen wird. Und ich glaube, dass es sehr schade ist, ist auch ein Problem, aber ich habe da auch noch keine wirkliche Lösung gefunden. Aber das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, Max, ist natürlich immer ein guter Weg. Das soll Podcaster generell viel mehr tun, andere Podcasts... Das auch, aber halt auch andere Podcasts zu empfehlen, weil man braucht nie Angst haben, dass man sich irgendwie gegenseitig Hörer wegnimmt, sondern es ist eher ganz andersrum. Die meisten Leute werden es so richtig angefixt, wenn sie so zwei, drei Podcasts haben, diese regelmäßig hören. Und genug Zeit haben eigentlich auch alle Leute.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also ich sehe das ja bei mir in meiner Twitter-Timeline. Da fliegen halt auch immer ganz oft irgendwie vorbei so die Folge und die Folge. Da denke ich mir auch, na, aber warum soll ich das jetzt hören? Weil ich habe ja eh schon so viel. Aber wenn dann halt die Empfehlung irgendwie in einem anderen Podcast ist und mir die Person, die ich sowieso schon regelmäßig höre, irgendwie das empfiehlt oder sogar die Person, die diesen anderen Podcast macht, dabei ist, dann ist das nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Und Max, du guckst wahrscheinlich jetzt einfach die iTunes-Listen da einfach durch, weil du halt eben die Podroll fliegst. Aber ich muss auch so ehrlich sein, ich gucke da jetzt nicht irgendwie dreimal am Tag durch, ob da jetzt irgendwas Neues hochgeploggt ist. Also ich glaube, diese Empfehlungen werden da ganz krass unterschätzt. Und das ist das, was halt einfach viel, viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit bringt, als jetzt einfach nur in irgendwelchen Twitter, Facebook, sonstigen Kanälen unterwegs zu sein. Weil da erreicht man sowieso nur die Leute, die man sowieso und zweifel schon hat.
Genau, und gerade tatsächlich bei Fußball und Macht, das sind einfach zwei Worte, die kann ich noch so häufig bei iTunes eingeben. Dafür ist das ja vielleicht auch das Falsche, was wir uns ausgesucht haben.
Ja, hättet ihr euch kalte Bratwurst genannt, dann hätte man euch leichter gedacht. Das war René, der da so gebrummt hat. Ausnahmsweise mal nicht Klaas im Hintergrund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bei so vielen zugeschaltet muss man das ja aufklären. Vielleicht an der Stelle dann auch der richtige Hinweis für euch, auch da als solltet ihr einen Podcast selbst betreiben oder einen entdeckt haben, der nicht genügend Aufmerksamkeit bekommt, auch keine Scheu zu haben, das einfach zu sagen. Also nicht nur auf der Podcast werden ja alle neuen sowieso aufgenommen. Also da findet ja keine Selektion statt. Wer wäre ich, dass ich da selektieren würde? Wer nicht drauf ist, den habe ich einfach nicht gesehen. Und auch ruhig einfach andere Podcasts anschreiben und freundlich fragen, ob sie vielleicht da mal reinhören wollen. Und dann ist meine persönliche Erfahrung aus dem Rasenfunk. Am Anfang habe ich noch am Ende jeder Folge einfach Podcasts empfohlen, die ich gerne höre. Das hat meiner Meinung nach aber weniger gut funktioniert, als so wie ich es jetzt mache. Jetzt weise ich immer auf einzelne Folgen hin und auch nur, wenn ich sie wirklich gehört habe und wenn ich dann auch zwei, drei Sätze dazu sagen kann, warum ich sie gerne gehört habe. Das Feedback, was ich so bekomme, ist, dass dann die Leute tatsächlich dann auch an den Downloads spüren, dass da jemand empfohlen hat. Und im Grunde würde ich mich freuen, wenn das jeder Podcaster machen würde, dass er am Ende seiner eigenen Sendung, wenn er etwas gehört hat, was er toll fand, das einfach nur mal einfließen lässt. Also im Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast ist es ja auch ein eigenes Segment sogar. Das finde ich, bräuchte es fast noch ein bisschen mehr. Denn aus gewissen Gründen, über die wir später auch noch sprechen werden, verändert sich da gerade in der Podcastlandschaft fast. Und diese unabhängigen Podcasts, hinter denen nicht ein Sender steht oder ein Werbenetzwerk oder ein großes anderes Medium, die werden es immer schwieriger haben, Reichweite zu bekommen. Und mit diesem Appell steige ich von meiner Kanzel herunter und lasse das einfach mal wirken. Eine letzte Frage hätte ich an dich noch, Anna. Du hast schon gesagt, mit welchen Folgen man starten kann. Und bei neun Folgen ist es tatsächlich ja auch noch einfacher, sich einen Überblick zu verschaffen. Du hast jetzt schon angedeutet, eventuell könnte das weitergehen. Wie war denn die Resonanz auf dieses Projekt?
Also alle, die uns gehört haben, die haben, also nicht natürlich nicht alle, aber viele haben sich zurückgemeldet und haben auch immer wieder betont, dass es einfach super spannende Themen sind. Also gerade diese Schnittstelle Fußball und Macht. Und wie ist das eigentlich mit Politik? Und wie ist das eigentlich, wenn Staaten sich da so einmischen und Fußball oder Sport generell instrumentalisieren? Das hat schon viel Zustimmung erhalten.
Also können wir darauf hoffen, dass es da auch nochmal was geben wird jetzt dann im neuen Jahr und es sich lohnt, auf jeden Fall den Feed zu abonnieren.
Also das Schöne ist ja, jetzt kenne ich euch ja alle und ich werde euch natürlich sofort berichten, sobald es wieder eine neue Podcast-Folge gibt.
Sehr gut. Das ist ein positives Signal und dann hören jetzt sowieso schon alle in Fußball und Macht hinein. Und dann bekommt ihr ja nachträglich bestimmt auch noch etwas Feedback, das ihr euch sehr, sehr redlich verdient habt. Lasst uns über den Millerton sprechen. Das heißt, wir schalten jetzt zu unserem Korrespondenten der Außenwette in Hamburg. Mike, Mike, kannst du mich hören? Du musst jetzt leicht verzögert mal antworten. Die Leitung ist in Studio. Lasst uns über den Millerton sprechen. 58 Folgen seit 2013. Wenn ich das richtig nachgesehen habe, ein Podcast zum FC St. Pauli. Auch ein sehr alter, schon seit fünf Jahren eben online. Wie kam es denn dazu, dass man euch dann auch hören konnte, plötzlich nicht nur lesen?
Im Endeffekt musste ich jetzt hier die Blumen weiterreichen an einen Podcast, der schon erwähnt wurde und der aus Gründen nicht dabei ist, nämlich das Textilvergehen. Als ich angefangen habe, Podcast zu hören, war das Textilvergehen das, was ich im Fußballbereich gehört habe. Und das fand ich so großartig, dass man sich da mit drei, vier, fünf Leuten, je nach Zusammensetzung, einmal die Woche an so einen Küchentisch setzt und einfach über das Geschehen im Verein diskutiert, dass ich gedacht habe, oh, das wäre so schön, wenn wir sowas auch hätten. Und ja, wir hatten sowas aber nicht, obwohl die Fernsehende selbst sein Polyfonzimmer ziemlich viel hat. Das aber halt nicht und dann habe ich gesagt, gut, wenn das sonst keiner macht, dann mache ich das jetzt. Und habe mir fünf, sechs Leute zusammengesucht, die im Endeffekt bis heute noch dabei sind. Da gab es so ein, zwei personelle Wechsel, wegen Umzug oder ähnlichen Dingen. Und wir haben da, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Querschnitt durch die Fernzene gemacht, inklusive jemanden auch vom Fernprojekt. Also es ging für viele Vereine. Vielleicht ist es noch ein bisschen komisch. Bei St. Pauli ist das Fernprojekt ja der Fanladen und ist wirklich das Herz der Fernzene. Und dass wir da mit wechselnder Besetzung mal Justus, mal Sven, etc., mal Stefan dabei haben, davon profitiert die Sendung, glaube ich, auch sehr. Und dann haben wir halt eine Nullnummer aufgenommen, haben uns ein, zwei Leute dann dazu geholt, wo wir gesagt haben, ein Thema, ob das in Ordnung ist. Und die meisten haben dann gesagt, ja, mach mal weiter, und die Fischen, ja, macht das durchaus Spaß. Und wir sind doch einige Folgen älter geworden.
Absolut. Und hattet auch schon namhafte Gäste, also von Philipp Heerwagen über Ewald Lienen bis hin zu Andreas Rettig, auch schon einige interessante Persönlichkeiten des Vereins. Wie ist denn euer Verhältnis zum FC St. Pauli, wenn wir vorhin beim Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast schon über deren Verhältnis nicht zu St. Pauli, sondern zu Eintracht Frankfurt natürlich gesprochen haben?
Ja, da habe ich ein bisschen beschämt zu Boden geguckt, als René das erzählt hat. Leider ist es ja auch bei vielen anderen Vereinen so, dass gar nichts wegen Podcasts, aber auch Fan-Webseiten sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt werden und nicht wie ein weiteres Medium, was einem im Zweifel sogar deutlich positiver zuneigt ist, als viele normale, althergebrachte Medien sind. Da können wir uns überhaupt nicht beschweren. Im Gegenteil, wir haben einen super Draht zum Verein. Vielleicht, wie gesagt, damals ist das ja auch mit aus dem Übersteiger heraus entstanden, der natürlich seit 1993 ein Fan-Team beim FCN Poly ist mit einem gewissen Standing auch und auch guten Kontakten zum Verein. Das hat sicherlich geholfen.
Hast du gesagt seit 1993? Seit 1993. Entschuldigung, ich wollte eigentlich noch einen anderen Podcast placken. Hat nicht funktioniert, das hat niemand verstanden. Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden. Machen Sie weiter. Ja toll, und du hast nicht gelacht. Danke René für nichts. Okay, Grüße auf jeden Fall. So Mike, seit 1993, Entschuldigung.
Die Grüße hätte ich natürlich nachher, wenn wir darüber sprechen, was wir für Podcasts noch hören, auch gebracht. Aber ja, hast du recht. Deswegen haben wir da einen sehr guten Drahtenverein und haben eben auch tatsächlich, ich glaube das ist bei Vereinspodcasts in Deutschland schon die große Ausnahme, tatsächlich sehr regelmäßig hochrangigen Besuch. Spiele hast du schon erwähnt, aber eben auch der Präsident war schon zweimal da, Evaldine war da, Andreas Rettig war da, also das ist natürlich schon alles etwas, was man so in dieser Ausführlichkeit und Länge dann halt sonst nicht hört. Und vielleicht was den Millantoren ausmacht, ist tatsächlich ein großer Unterschied zu den meisten anderen Podcasts zumindest, dass wir uns tatsächlich immer physisch treffen. Also Paulinas Erben macht das auch. Bei uns ist das auch so, wir sitzen immer in einem Raum. Und da werden mit Stammhörern wahrscheinlich Lachen zusammenbrechen, dass ich eine dermaßen schlechte Audioqualität heute an den Tag lege, weil das sagt man uns da auch gerne immer nach. Liegt aber halt daran, wenn sechs Leute in so einem Raum sitzen, wo auch noch ein Kühlschrank brummt und vielleicht die eine oder andere Bierflasche geöffnet wird und der Stuhl knarrt, dann sind da halt Hintergrundgeräusche. Das wird sich nicht ganz vermeiden. Wird uns aber halt gerne auch immer mal nahegebracht, das doch zu verbessern. Da sind uns aber so ein bisschen die Hände gebunden. Und seit dieser Saison haben wir das eben auch alles ein bisschen technisch anders aufgestellt. Bisher haben wir einen Übersteiger-Blog veröffentlicht. Inzwischen sind wir auf einer eigenen Seite, die da heißt melaton.de. Und wir haben den Gast so ein bisschen weiter im Vordergrund gebracht. Also wir sprechen nicht mehr über die zurückliegenden ganzen Spiele, wie wir es in der Vergangenheit gemacht haben, sondern wir sprechen immer maximal noch über ein Spiel, weil wir jetzt eben und damit sind wir tatsächlich fast so ein bisschen wider Rasenfunk. Wir haben ein zweites Format, nämlich die Vor- und Nach-den-Spiel-Gespräche. Die haben wir schon ein bisschen länger, aber bisher war das immer auf zwei getrennten Websites auch. Und da wird tatsächlich von aktuell drei sehr engagierten Leuten, Michael, Daniel und Tobias, vor und nach dem Spiel jeweils ein Podcast mit einem Fan der Mannschaft geführt, gegen die wir gespielt haben. Und dadurch haben wir tatsächlich zwei verschiedene Hörformate. Einmal heißt auch intern bei uns die Hauptsendung, wo wir halt da immer zu sechst alle drei, vier Wochen sitzen. Übrigens im Stadion, also in den Fan-Räumen, die die Fanszene, die sich das erste Mal Pauli gekauft hat, als das Stadion umgebaut wurde. Und eben vor und nach den Spielgesprächen.
Und ihr seid ja auch einer der Podcasts, der durchaus auch von Fans anderer Vereine gehört wird. Also ich spreche da jetzt für mich. Ich weiß auch, dass aus der Runde viele im Millern-Ton reinhören. Bekommt ihr da auch ähnliche Rückmeldungen wie die Jungs und das Mädel vom Eintracht Frankfurt-Podcast, wo es heißt, bei euch höre ich trotzdem rein? Oder ich höre besonders gerne rein, wenn die Stimmung schlecht ist, wenn es schlecht läuft?
Deswegen wäre das jetzt kein Grund. Zum anderen ist es aber so, dass wir... Also ja, wir haben, glaube ich, viele Hörer, die nicht ganz Pauli-Fan sind. Ich glaube, das liegt aber dann tatsächlich halt an den Gästen. Und da vielleicht auch höre ich häufig... Ja, also die ersten drei Spiele, die er da bespricht, die kippe ich immer weg. Völlig richtig. Würde mich als Nicht-San-Pauli-Fan dann auch nicht interessieren.
Wobei ich genau das toll finde. Also ja, klar, die Spiele mögen nicht jeden interessieren. Aber dass ihr sogar, wenn Andreas Rettich zu Gast ist, erst noch ganz entspannt eine Stunde darüber redet, wie dieses 1-2-1 in Paderborn jetzt nochmal genau zu bewerten ist, das finde ich super. Ich habe das deswegen gehört, weil ich wissen wollte, sagt er jetzt mal zwischendurch was oder hält er jetzt komplett die Klappe oder werft ihr irgendwann ein, dass er doch nochmal aus dem Raum gegangen ist, um ein bisschen Ablage zu machen, das finde ich super.
Ja, also das kam ja vorhin auch beim Eintracht-Podcast her, wenn wir da einen fragen würden und erzählen wir dem, dass der zwei Stunden hier sitzen muss, dann ist der erstmal abgeschreckt. Das kommt bei uns natürlich auch mal vor. Also gerade die Folge mit Evalin war dahingehend ein besonderes Erlebnis, weil er kam halt rein und dachte, wie lange machen wir denn jetzt hier? Ja, also länger als neunzehn Minuten ja nicht. Also in einer Stunde kann das ja schon durch sein. Unsere Sendungen sind halt eher bei drei Stunden. Und wir kamen ihm da natürlich so ein bisschen entgegen, haben gesagt, ja, probieren wir schon.
Also mit entgegenkommen hast du gemeint, ihr habt gelogen.
Ja, genau. Dieses Setting soll ja tatsächlich sein, da sitzen ein paar Leute und unterhalten sich ähnlich wie am Tresen über ihr liebstes Hobby. Und das klappt mit Fans wunderbar. Und das klappt natürlich, wenn dann ein, ich sag's mal offizieller, ob es jetzt aus der Chefetage ist oder ob es ein Spieler ist, ist dann erst mal relativ egal. Also ein Vertreter des Vereins dabei ist. Dann merkst du schon immer so in dieser ersten halben Stunde, also die meisten haben keine Folge vorher gehört, die wissen also nicht so richtig, worauf sie sich da einlassen. Und die tauen dann auf. Und da hat, glaube ich, dieses Reden über die drei Spiele immer sehr geholfen. Und das müssen wir jetzt hinkriegen, dass wir das, wenn wir über ein Spiel reden, trotzdem schaffen. Spoiler an dieser Stelle, wir haben demnächst Sammy Allagri zu Gast. Da haben wir schon sehr drauf. Und ja, das führt dann natürlich dazu, dass irgendwie, vielleicht auch nach dem zweiten Bier, man tatsächlich in so einer Kumpel-Atmosphäre da sitzt. Und dann werden halt Sendungen auch mal länger. Und wie gesagt, Ewald kam rein mit der Ansage, länger als 90 sowieso nicht, im Idealfall 60. Gebraucht haben wir dann 120. Da habe ich dann mehr oder weniger abgebrochen, weil ich an ihn gedacht habe und seine Zeit mich überstrapazieren wollte. Und jetzt kommen wir zu der Badesaalstäube zurück. In dem Moment, wo wir alle gesagt haben, super, danke, fertig, Cut, steht Ewald, nein, steht ein Mensch, den wir jetzt nicht benennen wollen, auf und reißt das Kabel aus dem Dekoder. Die Aufnahme war weg. Und es war wirklich, seit wir angefangen haben, war dieser Traum, wir machen eine Folge mit Evaline. Das war unser großes Ziel. Das hatten wir dann erreicht. In dem Moment geht die Aufnahme flüten. Und mir fiel echt alles aus dem Gesicht. Erstmal war es Sebastian, der da saß und der bei uns die Technik machte, der da saß und wir saßen wirklich, wie er leich und blass wurde, während Eval schnell mal eben auf Kronen. Und als der dann wieder kam, sagte er, Sebastian, ich glaube, wir haben ein Problem. Und wir haben dann zwei Tage gebraucht, um diese Datei zu rekonstruieren. Eval sagte dann in dem Moment, ach Mensch, das war so super hier. Ich weiß auch noch genau, was ich gesagt habe, wir machen das jetzt einfach gleich nochmal. Das auch so ein bisschen zu diesem Setting, dass die Leute sich da dann hoffentlich wohlfühlen. Und das ist halt das, was ich auch wirklich dann nur an Vereine wie Antwerp Frankfurt weitergeben kann. Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendeinen Vereinspodcast gibt, einen Fernpodcast, der dem Verein etwas Schlechtes angedeihen lassen würde, selbst wenn da mal Kritik kommt. Und trotzdem profitiert jeder Verein von den verschiedenen Webseiten und auch dem Vereinspodcast, die es da gibt, in welcher Form auch immer. Und deswegen wäre da mehr Unterstützung, bzw. eine ähnliche Unterstützung, wie sie uns zuteil wird, absolut wünschenswert. Und ich glaube, es wäre für jeden Verein etwas Gutes.
Amen. Hoffen wir, dass der ein oder andere Verein hier auch reinhört. Einen Aspekt würde ich gerne noch kurz mit dir besprechen. Bei euch spielt auch der Blinden- und der Frauenfußball eine Rolle. Habt ihr darauf Feedback bekommen und wie kam es eigentlich dazu? Es ist ja nicht selbstverständlich, dass man darüber auch spricht.
Ich fange mal mit dem Blindenfußball an. Das ist sehr naheliegend, weil in der Zusammensetzung, wie wir uns da beim ersten Mal getroffen haben, war auch Wolf dabei. Wolf macht seit vielen Jahren das Blindenradio beim FCVP, also die Spieltags-Live-Besprechung, die für die Blinden- und Sehbehinderten im Stadion kommentiert wird oder reportiert wird, wie er sagt. Das heißt, die sitzen auf der Gegengraben ganz oben bei den Medienplätzen und besprechen live das Spiel und es sitzen um sie herum, ich weiß nicht wie viele, ich sage jetzt mal 20, 30 Personen, die halt Kopfhörer haben und diese Besprechung von den beiden, die das meistens zusammen machen, hören. Das gibt es glaube ich inzwischen auch bei den allermeisten Vereinen. Ich meine, es sind so beiden zwischen Lizenz-Auflage, bin ich aber nicht ganz sicher. Und dementsprechend, Wolf macht nicht nur das, sondern ist auch Trainer der blinden Fußballmannschaft des FC Lankauly, die im letzten Jahr erstmals Deutscher Meister wurde. Und dementsprechend war das natürlich von Anfang an ein Bestandteil. Leider, so innerhalb des letzten Jahres, ist das bei Wolf in der Zeit ein bisschen schwierig geworden. Deswegen ist er nicht mehr so regelmäßig dabei. Wir schauen da aber natürlich trotzdem immer noch drauf. Und der Frauenfußball, ja, da hat der Frauenfußball als Erteilung beim FC St. Pauli in den letzten Jahren einen kleineren Boom gehabt mit Gipfelnd, dem Aufstieg der Mannschaft des Frauenteams in die Regionalliga, die dritte Liga im Frauenfußball. Und da ich das selber auch gerne mir angeschaut habe, hatte ich dann irgendwann auch da Kontakt zu den Spielerinnen. Und da hatten wir dann die Inga, die damals noch Kapitänin war, zweimal zu Gast. Inzwischen spielt sie in der dritten Mannschaft jetzt, oder im dritten Team, Entschuldigung, ich soll nicht Mannschaft sagen, beim Frauenfußball. Und ja, auch da gucken wir mal drauf. Wobei das natürlich auch ein bisschen dann tatsächlich auch in meine Richtung geht, weil ich ja auch immer gerne diesen Vereinsblick habe. Sprich, ich schreibe dann ja auch mal einen Artikel über die U19, die U17 und so weiter. Und da gucke ich dann auch das, was der FCN Pauli sonst so an sportgreibenden Abteilungen hat. Und da fällt sowas dann halt auch mit rein.
Über Schach habt ihr auch mal ausführlicher in einer Folge gesprochen. Die habe ich noch in Erinnerung.
Mit Jörn Kreuzer, der ist der Arbeiterinnen- und Arbeiter des FCN Pauli in der Medienabteilung. Und der war da auch ein erhörungswerter Gast.
Welche eurer vielen Folgen würdest du denn empfehlen für neue Hörerinnen und Hörer?
Also, wer einfach nur mal ein bisschen Spaß haben will, hört die Folgen mit Fabian Boll und Timo Schulz. Da kann man sehr viel lachen. Und die hört ein paar sehr angenehme Beiträge von Fußballspielern. Alle Folgen mit Spielern sind sehr hörenswert. Die mit Evaline und Gretz Rettig hatte ich schon erwähnt. Aber tatsächlich schließe ich mich klar an, das ist immer eine gute Idee, die letzte Folge zu hören. Die haben wir nämlich letzte Woche veröffentlicht. Und da haben wir uns vier Stunden mit USP unterhalten, also unserer Ultra-Gruppierung. Und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich eine Folge, die vereinsübergreifend absolut empfehlenswert ist. Und das ist kein Eigenlob, sondern es hat mit den beiden zu tun, die da waren. Das sind beide Menschen, die ich schon sehr lange kenne, seit Anfang der 2000er, und die damals USP, also die führende Ultra-Gruppierung beim FC St. Pauli, gegründet haben und bis heute dabei sind. Und ich glaube, es herrschen viele Vorurteile im Fußball Deutschland, was Ultras anbelangt. Und da werden einem in der Sendung, glaube ich, einige zumindest genommen. Man muss da auch nicht, gerade wenn es um das Thema Gewalt geht, mit allen Punkten zwingend übereinstimmen. Aber sie erklären, wie ich finde, sehr eloquent und sehr anschaulich, was da in diesen oftmals als Kindergarten verschriebenen Gruppen tatsächlich alles an Denkprozessen stattfindet. Und dass das alles schon sehr reflektierende und ihre Umwelt wahrnehmende Menschen sind, die sich ganz, ganz furchtbar viele Gedanken machen und wo nichts einfach nur so dahin gerostet wird, sondern das Allermeiste, was sie tun hat, Hand und Fuß.
Hättest du diese Folge jetzt nicht empfohlen, sie wäre auf meinem Zettel gestanden, möchte ich auch allen Hören wirklich sehr ans Herz legen. Eine sehr, sehr gute Folge. Ich habe währenddessen geputzt und habe tatsächlich dann weiter geputzt, weil ich die Folge noch fertig hören wollte. Also ihr habt auch noch was Gutes für den Zustand meines Haushalts hier getan.
Ich muss mich da gleich noch einklinken, Mike. Ich bin auch jemand, da kommen wir später wahrscheinlich dazu, weniger Vereinspodcasts hört als ihr vielleicht, wobei ich, glaube ich, den Millernton vermutlich bisher mit Abstand am meisten gehört habe. Und die letzte Ausgabe von euch wollte ich eigentlich hören, weil die nach dem Derby war. Und ich wollte quasi von euch hören, wie ihr das Derby erlebt habt in Hamburg. Und dass dann natürlich noch das Thema Mythos Ultra, also die Ultra St. Pauli hinten dran kam, war quasi perfekt. Also ich habe die Sendung absolut genossen und fand sie total super.
Womit wir auch ganz galant zu Sven weitergeleitet hätten. Mike hat uns gerade schon beschrieben, wie man seine Gäste mit Bier gefügig macht und sie dann ganz viel Lust haben zu plaudern. Genau das müsste bei dir, lieber Sven, schon eingetreten sein. Du bist der Einzige, dem ich hier ein Bier anbieten konnte. Und was soll ich sagen? Ich war erfolgreich. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass du jetzt in ganz entspannter Atmosphäre uns mal erklären kannst, Lottes Erbe nennen. Was ist das und woher denn dieser verrückte Name? Ich erkenne da so eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit zu einem anderen anwesenden Podcaster.
Ja, also diese Ähnlichkeit zu einem anderen Podcast ist tatsächlich absolut ungewollt. Und bei der Namensfindung unseres Podcasts war mir das schon durchaus bewusst, dass der Name Lottes Erbenen durchaus zu nah an Kolinas Erben ist. Die Reaktionen kamen dann auch. Ist das nicht ein bisschen zu nah an Kolinas Erben?
Wer ist denn Lotte überhaupt?
Erklär das mal. Genau, uns fiel aber in dem Moment quasi fast nichts besseres ein. Denn der Name rührt her von Charlotte Lotte Specht, einer Frauenfußballpionierin aus den 30er Jahren, eine Frankfurterin, die den ersten Frauenfußballverein in Deutschland damals gegründet hat, der leider nur ein Jahr Bestand hatte. Aber sie kann ohne Zweifel in Deutschland als die Pionierin des Frauenfußballs gelten. Mit Sicherheit auch zu einer Zeit, als die Frauen vermutlich noch höhere Repressalen zu erleiden hatten als in den späteren Jahrzehnten. Dafür gebührt ihr Respekt und deswegen haben wir uns auch für den Namen entschieden, Lottes Erbenen, also um damit quasi die Spielerinnen, die dann nach ihr gekommen sind, in den Verein Fußball spielen, so ein bisschen zu würdigen, also beide Seiten. Sowohl zum einen Lotte Specht und zum anderen natürlich die Damen, die heute gegen den Ball treten.
20 Folgen habt ihr seit 2017 jetzt veröffentlicht, aber wer ist denn überhaupt Wir?
Wir, das ist natürlich noch meine wunderbare Partnerin Jule, die nicht in München sitzt, wie ich, sondern in Norddeutschland und ihres Zeichens Fan des VfL Wolfsburg ist. Frauen, urbemerkt. Und ich Fan des FC Bayern. Das heißt, in den Farben stehen wir hier an einer Seite. Lieber Max.
Zwischen uns passt kein Blatt. Ich habe das Bier mit dir geteilt, damit sind wir quasi Brüder.
So sieht es aus. Ja und das ist meine Partnerin und das andere bin dann ich. Und meine Partnerin wird in zwei Wochen in Nürnberg sein, bei der Gala der Akademie. Und ich bin deswegen dann heute hier.
Genau, so habt ihr euch das aufgeteilt. Warum denn der Frauenfußball? Woher kommt dein Interesse dafür? Wir können vielleicht an der Stelle erwähnen, dass du auch noch ein anderes Fußballprojekt hattest.
Habe, ja zwei so.
Kick it like Asia.
Genau.
Über den Fußball im asiatischen Raum. Woher die Begeisterung für den Frauenfußball? Und warum gibt es eigentlich nur euch? Ohne, dass ich sagen wollen würde, dass es euch schlecht wäre. Aber es ist ja mindestens so interessantes Thema wie Männerfußball.
Es ist absolut. Und da kann man wahrscheinlich auch stundenlang drüber diskutieren und debattieren. Also, Frauenfußball zum einen, bei mir ist es so, ich bin, glaube ich, das erste Mal in den 80er-Jahren mit Frauenfußball in die Brunnen gekommen, als ich in der Sportschau im ZDF-Sportstudio, aber ich glaube eher so Sportschau, wo dann mal der ein oder andere Bericht gezeigt wurde von der Frauennationalmannschaft oder wo damals auch noch die Frauen ihr Pokalfinale in Berlin wurden, im Pokalfinale der Herren ausgetragen haben. Und wir als Bayern-Fans wissen es ja, der FC Bayern halt relativ oft in Berlin ist, früher dann natürlich öfters die Finals vorher gesehen und ich mir dann natürlich auch immer gewünscht hatte, wäre das nicht mal toll, die FC Bayern Frauen in Berlin vor den Herren, das wäre toll. Also das heißt, ich hatte schon relativ früh eine Berührung mit dem Frauenfußball in den 80ern im Endeffekt. Und für mich war das nie die Frage Frauenfußball, Herrenfußball oder Frauenfußball ist nichts für mich. Oder Frauen können keinen Fußball spielen. Nun bin ich im Osten groß geworden. Vielleicht bin ich auch diesbezüglich ein bisschen anders sozialisiert worden. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich wohl auch eine gewisse Rolle gespielt. Sprich Gleichberechtigung der Frau und so weiter und so fort.
Klär mich mal kurz auf, da habe ich eine eklatante Wissenslücke. Wie war es denn um den Frauenfußballen, der DDR bestellt?
Die haben für Verhältnisse auch relativ spät den Frauenfußballen angefangen. Aber Turbine Pozzam zum Beispiel, der Rekordmeister oder die Rekordmannschaft aus dem Osten. Mitte der 80er hat man dann auch einen Nationalmannschaft der DDR-Frauen ins Leben gerufen.
Was war sonst noch bei deinen Frauenfußballen? Wie du in den 80ern zum Frauenfußball gekommen bist.
Später hab ich das immer weiter verfolgt. Als ich nach München gezogen bin, war ich dann auch immer so gesagt, ich möchte gerne mal zu den FC Bayern Frauen. Die spielten aber noch in Aschheim. Da ich fünf Tage die Woche genau in dieser Ecke gearbeitet hab, hab ich mir gesagt, ich fahr nicht am Samstag noch einen 6. Tag in die Ecke. Mit dem Reizug der FC Bayern Frauen ins Grünwalder, ich hab's ja nur 10 Minuten oder wir beide relativ nah hier, war für mich klar, dass ich da mal hingehen muss. Seitdem hat sich das Ganze dann auch intensiviert. Frauen, WM und EM hab ich an sich eh immer geschaut. Und natürlich so, dass wenn du dann auch mit einem Podcast-Projekt anfängst, dass du dich dann noch weiter in die Thematik rein vertiefst. Und weißt auch, wie es ist, es entwickelt sich so ein gewisser Sog. Man lässt sich dann auch gerne da reinziehen und tiefer reinziehen. Und so entwickelt man da einfach dann noch so eine etwas höhere Affinität. Auch durchaus Verbundenheit zu dem Ganzen.
Wenn ich das richtig interpretiert habe, Rüdiger, so ist das ja auch ein bisschen euer Ansatz beim Brennerpass, dass ihr euch bewusst den Frauenfußball noch dazu genommen habt als Thema und euch jetzt da so ein bisschen reinarbeitet, Folge für Folge.
Genau, wir haben uns ja immer in unserem gesellschaftspolitischen Teil des Brennerpasses haben wir auch durchaus immer so ein bisschen feministische Meinungen vertreten oder uns dafür ausgesprochen, darüber gesprochen. Und irgendwann haben wir gesagt, es geht ja nicht mehr, dass wir das tun, ohne nicht auch mal was zum Frauenfußball zu sagen, uns da reinzuarbeiten. Und das, im Grunde genommen tun wir das gerade. So, dass wir beide eigentlich wenig darüber wissen. Aber jetzt, wir gucken jetzt und wir machen das jetzt. Und wir arbeiten uns da rein. Und es gefällt uns gut, was wir sehen.
Ich finde das ehrlich gesagt sehr nobel. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass viel mehr Leute genau diese Herangehensweise haben, wie...
Ja, es macht Spaß. Es ist auch lustig, wie schnell das geht, so dass man so seine Lieblinge kriegt und sich so Spielerinnen rausguckt und Sachen. Und für eine, die man anfängt, denkt, da gucke ich das nächste Mal genauer hin. Das macht Spaß.
Es ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache, gerade weil du gesagt hast, dass ihr sehr viel feministische Themen auch herangehensweise in eurem Podcast habt. Es ist halt zum Beispiel etwas, was mir auffällt, zum Beispiel in meinem Bekanntenkreis, die Leute, die alle ja auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, moderat sind, moderat dem Thema gegenüberstehen und auch sehr offen gegenüberstehen. Gleichzeitig aber, wenn es um das Thema Frauenfußball geht, eigentlich damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben wollen. Das ist total putzig. Es sind sehr viele, die sind für das Durchgändern und für Profeminismus in einem gewissen Rahmen und für Gleichberechtigung und so weiter und so fort. Aber die eigene Frauenfußballabteilung des Vereins, den sie eigentlich unterstützen, nee, kann ich nicht, will ich nicht. Das finde ich immer sehr merkwürdig. Ist aber auch etwas, wo wir bei Lottes Erbenen das auf unserem Zettel stehen haben, dem wir gerne mal nachgehen möchten. Unter anderem zum Beispiel auch, warum gibt es, also beim Millerton hat man das ja gehört, da auch bei dem Thema Ultras ging es ja auch um Frauen bei den Ultras. Warum, zum Beispiel, so fällt es mir auf, gibt es sehr viele Frauen bei den Herren-Teams, die dann auch bei den Ultras mit dabei sind, vielleicht auch als Vorsänger. Witzigerweise gibt es das aber beim Frauenfußball nicht. Ich finde es total spannend und interessant, diesem Thema mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise nachzugehen, warum das so ist.
Wie ist denn da die bisherige Resonanz? Ist es einfacher, Feedback von Vereinen zu bekommen, eventuell auch an handelnde Personen ranzukommen, für eine Podcast-Aufnahme einfach, weil das Grundrauschen in der Berichterstattung über Frauenfußball eben so viel kleiner ist als beim Männerfußball?
Ja und nein. Also grundsätzlich ist es... Manche Sachen sind durchaus einfacher für uns. Aber...
Kannst du da ein Beispiel nennen?
Ja, zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt unter anderem, eben für Lottes Erbin auch, ich habe eine Jahresakreditierung bei den FC Bayern Frauen. Das heißt, wir können also in meiner Person, als der auch noch fotografiert, als Fotograf, quasi macht das so zwei Sachen in einem. Ich kann da quasi dabei sein, das gilt dann auch noch für andere Sachen. Das macht es sicherlich etwas einfacher, an vielleicht... offizielle ranzukommen. Aber zum Beispiel haben wir im letzten Jahr eine Umfrage gemacht an die Vereine, weil wir haben sie angeschrieben, haben gefragt, wir haben die Webseiten durchgecheckt und haben dann geschaut, okay, wie schaut es aus mit behindertengerechten Zugängen? Wie sieht es aus mit den Eintrittspreisen? Gibt es Dauerkarten? Was kosten die? Und so weiter und so fort. Und haben die Vereine angeschrieben. Und es gab zum Beispiel, glaube ich, zwei Vereine, die ich auch angeschrieben hatte. Und da habe ich zum Beispiel auch, das waren zwei Vereine, direkt angeschrieben und hatte zum Beispiel eine spezielle Frage. Habe ich keine Antwort bekommen. Und witzigerweise, vom Verein, wo ich mich schwergetan habe, eine Kontakt-E-Mail-Adresse für den Frauenbereich zu finden.
Weil die sich gefreut haben, dass das mal jemand gefunden hat.
Werder Bremen zum Beispiel war ein so ein Ding, wo man halt sagt, es ist ein großer Fußballverein. Und jetzt schreibe ich da einfach mal an eine Info-Ad irgendwas, ob ich da eine Antwort bekomme. Und wir haben dann tatsächlich da von Vereinen, wo ich das nicht erwartet hätte, von den größeren Fußballvereinen, haben wir tatsächlich auch eine Antwort bekommen. Bei kleineren, witzigerweise, die haben uns noch nicht mal geantwortet, die haben uns gleich irgendwie total ignoriert. Allerdings, wie gesagt, das waren wir auch am Anfang gewesen. Vielleicht wird es jetzt im Laufe der Zeit irgendwann mal besser.
Dazu würde ich auch noch gerne was hinzufügen. Also als wir die Gesprächsstunde gemacht haben, war es uns natürlich eigentlich sehr wichtig, dass wir genauso viele Frauen wie Männer als Gäste einladen. Und uns ist aufgefallen, es war wahnsinnig schwer, an Gesprächspartnerinnen heranzukommen, ob es jetzt Journalistinnen, Historikerinnen oder andere Filmemacherinnen oder Expertinnen sind. Einzig bei dem Film Offside, wo es ja um Frauenfußball ging, da haben wir tatsächlich zwei Frauen und nur einen Mann gefunden.
Interessant.
Kann ich vielleicht auch an der Stelle schon mal vorgreifen? Ich habe ja im Rasenfunk auch das Ziel einer 50-50-Quote, beziehungsweise bei den Gästen. Also 50-50 wird es allein deswegen schon schwierig, weil ich eben ein Typ bin und ich habe in der Regel zwei Gäste. Aber bei jeder Schlusskonferenz schicke ich die erste Anfrage, die rausgeht, ist immer eine Frau, ein Mann. Und trotzdem, jeder, der den Rasenfunk ein bisschen verfolgt, weiß, ich bin von dieser Quote noch weit entfernt, weil die Grundmenge an Menschen, die man fragen kann, geringer ist. Auch wenn ich da versuche, die Augen weitestmöglich aufzuhalten und immer wieder auch Podcasts nicht affine Frauen einzuladen. Aber man findet eben schwieriger welche. Und tatsächlich gibt es auch mehr Absagen, die auch eher so in eine Richtung gehen. Ich traue mir das eigentlich gar nicht zu, so sehr über einen Spieltag zu sprechen, wo ich die Person bei Twitter schon seit Jahren sehe und sage, ganz ehrlich, du verstehst locker so viel.
Aber da kannst du doch vielleicht diesen Frauen sagen, guck mal, der Rüdiger Rudolf beim Brennerpass macht es doch auch.
Stimmt, das werde ich jetzt in Zukunft sagen.
Aber witzigerweise haben wir zum Beispiel, ich meine, das Spannende, was ich bei uns finde, ist ja, dass wir als Duo quasi einmal männlich, einmal weiblich sind, dass wir beide auch relativ unterschiedlich sind. Und dass wir bei unseren Gästen, ich glaube, ungefähr, so viele hatten wir noch nicht, aber es hält sich ungefähr die Waage zwischen Frauen und Männern. Das bin ich halt in der Unterzahl, mal ist es dann Jule in der Unterzahl. Aber wir haben da eigentlich bisher auch relativ viel Glück gehabt. Und es gibt auch noch sehr, sehr viele Frauen, die wir auf unserer Liste haben, wo wir gerne bei uns in die Sendung einladen möchten oder wo wir uns auch ein Special vorstellen können zu einem bestimmten Thema. Eins kommt dann hoffentlich demnächst zustande, dank Kulinas Erben. Also da haben wir komischerweise nicht so das Problem. Allerdings musst du natürlich auch pro Sendung ein paar mehr Gäste auftreiben als wir. Und sie sind immer nur eine.
Also es wäre ja auch schon ein bisschen komisch, wenn gerade im Frauenfußball keine Gesprächspartnerinnen zu finden sein würden.
Richtig, wobei da wiederum die meisten mehr im journalistischen Bereich tätig sind als im Fans. Das ist das, was ihr vorher ansprach.
Aber ich kann da auch freuen, dass wir dieses Phänomen gibt's in allen Bereichen. Da sind Männer, die sagen, kannst du über Atomphysik eine halbe Stunde sprechen? Klar, kein Problem, mache ich sofort. Und Frauen sind da nicht so, dass sie einfach auch so nach draußen gehen und das Selbstbewusstsein einfach haben, sondern haben da mehr Sorge. Und ich kann das auch verstehen, weil man muss sich nur manchmal die Zuschauerpost angucken, die gerade im Sportbereich Journalistin bekommen. Die ist also ich verspreche mich selbst im Radio. Da kommt nichts, auch wenn ich Oliver Löw im Deutschlandfonds sage und wenn eine Kollegin ein Ergebnis irgendwie falsch sagt, dann gibt es direkt Post. Das ist schon ein gesellschaftliches Problem leider.
Wolltest du dann noch mal ganz kurz auf die Frage vom Max zurückkommen, wo du gefragt hast, warum Frauenfußball auch? Ein Grund ist natürlich auch, dass ich, dass wenn man sich mit der Thematik beschäftigt und das tun wir ja auch in unseren Podcasts, wo wir halt nicht nur quasi Berichten erzählen, sondern wo wir halt auch wirklich Informationen teilweise dann weitergeben, die man jetzt so vielleicht nicht unbedingt, wenn man es nicht aktiv konsumiert und sich nicht aktiv damit beschäftigt, bekommt und so ein bisschen Einblick darin bekommt, wo es eigentlich in der Welt des Frauenfußballs noch hakt. Und da sieht man dann auch erst mal, dann wenn man sich mit der Materie beschäftigt, wie viel Mädels und Frauen, die eigentlich nur ihren Lieblingssport ausüben möchten, wie viel sie im Gegensatz zu Herren und Jungs eigentlich aufopfern. Das finde ich immer wieder absolut faszinierend. Also das fängt natürlich beim Körperbau an, der nicht ganz so ist wie beim Männern. Das heißt, die Verletzungen sind häufiger, meistens sind es auch immer zwei, drei Kreuzbandrisse. Die meisten sind Halbprofis oder Amateure. Das heißt, sie gehen zur Schule, sie machen ihre Ausbildung, sie studieren, sie gehen berufnah, trainieren trotzdem noch...
Ohne die Aussicht auf Millionen.
Ohne die Aussicht auf Millionen, exakt. Und diese Leidenschaft, die die Frauen eben da auch reinstecken in das Spiel, in ihren Sport, finde ich sehr, sehr bewundernswert und ist auch etwas, was wir mit dem Podcast transportieren wollen. Und auch so ein bisschen, ja, für die sich vielleicht nicht so wirklich ständig damit beschäftigen, ein bisschen so, wie soll man sagen, darauf aufmerksam zu machen, wo es eigentlich wirklich denn im Frauenfußball auch hakt gegenüber dem Männerfußball, wo sehr, sehr vieles als eigentlich gegeben ist.
Ja, dann sag uns mal, ich könnte ewig über dieses Thema sprechen, ich verknife mir alle Fragen, gerade auch, was das Geschlechteverhältnis in den Journalisten-Bereichen bei Männer- und beim Frauenfußball umgeht. Das finde ich nämlich gar nicht so bedingungslos gut, hat nämlich auch viel mit etablierten Strukturen in Redaktionen zu tun. Sag uns mal, mit welcher Folge sollte man denn beginnen, wenn man jetzt mal bei Lottes Abern reinhören möchte?
Man könnte mit unserer Rasenfunk-Esken letzten aktuellen Folge anfangen, zum Beispiel weil das unsere Bundesliga-Vorschau auf die jetzt schon laufende Saison ist, die knapp über drei Stunden geht. Solange wollen wir da nicht noch mal werden.
Mich hat es nicht gestört, also mir gerne.
Ansonsten, unser Special, was wir zum Beispiel hatten mit Christoph Hetzer zum Thema Fernsehkommentator, wie wird man Fernsehkommentator, ist auch sehr hörenswert. Also ich ertappe mich selber auch immer wieder dabei, wenn ich Folgen von uns nachhöre, ich die dann einfach durchhöre und sag mir, hey, das war jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, oder ich hatte es eigentlich schlechter in Erinnerung. Prinzipiell, da wo wir Gäste hatten, die waren meistens relativ gut. Ansonsten bettelt die Jule und ich sonst immer nur wegen Wolfsburg und Bayern. Das will dann auch keiner hören.
Ja, und das ging ja auch zu eindeutig aus.
Das ging leider auch zu eindeutig.
6 zu 0 war da doch ein bisschen deutlich pro Wolfsburg. Aber das wissen natürlich alle Hörerinnen und Hörer schon. Und wer nicht, dann hören Sie jetzt bitte Lottes Erbenen. Zwei Podcasts haben wir noch, die auf der Shortlist der Akademie der Fußballkultur stehen. Und den nächsten können wir kurz abhören, denn es ist der Rasenfunk. Und den hört ihr gerade, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich hoffe einfach, dass er euch dann damit auch schon geläufig ist. Wir haben drei Formate. Das Tribünengespräch hört ihr gerade. Da geht es um zeitlose Themen. Auch wenn wir heute auch mal kurz aktuelle Themen wie die Einverleibung des FFC Frankfurt bei Eintracht Frankfurt behandelt haben. Es gibt den Kurzpass. Das ist unser kürzeres Format für alles Mögliche. Da spreche ich auch häufig inzwischen mit Gästen über internationale Ligen. Und es gibt die Schlusskonferenz. Da reden wir über den Bundesligaspieltag. Das sind die drei Formate des Rasenfunks. Und es war uns ein großes Vergnügen, auch mit auf dieser Shortlist stehen zu dürfen.
Aber wenn jetzt jemand kommt und hat noch nie den Rasenfunk gehört, welche Folge würdest du denn dann empfehlen, Max?
Ganz einfach, Schlusskonferenz.
Gar nicht so einfach tatsächlich. Deswegen habe ich mich auch so schwergetan, was wir eingereicht haben beim Podcast-Preis. Also die namhafteste von der Besetzung her war die mit Matthias Sammer und Jan Henkel und da wird auch glaube ich viel klar von dem, wie wir im Rasenfunk so ticken, also in welcher Art und Weise wir über Fußball sprechen wollen. Da war der Gast fantastisch, der Moderator hatte allerdings nicht seinen besten Tag, das bin in dem Fall ich. Deswegen habe ich die auch zum Beispiel nicht eingereicht. Ja, vielleicht die oder ein beliebiges Tribünengespräch. Ich finde, die Tribünengespräche sind gute Anhaltspunkte. Da sollte von den Themen, da gibt es jetzt 25, eingeschlossen dieses Tribünengesprächs, da mal kurz durchscrollen und sich dann in das reinklicken, was einem vom Thema irgendwie anspricht. Ist vielleicht ein guter Start. Aber hast du mich tatsächlich auf den kalten Fuß erwischt? Gut gemacht, Klaas. Ah, Olli, sehr gut. Das bin ich, Max Ost, Genetzer und vor allem Frank Helmschrott, der Ed Helmi, der vorhin schon erwähnt wurde. Der Frank ist nicht so häufig und gerne vor Mikrofon zu hören. Das Bezieht sich aber nur an seine Innenperspektive, die Außenperspektive aller Leute, die ich kenne, mich eingeschlossen. Ich würde ihn gern viel häufiger hören. Er kümmert sich vor allem um die Infrastruktur. Wir haben eine, wie ich finde, tolle Homepage. Das kann ich vor allem deswegen so sagen, weil Frank die gemacht hat, weil die einfach ganz großartig ist. Und ich da nicht mich lobe, sondern ihn, das hat eine ganz tolle Homepage, die er programmiert hat. Immer wenn etwas technisch nicht funktioniert, dann ist Frank der Go-To-Guy. Inhaltlich sprechen wir uns vor eigentlich jeder wichtigen Folge ab. Wir sprechen uns, welches Thema als nächstes kommt. Er hat mich ganz oft schon an den richtigen Stellen eingepremst. Bei den richtigen Stellen aber auch gesagt, jetzt sei nicht so zurückhaltend, mach das jetzt einfach mal und guck, wie es wird. Und auch das ganze Finanzierungsmodell und wie sich das alles entwickelt hat, das wäre ohne Frank undenkbar gewesen. 314 Folgen haben wir gemacht.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich dein WM-Projekt ziemlich cool fand. Das hab ich gerne gehört und ihr werdet mich jetzt auch alle auslachen, weil ich, wenn ich sage, dass ich eher so kürzere Podcasts höre, insbesondere wenn ich auch bei 120 Minuten sehr lange Texte schreibe und publiziere.
Es folgt schon einer inhärenten Logik.
Ja, genau. Aber das WM-Projekt, das fand ich zum täglichen Anhören auch eine sehr schöne Länge. Beispielhaft ist mir die Folge mit Peter Ahrens in Erinnerung geblieben. Aber es waren viele gute Folgen, aber die fällt mir als erstes ein. Wenn ich was vom Rasenfunk empfehlen müsste, wäre das das, was ich sagen würde.
Freut mich sehr. WM war auch das, was uns im Finanzierungsmodell, im Spendenmodell über die Klippe geschifft hat. Und hoffentlich fallen wir nicht wieder zurück. Schiefes Bild jetzt mit der Klippe fällt mir gerade auf. Ja, René hat das auch so gesehen. Ich würde sagen, das soll es gewesen sein. Zum Rasenfunk alles andere könnte man auch nachlesen, wenn es einen wirklich interessierte. Wir haben jetzt noch einen Podcast, der sich noch nicht selbst vorgestellt hat und der leider auch nicht in dieser Runde vertreten ist. Denn die beiden Jungs wollten nur zu zweit machen. Sie haben gesagt, zwischen uns passt kein anderes Mikro. Wir können uns nicht trennen. Und deswegen nehmen die Jungs vom Trikot-Austausch jetzt als Audio-Nachricht teil. Ich habe sie gebeten, zu sagen, warum gibt es euch? Was kann man bei euch hören? Und warum lohnt es sich bei euch reinzuhören? Und deswegen ist es auch für euch, liebe hier anwesenden Gäste, sehr, sehr interessant. Sie stellen uns am Ende ihrer Vorstellung auch noch zwei Fragen. Und damit könnten wir dann so ein bisschen in die Diskussion über die Fußballpodcastlandschaft im Jahr 2018 eintreten. Also laußen wir jetzt alle mal, was uns Klaus und Flo vom Trikot-Austausch-Podcast zu sagen haben.
Ein herzliches Servus.
Grüß euch.
Und hallo aus Österreich.
Wir sind Klaus.
Und Florian.
Und gemeinsam machen wir den Trikot-Austausch, einen Podcast über Fußballtrikots, Fußballkultur und Geschichten rund um den Fußball.
Der Trikot-Austausch-Podcast ist aus einer, in Wien würde man sagen, leidenschaftlichen Schnoppsidee entstanden. Klaus und ich kennen uns schon sehr lange und haben gemeinsam viele Jahre in einer Sportredaktion, einer österreichischen Wochenzeitung gearbeitet. Im Laufe unserer Zusammenarbeit haben wir dann festgestellt, dass wir nicht nur ein gemeinsames Interesse am aktuellen Fußball geschehen haben, sondern vor allem auch an der Geschichte und den Geschichten rund um den Fußball.
Und dass wir beide seit Jahren schon insgeheim Trikots sammeln und in unseren Kleiderschränken halten. Aber im Ernst, wir sind der Meinung, dass die Trikots eine Art Aushängeschild des Fußballs sind und gewisse Geschichten erzählen. Und genau diese Anekdoten und Stories, sowie die gesamte Kultur, die sich rund um den Fußball gebildet hat und ihn neben dem Sportlichen selbst ausmacht, rückt für uns in den Vordergrund.
Weil wir uns nicht nur in der Redaktion, sondern auch privat viel und gerne darüber unterhalten haben, wollten wir diese Leidenschaft irgendwann auch dann nach außen tragen. Und als langjähriger Podcast-Afficionado kam mir dann die Idee, die Thematik als Podcast umzusetzen. Als begeisterter Musiker, der seine Musik immer gerne selbst aufgenommen und produziert hat, war zumindest die equipmenttechnische Hürde leicht zu meistern. Und wir haben dann einfach an einem Nachmittag losgelegt.
Ja, und seit knapp eineinhalb Jahren gibt es seither wöchentlich eine neue Folge des Trikot-Austauschs. Jetzt könnte man meinen, unser Podcast bewegt sich sehr in der Nische. Und ja, Trikot-Designs sind bestimmt kein Mainstream-Thema. Aber unser Ansicht nach ist das Thema dennoch in unserem Lieblingssport sehr präsent. Von den technischen Errungenschaften, von der Baumwolle zu Multifunktionsstört, über die Auswüsterkämpfe bis hin zu den immer mehr werdenden leidenschaftlichen Sammlern und den berühmten Trikot-Austausch zwischen Spielern. Apropos Trikot-Austausch, wir gehen da mit dem Namen unseres Podcasts einfach einen Schritt weiter auf die sprachliche Ebene zum Trikot-Austausch und tauschen uns also im Gespräch miteinander oder unseren Gästen über Fußballdressen aus. Über schöne Designs und die Geschichten hinter den Trikots, beziehungsweise wie es in Österreich heute so schön heißt, den Leib an.
In jeder Folge präsentieren wir, passend natürlich zum Thema, unsere persönlichen Top 5 Trikots und zerpflücken diese Auswahl natürlich bis ins Detail.
Ja, und neben den Designs, bei denen wir, je nach Haus, Österreich oder Land, immer wieder unterschiedliche Perlen unter Anführungszeichen finden, überrascht auch auf uns selber, welches Tor es sich zu finden. Von schräg über amüsant bis tragisch traurig. Und deshalb lohnt es sich eigentlich auch einmal bei uns reinzuhören.
Zum Abschluss hätten wir noch zwei Fragen an die Runde.
Zum einen, da wir ja der einzige Podcast aus Österreich in dieser illustrieren Runde sind, habt ihr bei euch schon einmal einen Bezug zu Österreich hergestellt oder die Alpenrepublik, wie wir ja nicht genannt werden, in Folgen behandelt? Und welche Verbindungen habt ihr zum Thema Fußball in Österreich? Bzw. ist österreichischer Fußball für euch als Thema überhaupt interessant?
Abschließend, nach dem Höhenflug der letzten Jahre hört man inzwischen schon leise anklingen, dass der Podcast-Boom ein Ende findet. Wie seht ihr das? Ist ein Ende in Sicht? Hat sich das Medium Podcast auch im Themenbereich Fußball bereits etabliert? Oder stehen wir erst am Beginn von einer großen Entwicklung? Wie können Podcasts auch aus der Themennische heraus mehr Reichweite entwickeln? Und wie kann man das Hobby-Podcast zu einem Nebenberuf oder vielleicht gar zur Hauptberufung ausbauen?
Wir sagen Danke an den Rasenfunk für die Einladung und dass wir uns in dieser Spezialfolge präsentieren durften. Außerdem natürlich ein Dankeschön an alle Teilheimen-Podcasts, dass ihr uns mit so tollen Folgen und Inhalten versorgt und uns dadurch große Surfer-Gnüge bereitet.
Sportliche Grüße und ein herzliches Gutschert aus dem schönen St. Pölten in Österreich vom Trikot-Austausch.
Das waren sie, die beiden Jungs vom Trikot-Austausch, im schönsten Idiom, das hier in der Runde vertreten ist. Ich hoffe, ich trete damit niemandem hier zu nahe. Aber ich liebe es, diesen Jungs zuzuhören. Es ist, als würde man in Karamell baden.
Ich habe direkt auf Abonnieren gedrückt.
Völlig zurecht, Klaas. Wobei ich da auch die Frage stellen möchte, wie kann man Fußball und Macht kennen und den Trikot-Austausch nicht? Ich dachte, du bist der, der alles kennt.
Ist das in deiner Pod-Rolle? Natürlich.
Ich habe das sogar schon in der Schlusskonferenz empfohlen.
Ich muss zugeben, ich habe Trikot-Austausch auch tatsächlich erst im Zusammenhang mit der Preisvergabe von der Deutschen Fußballakademie wahrgenommen und habe da natürlich auch gleich reingehört, weil Trikots, bin auch großer Fan von Trikots, vermutlich alle, und finde es auch ganz großartig, was die zwei Jungs da machen.
Absolut. Sie leiden natürlich ein bisschen unter der Beschränktheit des akustischen Mediums. Man kann die besprochenen Trikots immer nur auf Facebook sehen. Das wäre in einer idealen Welt ein bisschen anders gestaltet, vielleicht sogar als Videoformat. Aber wenn ich zwei Folgen empfehlen darf an der Stelle, die mir sehr große Freude bereitet haben. Das sind beides sehr frühe Folgen, da bin ich auf den Trikot-Austausch aufmerksam geworden. Die Folge zu Torhüttertrikots ist sensationell, weil Torhüttertrikots sensationell sind. Es liegt einfach so nahe. Und dann gibt es auch zwei Folgen, beziehungsweise inzwischen sind es sogar schon vier, zu der Bundesliga in den 90ern, eben nur aus Trikotsicht. Unglaublich toll. Man hat das dann auch schnell wieder vor Augen. Man merkt, wie sehr ein Trikot eigentlich prägt. Dann hört man den beiden Jungs einfach wahnsinnig gerne zu. Die reden einfach sehr interessant und unglaublich fundiert. Am Anfang dachte ich mir, wie weit wird dieses Thema tragen? Jetzt haben die seit 2017 65 Folgen produziert. Ich komme mir überhaupt nicht mehr nach mit dem Hören. Absolut fasziniert.
Ich mag besonders die nerdigen Folgen von den Jungs. Diverse Länder aus Asien, wo sich die Trikots durchgehen, mag ich sehr gerne, bedingt durch meine Affinität auch zum asiatischen Fußball.
Also sehr empfehlenswert. Hört den Trikot-Austausch. Und vielleicht können sich ja mal Mike und René drum bewerben, dass sie da eine Vereinsfolge mit den Jungs zusammen machen. In euren eigenen Formaten oder ihr geht in den Trikot-Austausch. Das könnte ich mir sehr, sehr gut vorstellen. Einfach mal alle Trikots von Eintracht Frankfurt. Da gab es ja auch so manche interessante Geschichte.
Und natürlich alle Schiedsrichter-Trikots. Ich glaube, der Mode-Podcast Nr. 1, der wir nun mal sind mit Kolinas Erben.
Was sagt eigentlich Mode-Podcast Nr.
2 dazu? Aber dann sollten aber auch alle im Trikot da sitzen.
Natürlich.
Wir nehmen immer im Trikot auf.
Klaas hat sogar immer ein kleines Fähnchen mit dabei.
Ja, wie die Schiedsrichter im Kölner Keller ist, doch klar.
Absolut, die Podcast-Dienstkleidung. Also der Trikot-Austausch von Klaus und Flo völlig zurecht, auch auf der Shortlist dieses Preises. Es gab noch ganz, ganz viele tolle Einsendungen, die es nicht geschafft haben. Gott sei Dank haben wir mit der Entscheidung nichts zu tun. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Jury das vor ihrem Gewissen rechtfertigen kann, so manchen anderen Podcaster weggelassen zu haben. Es ist vermutlich einfach die Natur der Sache eines solchen Preises. Aber aus diesen 45 Einsendungen waren das jetzt eben die besprochenen Podcasts, die auf der Shortlist stehen und aus denen sich dann eben auch der Gewinner glücklich schätzen durfte. Was uns aber ja ein bisschen zu den beiden Fragen bringt, die beide hatten, ich wollte diese Folge ja auch ein bisschen als Update zu der 2015 aufgezeichneten Folge machen, wo wir damals schon über Fußballpodcasts gesprochen haben. Und ich würde gerne die beiden Fragen von Klaus und Flo als Einstieg in die Diskussion nehmen. Bin gespannt, wie viel Luft ihr dafür jetzt noch habt. Aber hey, ihr seid alle Podcast-Profis, ihr kriegt das hin. Und ihr wusstet, worauf ihr euch zu eingelassen habt. Ich habe hier neben mir jemanden stehen gehabt, der hat bei der ersten Frage den Finger gehoben. Und das war die, in der die Bezug zu Österreich gestellt wurde. Welchen Bezug haben wir zu Österreich? Wie nehmen wir den österreichischen Fußball? Was, wenn du das damit...
Beziehungsweise wie er eventuell in den Podcasts vorkommt. Und das war bei uns schon der Fall, also zweimal schon. Wir haben bei Lotus Erwin schon zweimal über den Fußball in Österreich gesprochen. Das heißt, wir hatten zwei Gäste. Einmal Nicole Selmer vom Ballesterer. Und dann den Philipp Eitzinger von Ballverliebt. Und wir haben da beide Male auch über den Frauenfußball in Österreich gesprochen. Vor allem natürlich auch in Hinblick nach dem letztjährigen Erfolg bei der Frauen-EM der Österreicherinnen. Und natürlich auch, weil einfach viele Österreicherinnen in Deutschland in der Frauenbundesliga spielen. Und letztes Wochenende erst das Länderspiel Deutschland-Österreich in Essen. Da waren 22 Spielerinnen in der, logisch, Startelf. Und 21 davon haben in Deutschland in der Bundesliga gespielt. Also ist das für uns auf jeden Fall definitiv ein Thema. Sam Pölten, Wien ist ja auch jetzt nicht so weit von uns weg hier von München. Und ich habe zum Beispiel auch immer noch auf dem Plan, irgendwann mal, wenn Sam Pölten vielleicht mal die erste Runde in der Champions League der Frauen überstehen sollte und nicht ständig irgendwie PSG oder Manchester City zu groß bekommt, auch mal nach Sam Pölten zu fahren, um mir dort die Frauen in der Champions League anzuschauen, aber vielleicht auch mal in der Bundesliga.
Ich kann vielleicht auch was dazu sagen. Also wir haben zwar leider keinen Film zu Österreich in unserer Filmreihe gehabt, aber wir hatten wenigstens einen österreichischen Journalisten als Gast da, und zwar Bert Rebhandl, der Journalist ist und gleichzeitig auch Filmkritiker. Und zwar zu einem interessanten Film, nämlich Second Game, ein Film über Ceausescu's Rumänien 1988. Und das Krasse ist, man sieht in den ganzen 90 Minuten diesen verschneiten Fernseher, also einen alten Fernseher, in dem das Fußballspiel von 1988 gezeigt wird. Alles so ein bisschen verschneit, man kann eigentlich gar nicht so viel sehen. Und man hört, wie der Regisseur sich mit seinem Vater unterhält. Und das Verrückte ist, dass der Vater nämlich bei diesem Spiel als Schiedsrichter gespielt hat oder mitgemacht hat. Und das Spannende ist natürlich auch, was natürlich auch unsere Frage war, welche Rolle hatten eigentlich Schiedsrichter im Kommunismus beim Fußball? Also vielleicht so ein kleiner Hinweis, was auch noch spannend ist bei uns.
Und ich sehe da Querverstrebungen zu Kolinas Abend. Wann gibt es das Special Klaas zu den österreichischen Schiedsrichtern?
Ist alles in Arbeit.
Gut, Klaas kriegt keine Frage mehr gestellt. Das wird mir jetzt so trocken und so kurz beantwortet. Damit kann ich nicht umgehen. Hat jemand von euch noch einen besonderen Österreich-Bezug? Ich möchte auf die Frage noch eingehen, bevor wir über den Podcast-Boom sprechen.
Ja, wir hier 120 Minuten. Wir werden nächste Woche, wenn ich das richtig auf dem Zettel habe, genau, zumindest mal eine Folge gemeinsam mit dem Ballester aufnehmen, wo es um Vorwärtssteier geht.
Ja, sehr gut.
So viel unser Beitrag zu Österreich.
Und der Brennerpass ruft jedes Mal, wenn ein Ball gegen den Pfosten trifft. Und wir mögen sehr gerne die Nachspielzeit. Eine Facebook-Seite eines österreichischen Kabarettisten, wo er sehr lustige Spieler-Interviews neu synchronisiert, falls das jemand kennt. Das ist eine Empfehlung.
Natürlich aus der Popkultur, so wie es sein muss.
Irritiert mich jetzt, weil unser Podcast ja auch die Nachspielzeit heißt. Aber nun ja, das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht so.
Oder habe ich mit als Fantan im Namen? Also ich glaube, es heißt Nachspielzeit.
Das mag schon sein.
Recherchiere, während ihr weiterredet.
Wahrscheinlich im Fußball auch ein eher ideenloser Einfall, Sachen so zu nennen.
Ach ja, andere Leute nennen ihr Format Schlusskonferenz. Also da würde ich mich jetzt nicht zu selbst kasteien, zu sehr selbst kasteien, würde ich nicht machen. Gut, dass der Brennerpass einen Österreich-Bezug hat, hat ja allein schon mit den Namen wahrscheinlich zu tun. Ha ha, dieser kleine riesige...
Wir sind die Brücke zum Österreichischen.
Aber man muss keine Maulzahlen, um euren Podcast zu hören. An der Stelle kann man vielleicht auch ganz kurz schon mal vor skippen in die Podcast-Empfehlung. Die Stadionsprechstunde befasst sich mit dem österreichischen Fußball. Kann ich an der Stelle empfehlen. Es gab auch schon hin und wieder mal Nachfragen, ob es in einem Kurzpass mal eine Rolle spielen kann, die österreichische Liga durchaus. Das ist auch in der Mache. Sobald Kolinas Abend vorgelegt hat, mit ihrem Schiedsrichter-Podcast nur zu Österreich, wird dann der Rasenfunk natürlich nachziehen.
Und bitte nochmal prüfen, ob du ballverliebt auch in der Portrulla ist.
Natürlich ist ballverliebt mit drin. Kommst du in mein Haus, trinkst mein Bier und beleidigt mich auf diese Art und Weise.
Er hatte doch nur ein halbes Bier, ihr habt doch geteilt.
Wenn Bayern Bier teilen, dann ist das anders gemeint. Das kommt sogar dann fast hin. Nein, wir sind hier gut versorgt und können deswegen auch fröhlich über den Podcast-Boom sprechen, beziehungsweise die Frage, die uns die beiden Jungs gestellt haben. Sehen wir da ein Ende kommen oder wo bewegt sich die Fußball-Podcast-Landschaft hin? Und weil ich weiß, Mike, dass wir da vor ein paar Jahren, nämlich 2015, schon drüber gesprochen haben, würde ich die Frage mal erstmal an dich geben. Wir haben vor drei Jahren darüber gesprochen, wie die Fußball-Podcast-Landschaft sich geriert in Deutschland. Was würdest du seitdem für eine Entwicklung feststellen?
Also, dass der Boom abappt, kann ich zumindest nicht wahrnehmen. Im Gegenteil, ich finde Podcasts springen immer noch aus dem Boden und gerade auch im Fußballbereich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer qualitativ auch ganz was Tolles ist. Das mögen dann andere beurteilen, aber ich glaube, zumindest quantitativ ist da alles andere als ein Ende des Booms absehbar. Bei mir selber nehme ich aber zur Kenntnis, dass ich tatsächlich heute weniger Fußball-Podcasts höre als damals, was in der Erstlinie damit zu tun hängt, dass ich inzwischen andere Podcasts auf anderen Themen deutlich mehr höre. Und vielleicht hat das auch ein bisschen was mit dieser viel beschriebenen Fußballmöglichkeit zu tun. Aber grundsätzlich bleibe ich dabei, dass ich glaube, das Medium-Podcast ist immer noch eins mit sehr viel Zukunft. Ich denke, du hast es vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet, es kommen ja inzwischen auch die ganzen öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender und auch andere Unternehmen auf die Idee, ein Podcast wäre doch eine super Sache. Also ich glaube, da wird es eher noch deutlich stärker ausgebaut werden, als das zurückgeht.
Da haben wir mit Klaas ja auch jemanden hier sitzen, der vorhin schon ganz galant darauf hingewiesen hat, dass der Deutschlandfunk natürlich nicht nur über Fußball und Sport spricht, sondern auch über das Radfahren im Radfunk. Toller Name übrigens. Wie seid ihr da nur drauf gekommen?
Vielleicht wegen Deutschlandfunk, aber ist nur eine Möglichkeit.
Nee, glaube ich nicht. Kann ich nicht glauben. Klaas, als ob so Entscheidungen liefen im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Dafür hatte ich schon zu viel mit dem Bayerischen zu tun, um das zu sagen. Du warst damals auch schon mit dabei. 2015 decken sich die Eindrücke von Mike mit deinem.
Ja, also man muss ja auch immer mit diesem Wort Boom aufpassen. Den einzigen Boom gab es um diese Serial-Serie aus den USA, die halt wirklich alle Erwartungen weit weit weit übertroffen hat. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass es Medienberichterstattung gab. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass sich Medienhäuser auch mit dem Thema Podcast beschäftigt haben. Und zu unser aller Glück, würde ich sagen, gibt es mittlerweile sehr gute Podcast-Formate in allen Sprachen. Und ich glaube halt, dass viele Leute einfach die Podcasts noch gar nicht für sich entdeckt haben. Von daher wird es weiter wachsen. Viele Leute, mit denen man so redet, die sagen dann ja Podcast, ich weiß jetzt zwar, was das ist, aber ich habe es noch nicht gehört, weil ich habe da nie Zeit für. Und dann redet man mit denen und dann sagt man, wie du fährst jeden Tag eine Stunde mit der Bahn zur Arbeit, dann hör doch einfach mal Podcast. Und irgendwann sind sie ganz glücklich, dass man ihnen mal den Tipp gegeben hat. Und in ganz vielen Berufen, das ist auch die Rückmeldung, die wir bei Kolinas Erben ja bekommen, ganz vielen Berufen ist es möglich, Podcasts zu hören. Und das machen ganz viele Leute. Egal, ob das der Lokomotivführer ist, die Briefträgerin oder was weiß ich. Die hören alle Podcasts. Und ich glaube, wir brauchen keinen Boom. Also wir brauchen nicht nur die großen Hits. Aber natürlich ist da die Spitze des Icebacks jetzt gerade mal so erschienen. Ich glaube, dass sich da, das wird alles noch viel variantenreicher. Das sieht man ja gerade im Bereich Fußball. Und wenn du dann jetzt mal überlegst, wie viele Sportarten noch nicht abgedeckt sind, wie viele Themenbereiche in Gesellschaft und Politik noch nicht abgedeckt sind, wird alles noch mehr, bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, das verrückte Weise tatsächlich, manche Leute noch gar nicht so genau wissen, wie man Podcasts hört. Also die zwar ein iPhone haben, aber Angst haben, auf die Podcast-App zu drücken, weil sie denken, das kostet was oder so.
Wie sind denn bei euch die Nutzungszahlen bezogen auf, wie viele Leute über die Homepage hören und wie viele über die App? Also beim Rasenfunk sind das immer noch 50 Prozent der Downloads, die tatsächlich auf der Seite selbst geschehen. Weshalb wir auch so viel Energie dann reingesteckt haben, die Seite neu zu gestalten und Hörer und Hörerinnen freundlicher zu machen. Ist das? Ich fange jetzt einfach mal bei Sven, weil er den Vorteil hat, sich neben mir an zu melden. Sven, wie ist das bei euch?
Nein, ich wollte jetzt weniger auf uns gehen. Das wissen wir gar nicht so genau. Wir haben unsere Download-Zahlen, aber wir checken, dass es nicht wirklich wie viel kommt über die Webseite oder woher kommt der Traffic, von wo hören uns die Leute. Aber ich kann das für mich selber bestätigen. Ich höre sehr viele Podcasts im Browser. Ganz einfach, weil wenn ich im Büro bin, dann habe ich mein mobiles Headset, weil wir in der Firma Skype for Business benutzen. Dann habe ich kabellose Kopfhörer, die habe ich einfach auf, gehe in den Browser rein. Das heißt, ich muss das nicht downloaden, ich kann das direkt über den Stream abrufen. Ich muss es nicht auf mein Handy runterladen, müsste dann meine Kopfhörer über Bluetooth mit meinem Mobiltelefon koppeln, dass ich dann jedes Mal mit mir rumtragen müsste, damit die Verbindung nicht abreißt. Und deswegen höre ich in der Arbeit größtenteils Podcasts nur über den Browser, sofern natürlich unsere IT nicht sagt, äh, nein, wollen wir nicht. Je nach Server, wo dann das Audio-File draufliegt.
Ist da Rasenfunk gewidelistet? Ich frage für einen Freund.
Rasenfunk funktioniert, aber es gibt blöderweise so eine Sendung mit so vier komischen Typen da in Köln, Frankfurt und so, ähm, der streikt unsere IT. Kann ich leider, muss ich mir immer vorher runterladen und dann, ähm, so, so hören, ja.
René, ihr seid ja schon sehr lange mit dabei. Haben wir ja vorhin schon thematisiert. Und ich weiß gleichzeitig, dass du auch sehr digital affin bist und auch viel Zeit und Mühe in eurer Homepage steckst. Wie gestaltet sich das denn bei euch?
Ich hab grad eben mal nachgeguckt. Ich hatte ja jetzt Vorbereitungszeit. Wir kommen in den letzten Folgen nicht über 6 Prozent, die über den Webplayer laufen. Also 94 Prozent gehen tatsächlich über mobile Apps ab. Ich glaub, der Punkt, den ihr hattet mit die meisten Leute, haben zwar diese App da auf dem Telefon, wissen sie nicht, wie sie funktioniert, die ist durchaus richtig. Ich meine, mich auch erinnern zu können, gab es da nicht auch, ich mein, Ende letzten Jahres mal irgendwie so eine Aktion, so nach dem Motto, jeder sollte irgendwie zwei Leute an die Hand nehmen und denen mal zeigen, wie das auf ihrem Smartphone funktioniert, da gab es mal irgendwo so einen Aufruf. Das fand ich eigentlich eine ganz schöne Geschichte.
Das nennt man bei mir Montag. Also ich nehme so viele Leute an die Hand und zeige ihnen Podcasts eingeschlossen, enge Verwandte und entfernte Bekannte an der Bushaltestelle. Das ist unglaublich. Und vor allem, wie einfach es ist, wenn man den Leuten einfach nur sagt, das ist Radio übers Internet und du kannst es hören, wann du willst und du kannst dir auch die Sendung anhören, die dich gerade interessiert. Das reicht meistens schon, dass bei den Leuten ein kleines Glühbirnchen angeht im Kopf und sie sagen, ah, ich bin echt so schlecht.
Ich bin immer versucht, das bei dieser Jugend zu machen, wenn die wieder an mir vorbeilaufen und aus deren Hosentasche irgendwas rausplärt, was die Musik nennt, denen zu zeigen, dass es da auch noch andere Dinge gibt.
Gute Musik?
Dann könnte da auch der Eintritt Frankfurt rausplärren, der Podcast.
Ja, aber das wäre doch wenigstens was Vernünftiges.
Da möchte jetzt keiner aus der Runde etwas sagen aus der sehr, sehr großen Runde. René, da halten sich dann alle nur bedeckt. Ich habe noch mal gerade die Zahlen rausgesucht der letzten ARD ZDF Online-Studie. Da liegt die On-Demand-Nutzung von Radiosendungen und Audiopodcasts in etwa auf dem Niveau der Vorjahrestudie aus dem Jahr 2017 bei 4 bzw. 3% der Nutzer. Klaas, du als Radiomensch, da gibt es noch jede Menge Optimierungspotenzial nach oben. Wie glaubst du denn, könnte man das heben als Podcaster?
Als einzelner Podcaster kannst du natürlich immer nur das machen, was du gerade erzählt hast, nach außen gehen. Das kann an die einzelne Person sein. Man kann aber auch, denke ich, da, also es gibt ja Versuche von einzelnen Podcastern, auch irgendwelche Veranstaltungen außerhalb des Podcasts mal zu machen. Ich meine, wenn der Milan Ton zum Beispiel irgendwie mal dann in die Fanräume einlädt und mal eine Live-Folge macht, also so ein bisschen Event, dass die Leute halt auch darüber ins Gespräch kommen. Und ich glaube, wir könnten als Podcaster, wir haben das vorhin ja schon mal gesagt, man sollte sich in den Podcasts empfehlen, aber das reicht natürlich nicht. Also wenn ich jetzt mal kurz frage, Max, wann hast du das letzte Mal über Ed Rasenfunk bei Twitter einen anderen Podcast empfohlen?
Über den Twitter-Account mache ich das tatsächlich nicht. Das hat allerdings auch einen Grund, weil dann wäre tatsächlich das Schwierige, den Leuten zu verkaufen, wen ich nicht empfehle. Denn ich bekomme immer mal wieder Hörhinweise von Podcastern und höre da auch sehr gerne rein. Aber nicht alles würde ich dann doch davon empfehlen.
Ja gut, das kannst du ja in der Sendung erzählen, wie du da ausfällst. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn man halt irgendwas gehört hat, also ich beobachte das gerade auf jeglichen Plattformen, dass die Leute die lesenden Artikel und dann wird der rausgehauen mit einem Spruch dazu und so weiter. Das ist bei Podcasten noch nicht so gängig, dass man jetzt sagt, boah, ich hab jetzt gerade hier eine super Folge vom Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast gehört oder vom Brennerpass und die bewerbe ich jetzt noch mal auf meiner Plattform. Da müssen wir halt noch ein bisschen mehr hinkommen.
Da muss ich auch noch mal kurz reinhacken, Klaas. Ich weiß zum Beispiel, dass wir beide folgen diesen Menschen auf Twitter und in der Form eines Nashorns, die ab und an schon auch mal durchaus einen Podcast über Twitter weiterhin viel, sprich teilt, nur da diese gute Frau ein Apple-Nutzer ist, kommen dann halt ein iTunes-Link raus, der natürlich wiederum für Android-Nutzer komplett nutzlos ist. Das heißt, man kann es schon nutzen. Man müsste sich da draufklicken, man müsste sich den Namen aufschreiben, müsste dann die Alternative sozusagen in seinem Podcast-Catcher suchen und sich den dann quasi abonnieren. Aber man kann jetzt, wenn man halt auf Android oder Windows unterwegs ist, nicht einfach nur weil jemand zum Beispiel einen Link via iTunes geteilt hat, dann als Windows-Nutzer da draufklicken. Es sei denn, man hat auch noch iTunes installiert. Das habe ich als Windows-Nutzer ehrlich gesagt, nur weil wir jetzt unseren Podcast haben. Sonst würde ich iTunes auch überhaupt nicht nutzen.
Ja gut, wir beim MDR machen das, wenn ich da kurz eingerätschen darf. Wir beim MDR machen das immer so. Wir haben da unsere HFC und FCM Podcasts und machen jedes Mal einen kleinen Text mit den wichtigsten Aussagen. Also je nachdem, wenn wir bloß unseren Experten haben, sind es halt drei Thesen zur Folge. Aber wenn wir irgendwie einen Gast haben, einen Spieler, einen Offiziellen, dann machen wir das schon ein bisschen ausführlicher, sagen er sprach über das, das und das. So bei der Bild, beim Phrasendrescher nämlich, dass auch so ähnlich war, also dass dann auch Facebook-Tafeln mit den zentralen Aussagen gemacht werden. Also ich glaube, das würde schon helfen, wenn man einfach irgendwie ein Textelement hat, was sich, glaube ich, leichter verteilt als so ein großes Audio, wo viele erst mal draufgucken, das sehen und denken, oh, hier sieben Stunden Audio, schöne Sache. Und es dann in der nächsten Sekunde wieder vergessen haben werden, wenn sie irgendwie gleich eine Aussage daraus mitbekommen, vielleicht eher noch neugierig werden.
Wobei man damit auch ein bisschen dem Podcast seine Stärke beraubt. Also gerade das Fehlen einer Verknappung ist ja das, was Podcasts dem mehr wert im Vergleich zu anderen Medien gibt. Und diese Zitat-Tafeln bei Facebook und Twitter funktionieren sehr gut. Ich persönlich kann sie aber nicht mehr sehen. Ich möchte keine Politiker-Statements mehr in 140 Zeichen sehen. Ich möchte keine Sportler-Statements zu 140 Zeichen sehen. Ich habe damit auch mal experimentiert beim Rasenfunk, aber habe mich da auch immer nicht wohlbeigefühlt, dann nach dem Lacher in der Folge zu suchen oder nach der einen Spitzenaussage, die in einem Satz so sehr teast, wie man sagt, dass man dann auch auf die Folge klickt. Ich glaube auch, dass das sehr gut funktionieren kann, ist aber vielleicht auch eine inhaltliche Abwägung, finde ich.
Das mag sein. Mich macht es oft sehr neugierig bzw. Ich hoffe, wenn ich einen Text dazu anlege, dass der die Leute auch einfach neugierig macht, sich dann auch die Folge anzuhören, wo wir schon auch die Rückmeldungen bekommen, dass das relativ oft ganz gut funktioniert.
Das ist schon auch so, wie der Max zum Beispiel sagte. Ich kenne, es gibt ja noch einen Podcast, über den reden wir vielleicht später noch drübergehalten. Die machen ja auch quasi so ein leicht verschwommenes Hintergrundbild und schreiben dann vorne so die drei Hauptthemen, der aktuellen Folge, und publizieren das dann in den sozialen Medien. Finde ich wunderbar. Hatte ich zum Beispiel auch für uns überlegt, dass wir das eventuell machen können. Aber dann habe ich mir gedacht, weil ich das in ähnlicher Form dann auch schon sehr oft gesehen hatte, dass ich mir gesagt habe, nee, eigentlich so toll ich das finde, aber ich mag das dann für uns dann doch auch nicht so haben.
Ich glaube, was da auch noch so ein wichtiger Faktor ist, ich meine, wir hatten das gerade in der Diskussion so ein bisschen, wir sprechen über iOS und Android und dann ist da ein Link und so weiter. Also es ist halt einfach nach wie vor noch ein sehr nerdiges Thema. Ich meine, wenn wir mal gucken, so die breite Masse der Menschen, die sind entweder auf Spotify und dann gibt es irgendwie einen Mix der Woche und da werden sie mit irgendwas Bescheid. Die gehen auf YouTube, da gibt es irgendwelche Trends oder die machen das Radio an, drehen an einem Knopf und dann plädert das Ding los. Und wir reden hier von Podcast, da muss ich eine App installieren, da muss ich mir den Namen raussuchen oder die URL, da muss ich da rein und dann muss ich mir die Folgen runterladen. Also der Weg, bis ich zum Hören kommen kann, der ist halt auch ein ganz anderer. Ich glaube, auch wenn das vielleicht so ein fieses Thema ist, aber solche Plattformen wie Spotify oder irgendwas, die bieten nochmal eine viel leichtere Zugangsvoraussetzung, mit denen du nochmal eine ganz andere Reichweite an Leuten auch kriegst. Da würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, Max, weil du, glaube ich, am längsten schon irgendwie mit deinem Podcast da auf Spotify auch unterwegs bist, siehst du da irgendwie einen stärkeren Anstieg bei den Downloads als über den normalen Webweg?
Einen Anstieg nicht. Allerdings sind die Zahlen sehr, sehr gut und waren sie von Beginn an. Und da hat sich auch nichts verändert durch das Auftreten anderer Podcasts. Also inzwischen ist ja Spotify offen und man hätte ja erwarten können, am Anfang ist es Download-Zahl X und dann wird die eher kleiner, weil noch mehr andere Podcasts mit dazu kommen. Also wir haben bei einer Schlusskonferenz, die immer so zwischen, sagen wir einfach mal, 20.000 Downloads hat, damit kann man auch ganz gut rechnen, manchmal sind es auch ein bisschen mehr, haben wir bei Spotify immer um die 2.000 Streams Minimum pro Folge. Das heißt, schon mal ein Zehntel der ursprünglichen Download-Größe und das Gleiche kommt auch noch mal über YouTube mit dazu Minimum. Also kann auch sehr gut mal Ausreißer nach oben geben. Das heißt, das was du gerade sagst, dass es auch schon Plattformen gibt, denen man auch aus verschiedenen Gründen kritisch gegenüberstehen kann, aber wo die Zugangshürde nicht ganz so groß ist und ein bisschen auch das Empfehlungssystem einfacher ist, vor allem bei YouTube stolpern die Leute über deine Folgen. Also ich frage die Leute immer, wie habt ihr den Rasenfunk gefunden, wenn es da Kommentare gibt nach dem Motto, toll, was du hier machst und ich habe jetzt mal abonniert. Das kann schon wirklich viel helfen. Und beim Rasenfunk möchte ich da nicht mehr darauf verzichten, weil ich auch tatsächlich den Eindruck habe, in dem Bereich kann man gerade noch viel leichter wachsen als in dem klassischen Podcast, bitte abonniere meinen Stream-Bereich, in dem ich mich über Reichweite eigentlich kaum noch weiter vergrößern kann, auch weil viele andere jetzt ihre Podcasts starten, die per se einfach schon mal 30.000 Downloads haben, weil sie einfach von einem großen Medium kommen oder weil da ein großer Name drüber steht und so weiter. Also für den Rasenfunk sehr, sehr wichtig. Und deswegen kann ich das auch allen anderen, die das möchten, nur empfehlen, das zu tun. Spotify, YouTube lohnt sich.
Das ist auch ein bisschen, was wir jetzt so erfahren haben. iTunes lief am schlechtesten. Dann kam Soundcloud. Und am besten lief es tatsächlich von der Webseite.
Und da finde ich den Hinweis auch nochmal ganz, ganz interessant. Da bin ich auch, ich weiß leider nicht mehr, durch welchen Podcast draufgekommen. Ich glaube, es war auch nichts Deutsches mehr. Deswegen kann ich jetzt leider, also mir fällt die Quelle leider nicht ein. Aber die haben bei sich erwähnt, dass viele ältere Hörerinnen und Hörer ausschließlich über ihr Newsletter die Folgen konsumieren, weil sie quasi nur dann mitbekommen, es gibt eine neue Folge und dann gehen sie da auf den Link und hören es dann einfach zum Teil auf dem Smartphone, dann eben im Handy, Browser oder im Browser am Desktop. Und das war für mich dann der Impuls zu sagen, okay, gut, dann probieren wir das auch einfach aus. Und der Newsletter vom Rasenfunk hat nicht viele Abonnenten, 340 oder irgendwie so. Aber tatsächlich kann man sehen, es gibt da eine ganz, ganz treue Hörerschaft, die nur so auf Folgen aufmerksam wird und was auch tatsächlich viel mit Alter zu tun hat. Also es gibt auch einige ältere Hörerinnen und Hörer des Rasenfunks. Und da habe ich schon die Rückmeldung bekommen, weil ich einmal vergessen habe, ein Newsletter rauszuschicken. Kam gleich die Rückmeldung, du hast in der Schlusskonferenz von der Folge gesprochen, ich habe die gar nicht gefunden. Dann sage ich, wie du hast sie nicht gefunden? Ist doch auf der Webseite, bei Twitter, bei Instagram, bei Facebook. Ja, nee, aber war nicht im Newsletter. Das hat mir richtig die Augen geöffnet. Also das kann ich auch an der Stelle. Es ist halt alles nochmal mehr Arbeit und es ist nicht klar, ob es sich für jeden lohnt. Aber da kann man auch nochmal Leute erreichen, die in dem Medium nicht ganz so sicher sind. Und so ein Newsletter, niemand mag Newsletter. Aber die, die man bewusst abonniert, schaut man ja dann doch rein. Und sowas wird dann vielleicht auch mal weitergeleitet an Leute, die es interessieren könnten. So erkläre ich mir zumindest, dass die Klicks da immer recht gut waren.
Das ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, ein Thema. Was ist Marketing rund um Podcasts? Jeder um seinen eigenen kann man ja immer ausbauen. Ich glaube, man muss da halt auch immer ganz ehrlich zu sich selber halt sein. Wie viel Zeit brauche ich für die Vorbereitung von der Folge? Wie lange dauert die Aufnahme? Wie lange dauert die Nachbereitung? Und will ich dann noch mehr investieren? Wenn das natürlich mein Ziel ist, ich will Reichweite klotzen und so weiter, kann man das alles machen. Aber man sollte sich halt auch nicht verrennen und denken, für fünf Newsletter-Abonnenten muss ich dann am Ende des Tages immer noch mal eine halbe Stunde länger sitzen oder so. Und da sollte man halt auch immer gucken, dass man die Abläufe möglichst knapp hat, damit man da auch nicht zu viel Zeit reinsteckt. Weil das Wichtigste ist immer noch das gesprochene Wort und nicht das Tammtamm drumrum.
Absolut. Und da muss man vielleicht auch bei allem, was ich jetzt sage, noch mit reinberechnen. Seit Anfang dieser Bundesliga-Saison mache ich nur den Rasenfunk und noch ein anderes Podcast-Projekt, das irgendwann 2019 hoffentlich das Licht der Welt erblicken wird. Das heißt, ich habe auch einen Zeiteinsatz, der nicht normal ist für einen Podcaster in Deutschland, weil bei der Mehrzahl der Podcasterinnen und Podcaster es einfach ein Nebenprojekt ist. Deswegen kann ich mir das eben auch erlauben, da auf allen Kanälen rauszutröten, was es jetzt gerade wieder Neues gibt. Richtige Anmerkung. Würde mich aber interessieren, wie schätzt ihr denn das ein, Oliver? Was sich jetzt gerade tut im Podcastbereich hinsichtlich, es gibt jetzt Vereine, die podcasten. Aktuell sind das Werder Bremen, Borussia Mönchengladbach und Leverkusen. Ich gehe fest davon aus, dass schon in drei Monaten, wenn man diese Passage hört, es mindestens einen weiteren Bundesliga-Verein gibt. Meine persönliche Wette, die ich noch nie mit jemandem abschließen konnte, weil es keinen interessiert außer mich, ist, dass es bis Ende der Saison sechs bis acht Bundesliga-Vereine mit eigenem Podcast geben wird. Oliver, was glaubst du? Verändert das die Podcast-Landschaft? Ist das etwas, was du positiv, negativ siehst? Oder ist es dir völlig egal?
Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so eine richtige Meinung zu, weil ich als Zweit- und Drittliga-Reporter mich mit der Bundesliga auch tatsächlich gar nicht so viel beschäftige. So und ich persönlich auch Podcasts eher so wahllos höre. Also ich finde irgendwas bei Spotify und höre es mir mal an. So und wenn es mir gefällt, höre ich es mir nochmal an. Oder auch über Empfehlungen so. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt die Bundesliga-Podcasts noch gar nicht wahrgenommen. Also ich könnte dir jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, ob die anderen Öffentlich-Rechtlichen irgendwie so in der Form, wie wir es beim MDR haben, Vereins-Podcasts haben, vereinzelt gibt es das sicherlich. So und ja, sollen sie machen. Ich meine, das wird sein wie mit vielen Produkten, so wie mit Vereins-Fernsehsendern und so weiter. Das ist dann eben auch wieder noch eine Plattform, um den Verein zu vermarkten und positiv darzustellen. Und ich glaube, die Leute werden aber schon wissen, weiß ich nicht, wenn es jetzt bei Borussia Dortmund eingeben sollte, dass sie bei Schwarz-Gelb sicherlich auch was finden werden, was ihnen vielleicht besser gefällt. Oder wo sie noch eine andere Sicht drauf bekommen. Deswegen, ich glaube, die Leute mögen schon auch irgendwo unabhängige Sachen, die jetzt nicht direkt vom Verein kommen. Oder vielleicht auch gar nicht von einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Medium, sondern von einem Blog, so wie der Eintracht-Podcast. Ich glaube, da nimmt man sich nichts weg. So, und ja, die Leute, die irgendwie alles von ihrem Verein konsumieren, die hören sich das dann wahrscheinlich auch noch an.
Also ich erinnere mich noch gut dran, das waren vor allen Dingen YouTuber, die sich dann darüber aufrichten, dass Öffentlich-Rechtliche jetzt auch auf YouTube sind und mit ihren Inhalten die freien Inhalte vertreiben. Und im Podcast-Bereich ist es ja auch noch viel stärker. Und jetzt kommen halt auch noch andere dazu, die auch noch Geld verdienen sollen. Und ich glaube, Podcasts sind ein Medium wie viele andere. Und überall, wo man halt die Möglichkeit hat, vielleicht sogar noch Geld zu verdienen, wird es halt interessant für Medienhäuser. Und deshalb gibt es ja auch, wenn man sich diese landläufigen Listen hier bei iTunes anguckt, dann gibt es halt die Sex und die Psychologie und die Mental-Podcasts, die da scheinbar am erfolgreichsten sind. Also wahrscheinlich sollte man sich dem Fußball abwenden und nur noch ein Sex-and-Crime-Podcast mit Comedy und ein paar Technikerwähnen von Apfelprodukten machen. Das sollte dann die Goldgrube sein. Und Fußball und Sex? Auch eine schöne Idee. Aber ich glaube, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Vereins-Podcasts hat, dann sollte man halt auch immer ganz klar sagen, dass das halt nur PR ist. Also was natürlich auch okay ist, und für manchen unkritischen Fan-Podcasts mag das vielleicht auch gelten, aber beim Vereins-Podcast ist das halt noch, ist das richtig deutlich, es ist einfach nur PR. Da werden keine relevanten Fragen für mich persönlich jetzt geklärt, sondern das sind Feel-good-Interviews, die man sonst in der Bunde gibt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch eine ganz große Chance von dem Podcast. Es wird immer Bereiche geben, wo sich unabhängige Podcasts bewähren können und auch weiter werden. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel höre, wie Axel mit all seinem Werf bei 93 über die Jahreshoffersammlung beim 1. FC Köln berichtet, wie das Textil vergehen, die Thesen ihres Lieblingsvereins Union Berlin auseinandernimmt oder wie der Milan Thorn über den Mythos Ultra diskutiert oder wie im Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast über das Finale gesprochen wird. Das sind Sachen, die kein Medium leisten kann. Und da kann man sich immer weiter bewegen. Ich glaube, das Blödste, was du immer machen kannst, ist, dass du irgendetwas anders kopierst. Diese Bundesliga-Podcasts werden sich alle gegenseitig kopieren. Natürlich wird den Bayern-Podcast einer der erfolgreichsten überhaupt sein. Aber inhaltlich ist es meistens dann doch recht dünn, glaube ich.
Denke ich auch, ja.
Wobei ich auf Grundlage der aktuellen Fallbeispiele widersprechen möchte. Auch wenn ich gerne sagen würde, die Vereins-Podcasts sind ganz fürchterlich, die es da gerade gibt. Aber sowohl der Werder Bremen-Podcast hatte wirklich gute Gespräche mit Florian Kohfeldt, Claudio Pizarro, Eggestein. Jan Delay würde ich an der Stelle ausklammern, aber einfach nur aus persönlicher Präferenz. Ich mag die Musik, aber ansonsten war das eher ein bisschen flach. Leverkusen hat zum Beispiel ein sehr, sehr gutes Interview mit Stefan Kiesling geführt, das auch gar nicht so unkritisch war. Natürlich wurde da nicht alles in Frage gestellt, was vielleicht jetzt ein unabhängiger Bericht erstattern gemacht hätte. Es war aber auch weit über der Qualität von vielen anderen Interviews, die man von Spielern hört. Und Gladbach hat zum Beispiel Lars Stindl über zwei Stunden in seinem eigenen Podcast gehabt und jetzt eine neue Folge mit Hans Meyer gemacht. Das waren alles Podcasts, da hatte ich Tränen in den Augen, als ich es gehört habe, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das waren Gäste, die wollte ich haben, und das waren Gespräche, die hätte ich gerne geführt. Das kann sich sehr gut noch verändern, auch bei anderen Podcasts. Und klar, man muss vor allem wissen, der Absender ist der Verein. Da werden vielleicht manche Fragen einfach nicht gestellt. Aber an den Beispielen, die ich jetzt konsumiert habe in den letzten Monaten, habe ich das noch nicht gespürt, dass da ein Vereinsmedium spricht.
Ich finde es aber auch schwierig, das einfach zu vergleichen, weil die Zugangsvoraussetzungen für die sind doch einfach ganz anders. Das ist doch genauso, als wenn ich mich beim Marathon hinstelle, als jemand, der irgendwie letzte Woche um Training angefangen hat und will mit dem amtierenden Ironman mitlaufen. Das kann doch gar nicht funktionieren. Ich finde das an der Stelle auch gar nicht tragisch. Da sollen die doch ihr Ding machen. Ich finde das überhaupt nicht schlimm. Die machen auch ihr Vereinsfernsehen und Zeug. Und was ich von den Hörern immer wieder mitkriege, ist, dass sie sagen von wegen, ja, ich höre mir das ab und zu mal an, aber am Ende ist es mir dann doch nicht authentisch genug.
Na, mein Gedanke ist eher, dass das ja vielleicht sogar auch ein bisschen die Türen aufmachen kann. Also wenn sich Vereins, Pressestellen jetzt für so was entscheiden und damit auseinandersetzen, dass die dann eben auch wissen, okay, welche Funktion so ein Podcast hat oder wen man damit vielleicht erreichen kann. Und dass es dadurch vielleicht sogar leichter werden kann, dass man eben an Spieler rankommt oder an Fußballgrößen, die man sonst nicht erreicht, weil sie dann eben sagen, ja, was soll ich da jetzt zwei Stunden rumlabern? Wenn sie das aber bei ihrem eigenen Verein schon mal gemacht haben, sagt der Verein vielleicht auch, hier gibt es einen Podcast, das wäre vielleicht für uns auch ganz interessant, geh doch da mal hin.
Ja, entweder das oder das, einfach die Hörer dann auch ein Stück weit sensibilisiert werden, weil sie halt eben feststellen, Moment, okay, ich hab da jetzt was gehört, jetzt hab ich verstanden, wie das Ding funktioniert. Das ist mir jetzt irgendwie mit einer Stunde vielleicht auch irgendwie zu wenig. Ich hab noch irgendwie Luft, dann guck ich mal, was es da sonst noch so gibt. Dann sind wir wieder bei dem Thema, von wohin die Leute überhaupt erstmal mit dem Medium an sich in Verbindung bringen.
Ja, das kann schon gut sein. Also sowohl die Sensibilisierung der Akteure fürs Medium, also wenn ein Lars Stintl schon mal im eigenen Vereinspodcast zwei Stunden über seine Karriere gesprochen hat, dann kriegt man ihn vielleicht auch nochmal in einem anderen Podcast und der sagt nicht gleich bei zwei Stunden, um Himmels willen, wie soll das denn gehen? Und das andere auch, dass Leute entfinden, da ist allerdings dann die Hürde schon etwas höher geworden. Also ich finde, das hat sich schon verschoben. Zum einen, das hab ich jetzt noch nicht gehört, dass in diesen großen Produktionen von etablierten Medien und auch Vereinen andere Podcasts erwähnt wurden. Irgendwann fiel mal der Begriff Rasenfunk im Borussia Mönchengladbach-Podcast. Das wurde mir dann gleich aufgeregt getwittert, hatte aber logischerweise 0,0 Effekt. Aber zum Beispiel den Vollraute-Podcast, einen sehr empfehlenswerten Borussia Mönchengladbach-Podcast, den es in drei Sprachen gibt, Deutsch, Englisch, Französisch. Ich meine, wo sind wir denn hier? Alles von Fans produziert, das ist ja wohl fantastisch. Mir wäre noch nicht aufgefallen, dass die dieses Fan-Medium mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise eingebunden hätten. Wenn ich hier jetzt eine Lücke hab, dann lass ich mich sehr gerne korrigieren und berichten.
Da kann ich aus meinem eigenen Erleben ein Beispiel bringen. Also wir haben halt beim MDR einen FCM-Podcast. Dann gibt's vom Alex hier Ersatzbank bei Twitter. Der macht ja den FCM-Blog und hat da auch noch, wir sagen immer, den anderen FCM-Podcast. Er sagt der wahre FCM-Podcast, wie auch immer. Und ich meine, das liegt jetzt auch daran, dass wir uns beide, glaube ich, ganz gut verstehen und über 120 Minuten eh viel miteinander zu tun haben. Aber das spielen wir uns die Bälle teilweise zu, weil wir beim MDR einen Experten haben, der gerne mal so ein bisschen den Oberlehrer macht und dann immer so erklärt, was der Trainer machen sollte in unseren Folgen. Und dann hat der andere FCM-Podcast mal die Frage aufgeworben, ob unser Experte eigentlich einen Trainerschein hat. Das habe ich dann gehört und habe ihn dann in der nächsten Folge gefragt. Der hat gesagt, ich habe keinen Trainerschein, aber ich erkläre halt gerne Dinge.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist aber noch die lobenswerte Ausnahme. Es kann auch sein, dass sich das verändert. Aber ich finde, das ist schon noch ein Unterschied, den man sieht. Er ist auch leicht erklärbar. Natürlich nehmen wir jetzt zum Beispiel mal den 1. FC Köln. Wenn die mit einem eigenen Podcast starten würden, und das hatte ich nicht für völlig ausgeschlossen, die wollen ja digital immer vorne mit dabei sein, dann gibt es als bereits bestehende Podcast sowohl Fan-Medien wie den Bocast, der jetzt wieder reaktiviert werden soll. Das habe ich schon vor ein paar Monaten mal angekündigt, liebe Podcast-Macher. Ich habe euch extra gefragt, also jetzt macht bitte auch was. Und es gibt aber zum Beispiel auch einen 1. FC Köln-Podcast vom Express. Und da steht dann natürlich der Verein irgendwann dann auch in der Situation, so wie ja Vereine auch nicht in der Regel auf ihren eigenen Social-Media-Plattformen oder Webseiten auf fremde Medien hinweisen, weil sie schnell in dieser, nenne ich den einen, muss ich auch den anderen Situation sind. Vielleicht möchte ich das gar nicht, oder ich möchte gar nicht in diese Zwickmühle kommen. Also das könnte sich auch noch schnell drehen. Und gerade beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel, da kann ich mir kein Szenario dieser Welt vorstellen, dass die mal die bestehenden FC Bayern-Podcasts erwähnen.
Und ich glaube halt auf dieser Punkt, dass die Medienabteilung eher jetzt dafür geschaffen werden und eigene Produkte anbieten, um andere nicht mehr bedienen zu müssen. Das darf man einfach nicht unterschätzen. Guck dir doch diese albernen Mixed-Zone-Interviews an, die es noch gibt. Da passiert so wenig, weil die sich auch einfach keine kritischen Fragen stellen lassen wollen. Glaubst du, dass in einem Bayern-Podcast mal die Frage diskutiert wird, wie gut denn ein Sponsor wie Qatar ist? Ich glaube es nicht. Also das ist halt dafür, braucht man Podcasts, die außerhalb von Medienabteilungen sind. Die sollen das gerne machen, aber das ist kein Journalismus, das ist PR. Du kannst noch so sehr sagen, dass das ein interessantes Gespräch mit Kiesling ist. Will ich ja gar nicht bestreiten, aber das wird nie kritisch sein.
Zumindest nicht so kritisch, wie man sein könnte und bestimmt nicht investigativ. Aber ich mache schon die Beobachtung, wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, dass die Vereine eigene Podcasts haben und das ist dann eben auch große Medien. Also Sport 1 zum Beispiel verlängert jetzt den Doppelpass. Ich kannte es vorher nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diese Fußball-Talks hin und kanntet. Verlängern Sie als Podcast. Sky schickt seine Fußballdebatten. Als Podcast nochmal raus, hat noch ein eigenes Format, was dann noch dranhängt als eigener Podcast. Und was ich jetzt beobachte, ist, durch die Pod-Roll habe ich immer einen ganz guten Eindruck darüber, davon wie viele neue Podcasts es gibt, in wie vielen Bereichen. Und früher habe ich die auch häufiger in den Top-Folgen-Listen gefunden bei iTunes und bei anderen Diensten, vor allem aber iTunes. Und jetzt bin ich eigentlich gar kein Freund davon, diese Charts überzubewerten, weil es ist völlig undurchsichtig, nach welchen Kriterien man da oben kommt. Und meiner persönlichen Erfahrung nach macht es eigentlich auch gar nicht so den riesen Unterschied, ob man da jetzt mal auf 3 oder auf 30 ist. Aber für einen neuen, unbekannten, unabhängigen Podcast eben vielleicht schon, bei der dann Leuten wie uns, die sich in dieser Sphäre aufhalten, auffällt. Und da habe ich schon den Eindruck, da wird sich was verändern. Dadurch, dass du im Grunde, wenn jetzt Lieschen Müller einen Podcast startet zu irgendeinem Nischenthema, die hat keine Chance mehr in die ersten Top 10 zu kommen. Also es ist völlig ausgeschlossen. Und dann kann es vielleicht auch viel häufiger passieren, das, was wir vorhin bei Anna hatten. Das tut einem ja fast schon körperlich weh, dass wir alle, bis auf Klaas natürlich, Fußball und Macht nicht kannten. Das könnte häufiger passieren. Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Bedenken, ehrlich gesagt. Da will auch keiner. Okay, ich meine, andere Frage. Man kann die Frage ja auch andersherum stellen. Da würde ich gerne bei Mike anfangen, weil er vorhin schon fast mit schlechtem Gewissen geantwortet hat. Fühlst du dich denn jetzt als Vertretung für den Millantoren genügend wahrgenommen und wertgeschätzt, sowohl von Hörern und Hörern als auch von den Medienvereinsvertretern usw.?
Also im Verein auf jeden Fall. Das habe ich vorhin auch aus völlig geschildert, warum das so ist. Da ist es aber auch so, jetzt auch mal weg vom Millantoren, auch als Blogger im Verein, und das bin jetzt ja nicht nur ich, das hat ja durchaus noch ein paar andere Seiten, wie den Magischen FC oder andere, die da sehr wohl sehr wertgeschätzt werden und die auch nahezu eins zu eins wie normale Medien behandelt werden. Also wir dürfen genauso auf Pressekonferenzen, wir werden genauso auch mal zu einem Gespräch eingeladen. Und das ist, glaube ich, beim FC St. Pauli wunderbar und das hat Einzug gehalten unter anderem auch mit demjenigen, der da jetzt für verantwortlich ist, der Christoph Pieper, der von vornherein gesagt hat, wir wollen Fan-Medien gleichrangig behandeln. Also das ist absolut, glaube ich, schon sehr selten in der deutschen Vereinsfußball-Szene und da können wir uns sehr glücklich schätzen, davon profitieren wir und eben wie gesagt, nicht nur wir als Podcast, sondern auch insgesamt die Blogs beim FC St. Pauli. Und bei den Hörern, naja, also wir sind halt ein Vereinspodcast eines zweitligesten und wenn wir da so im Durchschnitt Download-Zahlen von oben bei 4.000, 5.000 haben, dann ist das etwas, wo ihr sagt, ja, viel mehr können wir uns da nicht erhoffen. Das ist schon ziemlich fantastisch für uns. Und da bin ich sehr zufrieden mit und trotzdem hast du natürlich, wir haben es im letzten Sommer zum ersten und diesen Sommer zum zweiten Mal gemacht, dass wir, wie du gesagt hast, eine Sendung in den Fernräumen aufgezeichnet haben mit Publikum. Und da stellst du dich natürlich vorher schon hin und denkst, wenn da nur drei Leute kommen, ist das ein bisschen peinlich. Und es war dann aber beidesmal so, dass der Raum, wo ungefähr 100 Sitzgelegenheiten zur Verfügung stehen, auch dann annähernd voll war. Es waren immer zwischen 90 und 100 Leute dann da. Das heißt, wir haben schon eine gewisse Relevanz. Ich maße mir jetzt nicht an, zu glauben, dass von den 30.000, die da regelmäßig zu den Heimspielen gehen, uns mehr als zwei Zehntel dann ungefähr kennt. Aber ich treffe immer noch Leute, die einen St. Pauli-Cappy, einen St. Pauli-Pin und einen St. Pauli-Pulli tragen. Und wenn ich dann sage, ich schreibe für einen Übersteiger, wie gesagt, ein Fernsehen, das seit 1993 existiert, dann sagen die, für wen. Und daher wird es auch bei Milan Ton sein, so sein.
Warte mal kurz, Marc, du hast es gerade geschafft, dass sogar deine Telefonleitung instabil wurde. Also du hast eindrucksvoll bestätigt, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Ich glaube, es hat sich wieder beruhigt. Setz bitte noch mal kurz an, ich glaube schon, dass...
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass wir in dem, was man aktive Fernszene nennt, eine gewisse Wahrnehmung haben. Also da werden wir uns, und das Marc jetzt sicherlich auch durch die Ultra-Folge noch mal etwas zunehmen, dass uns da schon viele Leute innerhalb der Fernszene kennen. Und das hat sicherlich auch damit zu tun, dass wir über den Übersteigerblock kamen. Also da, glaube ich, brauchen wir uns nicht beschweren.
Rüdiger, ihr habt im Brennerpass neulich mal darüber gesprochen, dass ihr gerne Spieler einladen wollen würdet, um dann mit ihnen über alles zu sprechen, außer Fußball, also so ein bisschen auch den Brennerpassansatz, ins Extrem zu steigern. Das würde ich als Außenstehender jetzt noch als relativ unwahrscheinlich bezeichnen. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst. Aber ihr seid ja auch dadurch, dass ihr so ein bisschen auch andere Interessen bedient und damit ja, wie vorhin beschrieben, auch ein anderes, leicht anderes Publikum vielleicht habt, als viele von uns hier versammelten. Wie stehst denn du diesem Thema gegenüber? Man macht es ja auch nicht für den Download, aber irgendwie ist ja Feedback und zu wissen, dass es dann auch konsumiert wird, schon auch Teil dessen, was wir hier als Antrieb wahrscheinlich haben.
Ja, du meinst jetzt die Sache mit der Wertschätzung.
Also,, ich als Schauspieler, ich weiß so, wenn man...
Du wirst eh nie geliebt.
Wenn man Wertschätzer, wenn man noch nicht den deutschen Filmpreis gewonnen hat, fühlt man sich natürlich eben mal noch nicht ausreichend wertgeschätzt. Aber mit dem Podcast, also ich weiß es nicht. Also es macht uns, also mir sehr viel Spaß und ich bin manchmal überrascht so. Wie viel, ich freue mich immer wahnsinnig, wenn wir dann Feedback haben oder Leute schreiben auf Sachen, die wir im Brennerpass gesagt haben und wo ich dann manchmal erstaunt sitze, sieh mal an. Das hat tatsächlich jemand gehört und er äußert sich dazu. Wie man eine größere, breitere Masse erreicht, ich weiß es gar nicht. Wir sind jetzt auch seit dieser Saison auf Spotify. Also ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn das mehr werden. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, wie.
Vielleicht verändert es ja auch. René, du bist ja schon so lange jetzt mit dem Ertracht Frankfurt Podcast unterwegs. Haben wir ja vorhin auch schon darüber gesprochen. Habt ihr eine gläserne Decke erreicht? Oder ist das überhaupt gar nicht so wichtig? Ich will jetzt eigentlich auch nicht über ein Thema sprechen, wo ihr dann vielleicht irgendwie sechs von sieben von euch sagen, es ist uns eigentlich völlig egal, wir machen es ja aus anderen Gründen. Haben wir ja vorhin auch darüber gesprochen.
Also in erster Linie machen wir nach wie vor, dann mache ich. Ich kann jetzt ja hauptsächlich dann eher für mich sprechen und weniger für die anderen. Dann mache ich das erst mal, weil ich da Lust drauf habe. Und solange wie ich die habe, ziehe ich das Thema auch durch. Klar freue ich mich, wenn... Natürlich freue ich mich, wenn die Folgen eine Menge Abrufzahlen haben. Aber es ist so, dass wir momentan, wenn eine Folge irgendwie ausfällt oder später kommt, dann kriegen wir ein wahnsinniges Feedback von der Hörerschaft, die wir haben, die dann irgendwie traurig sind, dass die Folge irgendwie einen Tag später kommt oder dass die nicht am nächsten Morgen schon da ist und die den auf den Weg zur Arbeit hören können. Also da ist mehr als genug Wertschätzung schon da. Und solange ich da jede Woche Lust habe, mich da hinzusetzen, werde ich das Thema einfach auch durchziehen. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was es dann halt am Ende auch den Ausstieg gibt, warum das, was wir machen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen richtiger ist, aber aus unserer Sicht der richtigere Weg ist als das, was irgendwie ein Medienhaus mit einem riesen Werbeetat da hat.
Ja, wobei auch die Frage ist, ob es den richtigen und den falschen Weg gibt. Jeder geht halt so seinen eigenen. Es gibt ja auch ganz unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen. Also bei mir hat sich der Blick zum Beispiel auf Downloads, und wobei Downloads sind mir eigentlich relativ wurscht, aber auf das Feedback zu den Sendungen, das ist mir immer wichtig. Wie viel kommt im Forum rein, wie viel bei YouTube, wie viel bei Twitter und Facebook kann man da inzwischen total vergessen? Da gucke ich ganz anders drauf, seitdem ich den Plan verfolge mit dem Rasenfunk, meine Miete zu bezahlen und das auch aktiv tue. Also seitdem, vielleicht bin ich deswegen auch hypersensibel bei diesem Thema und es ist vielleicht eigentlich gar nicht so wild, aber seitdem gucke ich da sehr viel deutlicher drauf. Und vielleicht ist das bei manchen Medienhäusern, die das ja als Ergänzung zu ihrer aktuellen Berichterstattung machen, schon auch nochmal eine andere Situation. Da erlebe ich auch eine gewisse… Also ich hatte jetzt Kontakt mit vielen Medien. Es gibt einige, die sind sehr, sehr aufgeschlossen, wenn man mit ihnen über Podcasts spricht und auch darüber, sich gegenseitig zu helfen, in den Bereich voranzukommen. Es gibt auch Medien, die ganz klar sagen, wir bauen da gerade unser eigenes Geschäftsmodell auf oder haben irgendwas anderes am Laufen, mit dem wir aber da richtig auch monetär etwas machen wollen. Und deswegen sind die dann sehr zurückhaltend, was mögliche Kooperationen etc. angeht.
Na gut, das ist bei dir halt nochmal ein anderer Blick. Aber wenn ich sehe, dass, wenn wir Dienstags anfangen, aufzunehmen und ich mache unseren Live-Chat auf und da sitzen schon irgendwie 30 Leute und warten darauf, dass die Sendung gleich losgeht, das ist dann halt auch nochmal so eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Ja, logisch.
Ich finde auch, Max, dass du da auch klar irgendwie eine Stufe weiter bist, aber wenn ich das richtig mitgekriegt habe, ist das ja auch so, dass du das ja sehr bewusst entschieden hast, dass du in deinem Rasenfunk da irgendwie kompromisslos bist und das machst, was du machen willst und deshalb auch keine Sponsoren hast. Und da liegt, glaube ich, auch vor unserem Brennerpass einfach eine unglaubliche Freude drin, das machen zu können, was wir wollen. Das geht halt, wie wir auch schon hier gesagt haben, nur so um Podcasts. Ich war diese Woche zum Beispiel, der ist gerade unterwegs live in Deutschland auf Tournee, zeigt das wunderbare Welt des Fußballs. Und da hab ich mir das angeguckt und ich kannte das noch gar nicht so lange. Die anderen werden das besser kennen. Dann kommen natürlich auch viele Dias und Witze über Cristiano Ronaldo, die dann die üblichen Witze über sein gockelhaftes Auftreten. Und ich mich dann irgendwie freue, dass wir ein Brennerpass-Medium haben, wo wir auch mal schnell kurz jetzt auch mal auf die Spiegelgeschichte und die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe eingehen können, ohne da irgendwie jemanden... Ja, genau. Wir müssen, ohne der Götze Ronaldo da so huldigen zu müssen, wie das andere Medien diese Woche gesagt haben, dass sie das tun müssen. Nicht tun müssen, aber automatisch tun.
Die redaktionelle Freiheit, das ist der Zauber, den das Medium Podcast hat, wenn man selbst ein Podcastender oder eine Podcastende ist. Was mich zu dem einen Thema bringt, über das ich mit euch noch gerne sprechen wollen würde, was wir vorhin schon mal gestreift haben, nämlich die fehlenden Frauen an den Mikrofonen. Da wir jetzt auch wieder so eine Männerlastige Runde sind, würde ich gerne auch direkt die Frage stellen, Oliver, was müssen wir Männer denn dafür tun, dass wir weniger zu hören sind? Du weißt, wie ich es meine. Wie kriegen wir mehr Frauen in die Fußball-Podcast-Landschaft?
Tja, da habe ich jetzt keine zufriedenstellende Antwort. Ich glaube, sie einfach machen lassen. Aber das klang ja vorhin auch schon ein bisschen durch, dass sich da Frauen offenbar auch oft genug nicht trauen. Also ich glaube, das Interesse ist da und dann sollen sie einfach machen.
Aber machen wir es uns da vielleicht nicht auch ein bisschen zu einfach, weil ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass wir die auch ein bisschen Teil des Problems sind. Also vielleicht auch, weil dieser Raum so männlich geprägt ist, ist es noch schwerer fällt für Frauen zu podcasten. Es gab einmal einen Podcast, der von zwei Frauen betrieben wurde. Das war der Zuckerpass. Inzwischen leider wieder eingestellt. Ich habe versucht, die zu pushen, wie es ging über die Rasenfunk-Kanäle. Das dürfte übrigens das letzte Mal gewesen sein, Klaas, um deine Frage von vor einer Stunde zu beantworten, dass ich über den Rasenfunk einen Podcast direkt empfohlen habe, also nicht in der Sendung. Die sind nicht vom Boden weggekommen. Ich hatte den Eindruck, die wurden wegignoriert.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann da jetzt nicht so sonderlich viel zu sagen. Also ich würde es mir anhören oder was weiß ich, bei Nicht-Fußball-Podcasts höre ich mir auch gerne Frauen an, wenn die die Podcasts moderieren. Also das ist jetzt für mich kein Kriterium und ich würde das auch genauso teilen und liken. Aber die Initiative, einen Podcast zu starten, die muss ja erstmal von den Mädels selber kommen. Ich meine, oder in den Medienhäusern kann man natürlich irgendwie drauf achten und sagen, ja, man kann auch Frauen einsetzen. Aber da bin ich jetzt auch nicht in der entscheidenden Position, dass ich sagen könnte, macht mal, sondern könnte maximal zu meinem Chef sagen, hier, warum haben wir eigentlich keine Frau? Wir hatten mal eine beim FCM-Podcast, die hat jetzt einfach eine andere Rolle im Funkhaus. Deswegen, also ich fände es gut, wenn auch viele Frauen über Fußball erzählen. Aber wir können sie ja nicht zwingen.
Nee, das ist ja klar. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, wir müssen da... Also, wenn man wirklich ein ernsthaftes... Wenn es einem egal ist, ist ja auch, meine Güte, jeder, wie er mag. Aber wenn es einem nicht egal ist, dann glaube ich, müssen Männer auch schon ein bisschen da versuchen, anzuschieben. Ich glaube nicht, dass das alleine kommen wird, allein weil Frauen erstmal schon mal in der Minderheit sind, zum Beispiel in den Redaktionen, die sich mit Sport und Fußball befassen. Außer es geht um Frauenfußball, weil da dürfen ja dann gerne die Frauen hin, interessiert die Männer nämlich nicht. Das war das, was ich vorhin sagen wollte.
Aber in welcher Form können wir das anschieben?
Wir hatten die Diskussion in unserer Ultra-Folge, da ging es grundsätzlich darum, warum es keine Frauen auf dem Zaun gibt als Vorsängerinnen. Und ich glaube, die Diskussion über Frauen im Podcast ist recht ähnlich gelagert, weil wir hatten da im Endeffekt die beiden Vertreter, die eine ganz unterschiedliche Rangehensweise hatten. Der eine sagte, ich bin grundsätzlich gegen so eine Art Frauenquote, weil ich will da nichts erfüllen, sondern jemand, der passt, der passt dann halt. Natürlich Geschlechter unabhängig, also gar nicht, dass man Frauen da nicht hin haben will, sondern wenn da eine Frau passt, dann wird sie da auch sein, so ungefähr. Der andere sagte halt, ja, das ist eigentlich der richtige Ansatz, aber der klappt halt nicht. Im Gegenteil, wir müssen es pushen, wir müssen das forcieren, wir müssen da über unseren Schatten springen, wir müssen das antreiben, wir müssen das voranbringen. Brauche ich ja gar nicht weit gucken, das ist ja bei uns auch so. Wir sind eine Runde von fünf, sechs Leuten und der feste Bestandteil der Runde ist komplett männlich. Wir haben zwar immer wieder Gäste, die weiblich sind, aber halt auch verhältnismäßig selten. Und eine ähnliche Diskussion hatten wir bei der vorletzten Sendung, die beschäftigt sich mit den Fantastic Females, eine Ausstellung über weibliche Fans im Fußball, die jetzt durch Deutschland tourt in den nächsten Monaten, ich glaube aktuell in Hannover, war jetzt gerade in Hamburg. Und da haben wir auch beide gesagt, es ist halt so, dass man in diesem Männer dominierten Bereich Fußball halt als Frau sich nicht zwingend in den Vordergrund drängelt. In den allermeisten Fällen zumindest. Und da ist halt so ein Podcast zu betreiben, so ein Podcast zu führen, ist sicherlich auch mit einer gewissen Frontsau eine Affinität einhergehend. Und das fehlt Frauen oftmals. Womit ich halt eben nicht sagen will, dass sie das nicht könnten, sondern die haben da gar nicht unbedingt den Anspruch zu und wollen das vielleicht auch gar nicht. Und da muss man sicherlich dann häufiger mal Frauen zu ihrem Glück zwingen, in Anführungsstrichen, und sie einfach mal als Gast einladen. Und ja, das macht der Rasenfunk, glaube ich, ausgezeichnet. Also, den Anteil, wie du da Frauen ein... Nee, habe ich auch nicht so aufgefasst, kommt hoffentlich auch von mir nicht so gestellt rüber. Sondern es ist einfach so, dass du da einen sehr hohen Anteil an weiblichen Gästen hast. Und ja, würde ich mir bei uns auch bei viel mehr Themen wünschen. Das könnte ich natürlich sagen, mache ich mir einfach. Unsere Fußballprofis sind halt alle männlich. Aber ja, wir haben halt auch eine Frauenhandballmannschaft. Wir haben eine Frauenfußballmannschaft. Da könnte man sicherlich auch ab und an häufiger Gäste zu einladen. Und ich denke, dass zumindest die Podcasts, die Gäste haben, sind ja auch nicht alle. Da wäre das sicherlich eine Geschichte, die man häufiger vielleicht mal von sich selbst aus einfach antreiben muss.
Also wir haben auch das Problem, das hatte ich ja schon erwähnt, gehabt, dass wir tatsächlich auch teilweise Expertinnen hatten, die perfekt gepasst hätten. Und obwohl wir mehrmals mit ihm, also ich habe mehrmals mit ihr telefoniert, mehrmals E-Mails geschrieben und trotzdem hat sie sich im Endeffekt dagegen entschieden, hauptsächlich mit dem Argument zu sagen, naja es gibt ja auch den und den und die können das eigentlich besser und die sind da noch mehr tiefer im Thema drin. Oder ich habe das ja vor drei Jahren das letzte Mal gemacht. Also es ist schon wirklich sehr viel, dass man, oder dass viele Frauen vielleicht denken, sie müssen immer hundertprozentig richtige Expertisen aufweisen, um irgendetwas sagen zu können, damit es eben auch wirklich stichfest ist, falls danach Nachfragen kommen.
Ich glaube auch, das hatte, was vorhin auch schon angesprochen wurde, eben dann teilweise auch darunter, dass man sich möglicherweise davor fürchtet, vor eventuellen Reaktionen, wenn eine Frau einen Fehler macht, wird er weniger leicht verziehen, als wenn ihn ein Mann macht.
Und das ist der wesentliche Punkt. Wir sprechen jetzt immer auch in so Konstruktionen, denen Frauen fehlt oder sie nehmen sich nicht selbst wichtig genug. Ich finde, das ist schon auch noch, also das ist nicht nur etwas, wo man jetzt mit dem Finger auf die Frauen zeigen sollte, sondern das ist für mich eigentlich der springende Punkt. Frauen werden anders kritisiert als Männer. Das sehe ich auch im Rasenfunk. Ich habe die tollsten Hörerinnen und Hörer, meine ich ganz ernst. Was an Feedback kommt, sensationell. Dass ich hier den Anfang so versaut habe in dieser Folge, wird mich noch monatelang nerven. Ich vermute, es wird nicht so sehr strapaziert werden von Hörern und Hörern da draußen. Und dennoch stelle auch ich fest, dass Frauen in einer anderen Art und Weise kritisiert werden und für andere Dinge kritisiert werden. Und ich habe mir, als mir das klar wurde, das gab da einmal so ein Schlüsselerlebnis, wo ich mir einfach ganz sicher war, das war mit einer der kompetentesten Gäste, die ich jemals hatte. Und der erste Kommentar war, na die hatte er mal überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo ich mir dachte, das kann jetzt nicht wahr sein. In meiner Community. Und ich glaube, da ist es dann unsere Aufgabe als Host von Podcasts, dagegen zu halten und einfach gegen zu argumentieren. Und zwar nicht mit der pauschalen Keule, du darfst keine Frau kritisieren, sondern einfach, sag mir bitte, wo war sie inkompetent, sehe ich anders. Wo, ehrlich gesagt, alle, die ich bisher hatte, die entsprechend kommentiert haben, immer sofort aufs Glatteis kamen und mir nicht sagen konnten, worum es jetzt eigentlich ging. Ja, ich hab den Eindruck, die hätte die Spiele gar nicht gesehen. Ja, mach's mal fest, woran hast du den Eindruck? Und ich finde, das ist nämlich was, wo wir aktiv etwas tun können, wo wir nicht nur immer sagen müssen, was sicher auch in Teilen stimmt, dass manche Frauen sich selbst nicht trauen oder sich selbst nicht wichtig genug nehmen, aber das, was wir aktiv tun können, ist auch, dass wir bei solchen Dingen reingerätschen müssen und die Leute festnageln müssen und ihnen auch klarmachen müssen, du misst hier gerade mit zweierlei Maß. Ich hatte das auch in einem Fall, dass ich dann noch eine lange, es war eine sehr anstrengende Diskussion hatte, aber dass derjenige dann im Nachhinein sogar so toll war, zu sagen, krass, du hast recht, ich hab die wirklich mit anderem Maßstab bemessen. Ist sehr, sehr selten, aber es funktioniert.
Weißt du, was das Witzige ist? Ich bin jetzt kein Vater mit Kindern. Aber wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, dass der Typ, der eventuell eine Frau jetzt gerade über den Klee kritisiert hat, eine Tochter zu Hause hat, die irgendeine Sache macht, kann ich mir schwer vorstellen, dass er ihr vermutlich genau das Gleiche unterstellen würde. Oder dass er sie genau in der gleichen Art und Weise kritisieren würde, wie er eventuell eine Podcasterin oder Teilnehmerin an einem Podcast kritisiert hat. Und er würde das auch anders machen. Er würde die Kritik möglicherweise auch anders formulieren. Das kann man ja machen, aber man sollte es dann halt entsprechend konstruktiv angehen. Und ich finde eben, wenn ich jetzt eine Tochter hätte, dann möchte ich meine Tochter fördern. Und das sollte man dann eben auch versuchen zu tun bei Podcasterinnen oder Frauen generell, wo man halt auch sagt, natürlich muss man sie vielleicht manchmal schieben. Keine Frage, aber das ist dann nichts Schlimmes. Aber man muss sie dann halt einfach unterstützen und muss dann sagen, hey, das war doch eigentlich schon mal ganz super. Das war ganz toll am Anfang usw. Die Jule, die ersten Folgen, wenn du die hörst, bei uns, die war hypernervös. Also sie hat ihren eigenen Podcast auch, aber in den ersten Folgen war sie hypernervös. Das hat man auch gehört. Und es hat halt auch so eine Zeit gebraucht, bis die Jule dann in den späteren Folgen die Nervosität abgelegt hat.
Ja, und vor allem die auch mal Kotra gegeben hat.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Okay, also mir war es eigentlich nur wichtig, diesen Punkt noch zu machen.
Ich würde kurz noch was zu sagen wollen, auch wenn das schon sehr lange geht. Aber man muss sich auch einfach nur mal angucken, wie über Frauensport in der Berichterstattung berichtet wird und wie über Männersport, welche Fragen zum Beispiel Frauen gestellt werden. Das würde kein Reporter, ein Mann fragen. Aber guckt euch einfach mal die Interviews mit Kerber nach im Wimbledon-Sieg an. Es ist zum Fremdschämen einfach. Und das sind Rollenbilder. Und so sehr ich auch glaube, dass viele Väter tolle Sachen für ihre Kinder wollen. Viele sind noch so in diesen Rollenbildern festgefahren. Und wenn ich mir das halt meine, das ist durch die ganze Gesellschaft gezogen. Es gibt keine Frauen in Führungspositionen. Die Rollen von Frauen in der Sportberichterstattung brauchen wir glaube ich auch kaum diskutieren. Man kann ja froh sein, dass mit Dunja Hajali da jetzt auch mal eine Frau ist, wo dann gesagt wird, die stellt kritische Fragen. Sonst ist die Zuschreibung, die Frauen vor allen Dingen im Fernsehen bekommen ja oft leider eine ganz andere. Und da ist der Fußball natürlich auf allen Ebenen ganz weit hinterher. Ich meine, wenn Mike sagt, dass in der Kurve zu wenig Frauen sind, dann ist das ja auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Also da sagen ja auch viele Kurven, Frauen gehören hier nicht hin. Die schreiben sich zwar bestimmte Attribute immer auf die Fahnen, aber da dürfen sie halt nicht hin. Und da ist der Fußball immer noch wirklich ganz weit zurück. Und ich glaube, da ist wirklich jeder gefordert, egal ob er Podcaster ist oder nicht, da auch drüber nachzudenken, das immer im Blick zu haben. Und gerade Leute, die Medien machen, wir haben das Thema schon gehabt, Gesprächspartnerin zu haben, Frauen zu fördern, ist halt ein ganz wichtiges Thema, glaube ich, weiterhin. Weil das halt auch viel belebt, wenn es nicht nur Kerle sind, die sich gegenüber sitzen und lakronisch auf die Schenkel klopfen.
Du hörst auch viel lieber zu. Das ist ja das eigentlich Irre, dass sich dann Leute über Frauenstimme im Podcast beschweren. Ich hatte mal einen, der gesagt hat, er kann Frauen generell nicht zuhören, habe ich zurückgeschrieben. Also, tut mir sehr leid für deine Mutter. Und widerspricht übrigens auch allen evolutionsbiologischen Studien, die es gibt. Aber warum spricht das Intro des Rasenfunks eine Frau? Weil ich schon wusste, oh je, das wird eine Männerveranstaltung, egal wie viel ich dagegen tue. Und es ist nachgewiesen, dass ein Sprecherwechsel wichtig ist für die Aufmerksamkeit und aber vor allem auch ein Geschlechterwechsel. Also es täte sogar der Aufmerksamkeitsspanne gut, wenn möglichst oft wir gemischte Gruppen an Sprecherinnen und Sprechern hätten.
Da bin ich ja echt froh, dass ich dabei bin.
Ja, und ich weiß schon gar nicht, wie ich dich jetzt verabschiede.
Schon habe ich aufmerksamer zugehört.
Weil wir gerade nebenher besprochen hatten, dass Anna uns leider verlassen muss. Und ich dachte mir jetzt aber auch schon die ganze Zeit, um Gottes Willen, wir bilden hier eine ganz fürchterliche Rampe, um dich aus der Runde zu verabschieden. Und mit diesen Worten, dass zu wenige Frauen zu hören sind. Aber wir kommen ja nicht drum herum. Du hast noch andere Verpflichtungen, denen du völlig zurecht nachgehen sollst. Anna, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Nicht nur, ausdrücklich nicht nur, weil du eine Frau bist, sondern weil ihr einen tollen Podcast macht, den viel zu wenige Leute kennen. Und weil ich finde, dass du dir hier ganz wunderbar uns erklärt hast, warum den zu wenige kennen. Vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, super. Und ich hoffe, dass ihr tatsächlich mal reinhört und uns vielleicht noch weiter empfiehlt.
Absolut, absolut. Da kannst du Gift drauf nehmen. Danke dir, Anna. Ich hoffe, das war nicht das letzte Mal, dass wir mit dir im Rasenfunk gesprochen haben. Ab jetzt verfolge ich mit Argus Augen alles, was ihr tut. Aber bevor wir dich endgültig verabschieden, liebe Anna, darfst du noch anfangen? Hast du noch einen Podcast, den du den Hörern und Hörern besonders ans Ohr legen würdest?
Ja, in der Tat, natürlich. Und wo wir schon über so wenig Frauen sprechen oder darüber sprechen, dass so viele zu wenig Frauen Podcasts machen, werde ich natürlich jetzt einen Podcast empfehlen, in dem die beiden Gastgeberinnen Frauen sind. Einmal Theresa Sickert und Katja Weber, die in den digitalen, die digitale Safari machen. Das ist ein Podcast eigentlich über Fake News, Big Data, Bitcoins und vieles mehr, das unser Leben beeinflusst. Und da könntet ihr auf jeden Fall mal reinhören. Es ist ganz spannend, die beiden Gastgeberinnen treffen nämlich viele verschiedene Persönlichkeiten, die das Netz bauen, steuern und hinterfragen. Und es kommt also immer wieder zu einer Reise durch unsere digitale Gesellschaft.
Wunderbar, haben wir sehr gerne aufgenommen. Und ich hoffe, da wird auch der ein oder andere und die ein oder andere reinhören. Anna, lieben Dank dir, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast und dass du hier mal mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Bis hoffentlich bald mal.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Da geht die Digital-Uhr bei einem von euch steil. Wir haben jetzt Punkt 12 Uhr. Und das, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ist jetzt auch der Grund, warum wir die Podcast-Empfehlungen jetzt noch schnell machen und dann ein Schleifchen um diese Folge binden. Klaas ist der nächste, der los muss. Hier werden quasi schon Nummern gezogen im Head-Chat zu dieser Folge.
Wie an der Wurst-Tage.
Ja, nur, dass man diesmal dann raus darf aus dem Laden und nicht erst rankommt an der Theke. Klaas, darfst du ein bisschen mehr sein vom Schweindal und welche Podcast-Empfehlungen hättest du denn?
Wie viel darf ich denn nennen? Du bist oben früh. Weil ich hab natürlich, bin so meine Podcast-Rolle, meine persönliche durchgegangen. Wenn mich Leute nach Podcasts fragen, ich empfehle immer den Hintergrund vom Deutschlandfunk. Nicht, weil die hier bei mir um die Ecke sitzen, sondern es ist aus meiner Sicht wirklich der beste Podcast. Ein Thema, in einer Viertelstunde aufgearbeitet, ist vor allem für Leute, was die es halt nicht mehr schaffen, so die Seite 3 in der Süddeutschen zu lesen. Und die zweite Empfehlung, die ich immer gebe, ist das WDR-Zeitzeichen, wo nach Stichtag auf Ereignisse in der Vergangenheit zurückgeblickt wird. Dann so die Sport-Podcast-Liste für Radfans, den Besenwagen-Podcast und auch den Antritt vom Detektor FM. Besenwagen, auch mit so Ex-Profis aus dem Radsport, sehr spannend. Antritt hat so einen ganz schönen Blick auf unterschiedlichste Radthemen. Für Tennis-Fans Chip & Charge und den Wreck-It-Magazin-Podcast, also Chip & Charge von mein Sportradio, wirklich sehr hintergründig über Männer- und Frauentennis. Wreck-It-Magazin, super Interviews mit sehr spannenden Tennis-Spielerinnen und Spielern, unter anderem Andrea Petkovic, auf Englisch allerdings. Und bei Chip & Charge sitzt der Andreas Thies, der macht das Spiel meines Lebens. Super Rückblicks-Podcast, immer auf die Lieblingsspiele von Fans, die da eine Folge drüber reden. Ja, ich glaube, die ganzen Fußball-Podcasts lasse ich jetzt mal weg. Die kennen wir schon alle, außer vielleicht noch den Rückpass, den Fußball-Geschichte-Podcast, den haben vielleicht nicht so viele auf dem Schirm. Gibt es ganz coole Folgen über einzelne Vereine oder auch mal über so ein ganz spannendes Spiel in Moskau von der deutschen Nationalmannschaft. Das ist sehr gut, was hoffentlich jeder auf dem Schirm hat, ist der Radio-Rebell, nicht nur wegen des besten Podcast-Intros, sondern auch wegen der Unterhaltung zwischen Vater und Sohn. Und das Buch von den beiden, wir Wochen in Rebellen sollte natürlich auch jeder lesen. Was haben wir noch? Ach so, Abseits des Sports, das Talk-Radio von Stefan Schulz, der setzt sich einfach vor sein Mikro und lässt uns daran teilhaben, wie er gerade sein Buch, Die Rentnerrepublik, schreibt. Dann gibt es noch ein paar Serien, die ich empfehlen würde, von der BBC, die Assassination-Podcast über den Tod der früheren pakistanischen Premierministerin Benazir Bhutto und so aus dem deutschen Bereich. Wir haben ja schon über Serial kurz gesprochen. Da gibt es jetzt auch so ein paar Formate auf Deutsch. RBB, Christine und ihre Mörder. RBB Kulturradio, wer hat Burak erschossen? Und natürlich, auch wenn ich es rühliger jetzt vielleicht wegnehme, aber sein Podcast-Kompanie Bernie Meyer hat ja dunkle Heimat zusammen mit Nils Bokelberg gemacht über einen 100 Jahre alten Mordfall. Und jetzt mache ich es mal ein bisschen kürzer zum Abschluss, weil wir über Österreich vorhin noch gesprochen haben. Es gibt noch DOF, ein Podcast von Christian Bartlau. DOF steht für Deutsch-Österreichische Freundschaft. Und Christian ist als Deutscher in Österreich und gibt da Einblicke in die Politik von einem Land, das für mich oft schwer nachzuvollziehen, also sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen, obwohl es ja dieselbe Sprache ist wie bei uns und die Kultur sehr ähnlich. Das finde ich sehr gut und deshalb auch den bitte abonnieren.
Ich habe einfach mitgeschrieben, das war wirklich ein Parforce-Rid. Aber so können wir das jetzt eigentlich eh machen, denn die Hörerinnen und Hörer müssen sowieso für diesen Teil die Show notes. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit dieser Welt, dass sich das jemand auswendig merkt. Alles wird verlinkt sein. Ich schreibe hier eifrig mit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und der Klaas hat jetzt schon mal ordentlich vorgelegt. Klar, wie nicht anders zu erwarten. Klaas, damit entlassen wir auch dich in den wohlverdienten Feierabend. Stell deine brummende Deutschlandfunk-Maschine ab.
Das werde ich sofort tun. Aber ein Hinweis, weil ihr da ja wahrscheinlich nachher vielleicht noch über kurz redet, was Anfänger machen sollten, denen empfehle ich allen einfach auf dassendezentrum.de zu gehen. Da gibt es alle Möglichkeiten, alle Fragen, die es rund ums Podcasten gibt. Tolle Podcaster, die sich austauschen. Und alle sollten auf die Subscribe kommen. Eine Podcast-Messe, die es nächstes Jahr wieder im März geben wird. Da kann man sich super über Podcasts austauschen. Das für Anfänger. Und wenn ich noch einen Wunsch...
Die ist dann wo?
Die ist wahrscheinlich in Köln. Ja, und wenn ich mir noch was wünschen darf, gerade für Sport-Podcasts, Fußball-Podcasts, ich hätte gerne mehr reportageige Sportprojekte. Ich weiß, das ist unglaublich aufwendig, aber ich würde es gern hören, wie Menschen im Zug nach Aserbaidschan zum UEFA-Pokal fahren oder bei irgendwelchen Weltmeisterschaftsspielen rumtouren oder der Pokaltriumf begleiten. Ich glaube, da ist noch ganz viel Platz und da sollten sich mehr Leute dran trauen. Und nicht immer nur Lauer-Podcasts machen.
Klaas, jetzt bringst du mich gerade auf eine Idee für nächstes Jahr für die Frauen-WM.
Sehr gut, nein, das ist hervorragend. Gut gemacht, Klaas. Brav. Dann kannst du jetzt ab ins Körbchen.
Liebe Leute, entschuldigt das Brummen. Euch noch viel Spaß und erzählt keinen Quatsch. Ich hör mir das alles an.
Das kann man kaum glauben bei deinen Podcast-Empfehlungen. Dass du dir noch reinhörst, da verstecken wir noch irgendwo einen Easter-Egg und dann schauen wir, ob du darauf anspringst.
So, machen wir's. Bis dann, tschüss.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Klaas Reese, Ed Sport Kultur, war das von Kolinas Erben. Wer von euch möchte denn weitermachen mit den Podcast-Empfehlungen? Inzwischen brummt auch Rüdiger. Die Assimilation hat schon volle Züge angenommen. Du kannst mal überprüfen. Liebe Podcasterinnen und Podcaster draußen, vielleicht mache ich das Brummen an der Stelle einfach mal nicht raus und sage, wenn ihr Brummen auf euren Spuren habt, dann sind die Störquellen meistens Netzteile, die in Laptops stecken. Also Rüdiger, kannst mal kurz gucken, ob du da vielleicht etwas rausziehen kannst. Steckdosen, die im Umfeld des Aufnahmegerätes stehen, auf der Tischplatte zum Beispiel ganz schlecht. Und man kann überprüfen, ob es eine Einstrahlung ist ins Headset, indem man den Gast einfach bittet, mal den Kopf zu drehen, während er spricht oder sie. Wenn dann das Brummen verschwindet, dann ist es eine externe Störquelle, die man vielleicht durch einen Positionswechsel oder einen Raumwechsel ausschließen kann. Also insofern haben wir ja an der Stelle sogar noch etwas Gutes getan und Rüdiger traut sich nicht mehr, sich zu entnuten oder er brummt nicht mehr.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr brumme, ich habe gerade in der Tat das Netzteil rausgenommen.
Es muss sich ja auch los.
Man kann so viel lernen hier.
Das Faszinierende bei den Netzteilen ist, ich habe schon erlebt, dass wenn du den Schoko-Stecker aus der Steckdose ziehst, ihn um 180 Grad drehst, wenn du wieder reinsteckst, dass es dann wieder geht. Manchmal sind die Phasen einfach verschoben und dann funktioniert das auch schon. Das ist so ähnlich wie Globuli auf Steckdosen werfen. Funktioniert.
Das mit den Phasen habe ich aber auch noch nie ganz verstanden.
Ja, aber immerhin schön.
Nicht mal ganz und nicht mal annähernd. Soll ich was empfehlen?
Sehr gerne, Rüdiger.
Leg los. Also von meinem lieben Kompagnon Bernie weiß ich, er hört viel mehr Podcasts als ich. Er hört sehr viel, glaube ich, aus dem amerikanischen The Ringer Network. Verschiedene Podcasts. Schon Sport, aber also natürlich kein Fußball, sondern eher im Wrestling-Bereich. Und da natürlich auch um der Popkultur weiter zu frönen. Auch wunderbare Sachen wie The Re-Watchables. Ein Podcast, wo zum Beispiel gesprochen wird über Filme der 80er und 90er Jahre, die man mal gesehen hat. Das ist sehr unterhaltsam. Mein Lieblings-Podcast ist WTF, W-T-F, What the Fuck. Vielleicht hat es ja einer oder andere gesehen auf Netflix, die wunderbare Serie Glow. Womit wir wieder bei den Frauen sind. Gorgeous Ladies of Wrestling. Der Trainer heißt Marc Maron und hat diesen Interview-Podcast. Und man muss sagen, er ist so ein bisschen die Opera der Podcast-Szene. Also er hat wirklich von Barack Obama über Al Gore zu Hollywood-Stars. Er hat sie alle am Mikrofon gehabt und ist also ein ganz, ganz wunderbarer Podcast.
Sehr schöne Umschreibungen. Und trifft es auch sehr gut, wie ich finde. Marc Maron habe ich auch häufig bei gehört. Ja, genau, weil er wirklich so viele.
Er verdient nur nicht so viel Geld, vermute ich mal.
Ja, wobei er auch zu den Podcastern gehört, die sich, glaube ich, nicht beschweren können in der Hinsicht.
Ich glaube auch. Er macht ja noch das eine, andere. Und wenn ich noch Tipps geben sollte, ich kann es nur für mich selber sagen, ich meine, wir sind jetzt nicht in der Position, dass man, man hat es ja jetzt als Podcaster geschafft und kann nicht Tipps geben. Aber die Regelmäßigkeit war für mich und für uns sehr gut. Regelmäßigkeit, dass die Leute wissen, Montag kommt der Podcast.
Auch vor allem auf YouTube. YouTube, der Algorithmus fand es so klasse, dass wir während der WM täglich da ein Video hochgeladen haben. Das kann ich euch gar nicht sagen. Da kam irgendwie, weiß ich, 1000 Abonnenten gefühlt allein deswegen auf den Rasenfunk auf einmal, weil wir halt dann auch da hochgerankt wurden bei irgendwelchen WM-Suchbegriffen. Also Regelmäßigkeit ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Guter Hinweis. René, magst du weitermachen?
Ja, ich war zwischenzeitlich ein bisschen am Schwanken, weil ich hier acht Podcasts in der Liste stehe, weil ich zwischendrin nochmal aufgestockt habe, nachdem die ganze Frauendiskussion da war, aber nachdem Klaas mehr oder weniger das ganze Programmheft des Deutschlandfunks vorgelesen hat, habe ich da jetzt überhaupt keine Skrupel mehr. Ich muss natürlich als erstes empfehlen, weil sie ja quasi aus dem eigenen Haus sind. Den Ringfuchs-Podcast, den Marvin mit Jasper zusammen macht, geht natürlich um Wrestling, wie der Name schon ganz klar sagt. Aktuelle Themen, Rückblicke, manchmal reden sie auch über Videospiele im Wrestling. Sehr divers, macht immer wieder Spaß. Dann nicht wirklich Podcasts, sondern tatsächlich ein YouTube-Format. Da ist auch wieder Marvin mit drin und teilweise auch Basti Fußball 2000. Das ist quasi das Videopodong, was wir mit dem Atra Frankfurt Podcast nie schaffen. Machen sie da. Kommt jede Woche, ist so maximal eine halbe Stunde. Ist für YouTube-Verhältnisse, glaube ich, ganz okay. Und wenn wir schon bei Basti sind, dann müssen wir zwangsläufig über 3,90 reden. Nach dem Rasenfunk wahrscheinlich die zweitgrößte Fußballgala, die es wöchentlich gibt. Die muss man sich einfach anhören. Die Tippspiele kann man manchmal auslassen, aber spätestens dann, wenn wieder gelebt wird, dann ist das ein Muss.
Ich finde, die Tippspiele sind, je nach Thema, herausragend gut. Aber ja, 3,90, absolute Höhreempfehlung an dieser Stelle.
Blau-Weiß-Mittelstadt, Grüße.
Grüße, genau. Dann würde ich gerne weiter machen mit Cybercrime, eine Produktion des hessischen Rundfunk von Oliver Gunther. Und da verlässt mich der Name Henning Steiner. Das ist ein sehr gutes Format. Die hatten sich in der letzten Staffel, die jetzt knapp rum ist, als Thema Cyber-Sicherheit in Krankenhäusern. Also wer demnächst einen Krankenhausaufenthalt plant, sollte es vielleicht erst danach hören. Aber ansonsten sehr empfehlenswert, dass man diese ganze Zusammenordnung hinkriegt. Mal kürzer, mal längere Folgen lassen sich aber super weghören. Also ich bin mit dem Hund extra Runden gelaufen, um noch die nächste Folge hören zu können. Wenn wir schon bei Cybercrime sind, dann ist der nächste Schritt ganz klar Logbuch Netzpolitik. Kommen wir nicht drumrum. Linus Neumann, Tim Pritlav. Wöchentlich nehmen sie so netzpolitische Themen auseinander.
Tut ein bisschen weh beim Anhören, aber man sollte sich...
Es tut manchmal ein bisschen weh, wobei die beiden halt einfach so wunderbar zusammen harmonieren. Also es tut weh und man hat manchmal sehr viel Fremdscham in sich, aber man muss es sich trotzdem anhören. Und wenn wir schon bei Politik sind, dann ist der nächste Schritt Lage der Nation. Kommen wir leider auch nicht dran vorbei. Wir haben auch gerade eine ganz aktuelle Folge, die so ein bisschen halt, weil sie eine Live-Folge in... Essen, in der Kirche, glaube ich, gemacht haben. Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Halt so ein bisschen, aber wöchentlich aktuelle Politikgeschehnisse sollte man sich halt einfach anhören, damit man da so ein bisschen auch mal andere Meinungen da hat. Und das waren jetzt bis hierhin nur Podcasts mit Männern. Ich schäme mich da gerade so ein bisschen für. Aber jetzt biegen wir ein. Ich habe noch zwei Podcasts, wo Frauen mit dabei sind. Einmal der Weisheit, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt. Ist ein eher unregelmäßig erscheinendes Format. Sie nennen es ein einstündiges Radiomagazin mit mal alltäglichen, tiefschürfendem und albernen Themen. Also es ist halt wirklich auch so eine Mischung aus allem. Es geht eine Stunde und ich bin jedes Mal traurig, wenn die Stunde rum ist, weil es halt richtig, richtig gut ist. Und es sind zwei Frauen mit dabei. Und am Ende den Popkultur-Funk, der von Valentina gemacht wird, die leider auch nur sehr unregelmäßig sendet. Und ich warte immer noch auf die Sons auf NRK-Sonderfolge, die ich hiermit nochmal ganz hart einfordere, weil ich weiß, dass Valentina das hören wird. Die letzte Folge ging um Verschwörungstheorien und ist echt, echt super, sollte man sich auf jeden Fall anhören.
Sehr gut. Oliver, wir waren bei Spion Nummer 5, jetzt kommt Spur Nummer 4. Oliver, diesen Punkt.
Erzählen wir hoch, oder was?
Wir zählen gerade hoch tatsächlich. Da bitte ich nicht wieder jemanden vergessen, weißt du.
Ich könnte jetzt natürlich irgendwie noch die restlichen Sachen von Klaas vom Deutschlandfunk nennen, die ihr jetzt alle nicht genannt habt. Würde ich jetzt dagegen gescheitern, wenn ich mir die anderen Programminhalte erzählen würde? Oder Sachen aus Sachsen-Anhalt erzählen? Aber da wissen die meisten Leute nicht mal, wo das liegt. Ich mag sehr gerne frische Angearbeit von Zeit Online, wo immer wechselnde, mehr oder weniger prominente Gäste da sind. Meistens Schauspieler, Schauspielerinnen oder irgendwie Personen aus dem öffentlichen Leben. Aber neulich war auch ein Polizist da, das war mal ganz erfrischend. Und dann gibt es 25 Fragen, wie die Leute ihre Arbeit sehen, was sie verdienen, ob das das ist, wovon sie geträumt haben. Und das ist meistens auch nicht so super lang. Ich habe schon gesagt, ich bin eher so der, naja, wahrscheinlich Kurzhörer aus eurer Sicht. Und, weiß nicht, nur halbe.
Wissen schon, dass du hier so lange jetzt zugehört hast.
Ja, zuhören geht ja, ja. Oder selber mitmachen auch so ein bisschen. Das ist ja ganz interessant. Ich höre auch mal mir eine lange Sache an, aber bin dann eher so... Wenn ich eine Stunde koche, höre ich mir gerne zwei Sachen an. Deswegen mag ich gerne so kurze Sachen. Ich lese eben viele Texte. Wenn ich mich darauf konzentriere, kann ich nebenbei nichts hören, wo ich zuhören möchte. Und so fügt sich das ein bisschen zusammen, dass ich tendenziell lieber kürzere Sachen höre. Aber wie gesagt, frisch an die Arbeit mag ich sehr gerne. Weil es da spannende Geschichten zu hören gibt oder einfach Einblicke in mir bekannte Personen gibt, die ich so noch nicht hatte. Das finde ich sehr gut. Dann mag ich sehr gerne Brexit Means von Guardian, wo jetzt nur noch monatlich, bis vor einer Weile war das wöchentlich, einfach immer wieder erklärt wird, was bedeutet der Brexit, also das Verlassen Großbritanniens der EU, für Polen, für Deutschland, für Nordirland, für bestimmte gesellschaftliche Gruppen. Da werden auch immer Experten und Expertinnen meistens zugeschaltet aus den Ländern oder aus Brüssel usw., wo dann die verschiedenen neuesten Entwicklungen besprochen werden. Wenn jetzt wieder irgendein EU-Gipfel war und wieder nichts herausgekommen ist, sitzen da eben drei, vier Leute und versuchen zu erklären, woran das jetzt liegt oder was das bedeuten könnte. Wobei das Fazit immer so ist, so richtig wissen wir jetzt eigentlich nicht, ob überhaupt je ein Ergebnis kommt. Das ist eigentlich so das Fazit jeder Folge, aber das ist ja auch die Geschichte des Brexit irgendwo.
Und da kann ich auch die Remaniacs empfehlen an der Stelle. Habe ich selber noch nicht reingehört, aber kommt unter anderem aus dem Mund von Tim Pritloff diese Empfehlung. Deswegen kann man sie ungehört weitergeben. Das ist auch ein sehr guter Brexit-Podcast.
Ja, und bei den Fußball-Podcasts würde ich tatsächlich den Phrasendrescher empfehlen. Das ist ein Format, was mir sehr gut gefällt, von bild.de, wo jetzt, weiß ich nicht, Nils Petersen und Rudi Völler und so was zu Gast sind, was irgendwie ein ganz interessantes ist, dass sie eine Aufnahme immer auf zwei Folgen splitten. Aber wo ich dann tatsächlich auch immer schon ganz aufgeregt bin, dass dann irgendwann der zweite Teil dazukommt. Und wo irgendwie das auch interessant ist, weil sie dann immer irgendwelche Wegbegleiter von ihren Gästen angerufen haben und die dann irgendwie Fragen stellen dürfen. Und das ist dann phasenweise sehr niedlich. Und den höre ich auch sehr gerne. Das wär's.
Phasenweise sehr niedlich. Sehr schöner Claim auch für den Podcast. Finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Sollte man auch aufs Sticker drücken. Der nächste in der Reihe ist Sven. Was sind deine Podcastempfehlungen? Anna, mussten wir leider schon aufschieben.
Okay. Ja, muss ich mal schnell hier das Handy aufmachen. Ja, ich höre jetzt nicht so viel wie die anderen. Ich höre allerdings auch nicht in anderthalbfache Geschwindigkeit. Ich habe festgestellt, als ich bei dir im Auto saß, das ist halt wirklich absolut nichts für mich.
Anderthalbfach oder zweifach? Das ist ja die spannende Frage.
Ne, dann machst du mich anderthalbfach.
1,7. Ich habe es für dich auf 1,5 runtergemacht, weil ich dachte, das wird dann erträglicher bei manchen Podcasts, bei langsamen Sprechern auch gerne 2,0. Anders komme ich nicht mehr durch.
Ja, ich fange mal an mit Fotografie. Und zwar einmal der Podcast Radio Raw, ist zwar ein englischer Name, ist aber ein deutschsprachiger Fotopodcast. Dann Happy Shooting. Und mit Chris Marquardt und Absolut Analog, wer in die Welt der analogen Fotografie einsteigen möchte, der ist ebenfalls mit Chris Marquardt, allerdings mit seiner besseren Hälfte der Monika zusammen, beide. Und dann noch die Photophonie, also Foto mit F und Phonie mit PH. Technik Podcasts, höre ich eigentlich in der Regel meistens nur zwei. Und zwar ist das einmal beides BR-Produktionen, und zwar einmal das B5-Computer-Magazin. Geht immer ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Kommt immer sonntags, oder?
Genau, kommt immer sonntags. Ich habe auch aufgehört. Das gibt es dann noch als Podcast und ist eigentlich absolut top für mich, um da immer so mit den neuesten Sachen dran zu bleiben. Und der Netzfilter, PULS Netzfilter, auch von BR, eigentlich mehr so ein Format für, ja die Zielgruppe ist eigentlich eher so jungere Hörer. Ich mag es eigentlich trotzdem ganz gerne. Also es ist auch irgendwie eine Live-Sendung, die dann auf zwei Stunden, von zwei Stunden irgendwie dann zusammengekürzt wird auf 37, 40 Minuten mit abwechselndem Personal. Ich mag es immer nicht so gerne, zum Beispiel, wenn da zwei Jungs sind. Ich mag es eigentlich sehr gerne, wenn sowohl eine weibliche Moderatorin als auch ein männlicher Moderator durch die Sendung führen. Ja, das höre ich sehr gerne. Dann habe ich noch einen rein weiblichen Podcast. Und zwar, der hat jetzt nichts mit Fußball zu tun. Er heißt Müller und Matsko. Die Milfstitten machen mobil. Den Namen haben sich die Damen selber gegeben. Der stammt nicht von mir. Dabei geht es um Ariane Müller und Caro Matsko, die beide in Ulm geboren sind, die beide in Ulm zur Schule gegangen sind. Die eine wohnt inzwischen in München, arbeitet beim BR und ist die Bardame bei Ringswandel. Und die andere macht viel Theater und Kleinbühne, auch musikalisch. Das ist die Ariane Müller, weil ich die beiden nicht durcheinander haue. Immer so 30 Minuten, sehr interessant. Die beiden quatschen über allen möglichen Themen, die gerade so anstehen, ob sie gerade schlecht drauf sind, was ihre Kinder machen, über Seehofer, über Feminismus und so weiter. Ich mag es unheimlich gerne, den 30 Minuten da zuzuhören. Und dann Fußballpodcast, englischsprachig, und zwar BBC World Football. Wird mir meistens immer viel zu wenig genannt. Mag ich sehr, sehr gerne. 30 Minuten, natürlich durch das Netzwerk von der BBC, klar. Da haben die natürlich sehr viel Themen breitgefächert rund um die Welt, was gerade da ist. Und dann noch drüber gehalten, selbstverständlich. Der Ostfußballpodcast, nicht zu vergessen. Auf meinsportradio.de. Und dann gibt es hier noch einen, da kann ich aber gar nicht sehen, wie der eigentlich, The Lob Podcast heißt der. Auch ein englischsprachiger Fußballpodcast, der immer mal wieder, ja auch länger, 30, 60, 90 Minuten zu bestimmten fast so ein bisschen wie 120 Minuten auf Englisch zu einem speziellen Thema dann das Ganze bespricht. Nicht jedes Thema ist was für mich, aber ich habe ihn abonniert. Wenn es ein Thema dabei ist, was mich interessiert, höre ich das immer durchaus sehr, sehr gerne. Und ebenfalls kein Sport, aber ebenfalls Englisch ist The Bangkok Podcast. Also für Leute, die sich sehr für Thailand interessieren, vor allem für Bangkok, wie mich, das ist ein Podcast, der wird von zwei Jungs gemacht, die im Kanadier und einem Engländer, die schon seit, ich glaube, fast 20 Jahren in Bangkok leben. Und die haben immer mal wieder ganz interessante Gäste, berichten aus ihrem Alltagsleben, sprechen in 30 Minuten über aktuelle Topics, die halt gerade in Thailand so anstellen. Dann haben sie jetzt angefangen, so ein bisschen die einzelnen Viertel in Bangkok der Stadt vorzustellen, was da Besonderes gibt. Also auf jeden Fall unheimlich interessanter Podcast für jemanden, der thailandaffin ist. Und zum Schluss noch ein Podcast, den möchte ich noch nennen, den ich immer wieder gerne gerne reinhöre, den ich bin quasi darauf aufmerksam geworden, weil du da zu Gast warst, Max, und zwar der Sendegarten. Öfters sehr, sehr lang mit einem Gast, manchmal drei Stunden, manchmal zwei Stunden. Aber immer wieder wahnsinnig interessante Gäste. Auch hier kann man sich natürlich einfach, ja, dann quasi das rauspicken, ob einen das Thema interessiert oder eben nicht.
Absolut, kann ich auch empfehlen. Der Sendegarten ist ein bisschen ein Metapodcast über Podcasts selbst. Jetzt bin ich noch an der Reihe und ich werde mich kurz halten. Ich habe bei der Auswahl die harte Entscheidung getroffen, dass ich in meine History gegangen bin, in meine Listening History, und jetzt nur Produktionen nenne, die ich innerhalb der letzten sechs Monate auch mindestens einmal gehört habe. Ich könnte noch ganz, ganz viel anderes empfehlen, aber ich dachte mir, man kommt dann schnell in die Situation, dass man Freunde und Freundinnen von sich selbst empfehlen möchte. Also bitte nicht böse sein, wer da jetzt nicht mit dabei ist. Machen wir schnell die, die noch nicht genannt wurden, im Fußballbereich, der Rasengeflüster-Podcast mit Sebastian Schuppern und Jens Umbreit, Bundesliga mit dem herausragende Tobi Escher und den wunderbaren Rocket Beans. Fußball-MML höre ich jede Folge doppel 6 der Podcast dazu. Das ist so ein bisschen die nostalgisch-intellektuelle Version von Fußball-MML, ohne dass ich einem von beiden damit auf die Füße treten wollen würde. Und der reingemocht Podcast lohnt sich immer, wenn er denn mal erscheint. Und nun zum Sport, vom SZ Sport, höre ich jedes Mal gerne rein. Die Vereins-Podcasts von Werder Gladbach und Leverkusen lohnen einem Blick, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe. Die Deutschlandfunk-Sachen hat alle der Klaas schon genannt, deswegen lasse ich es weg. Na, das Sportgespräch möchte ich dann doch noch mal rausheben. Das lohnt sich. Es gibt sehr, sehr gute Hertha BSC-Podcasts, immer Hertha-Damenwahl und Hertha-Base. Da hoppe ich immer mal wieder so hin und her, genauso wie ich es bei mir, Sanrod und den Erfolgsfans, tue im Bezug auf den FC Bayern. Beim FC Schalke 04 gab es immer den Blauen Salon. Leider schon lange nichts mehr passiert, aber lohnt sich, den zu abonnieren, wenn eine neue Folge kommt. Wird sie sich gelohnt haben? Dann gibt es auch noch die Stuttur II, auch für Ohren in der schwarz-gelben Version. Mindestens genauso empfehlenswert. Textilvergehen haben wir schon genannt. Der Schlüsselspieler-Podcast habe ich in der letzten Folge schon erwähnt, weil Phil bei mir Gast war in der Schlusskonferenz. Das möchte ich an der Stelle aber auch gerne nochmal tun. Und der Ungehalten-Podcast lohnt auch. Ansonsten sonstige Sport-Podcasts und auch andere Themen. Sportradio 360, die Big Show, jeden Donnerstag um 17 Uhr, wenn man sich für Sport interessiert. Ein Muss, wenn man sich für NFL interessiert, ist Downset Talk, der beste deutschsprachige NFL-Podcast in meiner...... in meiner Wahrnehmung. Danke, meiner Meinung nach wollte ich eigentlich sagen. Im Politikbereich kann ich jung und naiv den Aufwachen-Podcast No Agenda, die Lage der Nation- und Logbuchnetzpolitik, sehr empfehlen. Wer sich für das Thema Blockchain interessiert und das Ganze nicht bei Adam und Eva anfangen möchte, Running on Blockchain ist da ein recht junges Podcast-Produkt, was ich sehr gerne höre. Gästeliste Geisterbahn ist ein Muss für die Entspannung zwischendurch. Die Anachronistin und Was-denkst-du-den? Zwei herausragende Podcasts von Nora Hespers. Serial muss man eigentlich nicht mehr empfehlen. Methodisch inkorrekt, der beste Wissenschaftspodcast, den es da draußen gibt. Auch wenn sie manchmal ein bisschen lange Einleitungen machen. Darunter hast du ein bisschen gelitten, als wir es auf 1,5-facher Geschwindigkeit gehört haben. Auf dem Weg nach Wacken. Making Obama kann ich noch sehr empfehlen. The History of Rome. Toller Podcast, überhaupt Geschichtspodcast. Dafür eignet sich dieses Medium so so gut. Und der lila Podcast, wenn man sich für Emanzipation und Feminismus interessiert, auch unbedingt empfehlenswert.
Zwei Podcasts, wenn ich noch kurz nachbestimmen soll, weil du History erwähnt hast. Das habe ich tatsächlich vergessen. Und zwar gibt es einen Amerikaner, der heißt Travis Doe. Der hat zehn Jahre lang in Prag gelebt und war dort als Touristenführer unterwegs. Und ist davor in München groß geworden. Und er hat zwei Podcast-Projekte. Eins, das wird leider nicht mehr aktualisiert, das heißt Bohemiken, der Bohemica-Podcast. Ich sag dir das nachher noch in Ruhe. Das ist ein Podcast über die Geschichte Tschechens. Die gehen da zusammen verschiedene Themen an und erzählen die nach. Finde ich unheimlich interessant, gerade wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Bohemischer und Tschechischer Geschichte für Tschechische Geschichte interessiert. Und sein anderes Projekt, das ist allerdings aktuell, das heißt, er lebt jetzt inzwischen wieder in Amerika, heißt Amerikaner für euch. Also Amerikan und dann aber A hinten dran, Amerikaner, genau, für euch. Und er erzählt quasi amerikanische Geschichte für Deutsche. Also auf Deutsch für Deutsche. Und packt da sehr viele interessante Stories an. Er macht manchmal so eine Art Rollenspiel, wo er einfach nur irgendwie ein bisschen was erzählt. Man hat mal so das Gefühl, okay, was ist das jetzt? Er erzählt, tut das gerade so, als ob er ein Schauspiel aufführt. Und manchmal geht er auch einfach nur irgendwie auf Hintergrund Sachen von der Geschichte von Amerika ein. Diverse Topics, also auch sehr interessant, wenn das interessiert.
Wunderbar. Bevor dir jetzt noch mehr Podcasts sein wollen.
Nein, alles gut.
Aber wir füllen alle Podcast-Klischees mit der Länge dieser Folge irgendwie. Ja, auch nett. Ich würde sagen, jetzt in die Runde, ohne dass ich das jetzt noch abgesprochen hätte, wir machen den letzten Teil nur ganz kurz. Wenn ihr selbst einen Podcast starten wollt, ihr lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, dann finden wir das A, hervorragend, B, helfen wir euch alle in der Runde sehr gerne. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft ich schon Leuten auf E-Mails, Direct Messages und so weiter geantwortet habe, wie man den Podcast starten kann. Ihr könnt euch, denke ich, an alle aus der Runde sehr gerne wenden. Und Klaas hat vorhin schon gesagt, geht auf dassendezentrum.de und das sendegate.de, also einfach nur sendegate.de. Das ist ein Forum, da gibt es die Podcastpartien unter anderem. Die nehmen sich genau dieser Sache an, nämlich Podcast-Neulinge und ihre Fittiche, helfen ihnen in technischer Natur, in inhaltlicher Natur. Und dann werden euch viele Fragezeichen sehr schnell in Ausrufezeichen und zufriedene Punkte im Kopf verändert. Und so kann man sehr schnell einen Podcast starten. Die Software, die die meisten von uns verwenden, ist Ultraschall. Damit wird jetzt gerade diese Folge aufgezeichnet. Die Zuschaltung der Gäste läuft über Studio Link. Aber das sind alles schon Details. Es gibt Podcasts, an die ihr euch wenden könnt. Es gibt eben diese Internetadressen. sendegate.de, das sendezentrum.de. Und dann kriegt ihr das hin. Und die technische Hürde sollte im Jahr 2018 nie der Grund sein, warum man einen Podcast nicht macht. Man bekommt im Grunde sogar mit dem Smartphone Folgen in akzeptabler und guter Qualität hin. Und das Veröffentlichen ist heutzutage wirklich kein Problem mehr. Es ist auch nicht teuer, ganz, ganz viel ist open source. Lasst euch davon nicht abhalten. Möchte jemand von euch anderen, die Verbliebenen in der Runde, Oliver, Rüdiger, René, Sven, möchte jemand von euch noch dazu etwas ergänzen? Und Mike natürlich. Sven, klar.
Das Gleiche, was eigentlich auch schon in der Folge vor drei Jahren, glaube ich, anklang. Und was mir selber ein bisschen sauer aufstößt, bei Leuten, die einen neuen Podcast beginnen, ich kann das durchaus nachvollziehen, warum man das vielleicht macht. Aber wenn man halt auf Soundcloud geht oder irgendwo anders seinen Podcast Hostet und den nicht in einen Podcast-Katalog integriert, sprich iTunes zum Beispiel, was dann der Referenzkatalog ist, dann hat man halt leider das Problem, dass man deviceübergreifend, sprich iOS, Android, den Podcast nicht abonnieren kann. Und ich hab so drei Podcasts, die auch teilweise alle neu sind, die ich nicht abonnieren kann. Das heißt, ich muss jedes Mal schauen, ob dann eine neue Folge online ist. Wenn mein Podcastketcher sagt, hier ist eine neue Folge, hör mich an. Ich muss also proaktiv hinterher sein.
Hast du das denn den Dreien schon gesagt?
Ja, also einen Podcast hab ich auf jeden Fall schon gesagt. Die meinten auch zu mir, sie wären auf jeden Fall dran. Also auf Soundcloud hosten mag ja okay sein, aber dann solltet ihr wenigstens schauen, dass ihr irgendwo in einem zentralen Podcastkatalog gelistet seid, worüber dann die diversen Podcasts, verschiedenen Podcast-Catch-Up-Plattformen übergreifen, letztendlich sich das Inhaltsverzeichnis rausziehen. Und dann noch eins, vor drei Jahren hat der Max, ja, also ich hab Podcast angefangen zu hören, weil der Max, den ich privat kannte, einen Podcast gemacht hat. Und sonst hätte ich mit Podcast-Hören auch nie angefangen, weil es für mich immer ein Apple-Ding war. Und natürlich auch unter anderem durch die Folge von vor drei Jahren über Podcasts, wenn sich die Hörde abgebaut hat, dann hat der Max natürlich aufgerufen und hat gesagt, geht's raus, macht Podcasts, ihr braucht's nicht viel, ein Handy und ein Headset reicht. Stimmt, hat er recht. Das Problem ist nur, ich sag euch eins, ihr werdet mit der Qualität nicht zwangsläufig zufrieden sein.
Das darf man den Leuten aber nicht verraten. Es ist erst mal nicht falsch. Deswegen kann man mit Smartphone und so weiter gut starten. Natürlich ist anderes besser und man steckt da Geld und Liebe und Geduld rein.
Aber ansonsten hat der Max schon recht. Einfach mal machen, einfach mal starten und dann werdet ihr schon sehen, wo euch das Ganze dann letzten Endes hinträgt. Was ich mir vielleicht irgendwie noch ein bisschen wünschen würde, wer beim Sende geht, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Also mir geht es zumindest so, ich hätte ganz gerne immer irgendwie ein schickes Intro, ich hätte ganz gerne irgendwie ein Logo, ist natürlich kein Muss, aber da, finde ich, gibt es irgendwie so einen Marketplace, wo man sich das irgendwie raussuchen könnte, finde ich relativ schwierig. Sowas sollte es vielleicht noch irgendwie geben.
Möchtet ihr anderen noch irgendetwas ergänzen oder seid ihr schon entschwunden in die Nacht? Wir nehmen das jetzt in der Sprechstunde auf.
Ich möchte nur nichts ergänzen. Weil hier keine Frauenstimme ist, bin ich kurz weggenickt.
Ich möchte bei dem Punkt gerne einhaken, mit diesem Hosen auf den anderen Plattformen. Das kann man machen, aber dann guckt halt wirklich, dass das Zeug von Anfang an wirklich in diesen Verzeichnissen ist oder diesen RSS-Feed. Ich habe so viele Dinge gehabt, die ich prinzipiell spannend gefunden habe, aber weil die Plattform es nicht bereitgestellt hat, dass diese RSS-Feed zum automatischen Abonnieren ist, acht Wochen später da ist. Und ganz ehrlich, die meisten Leute halten das nicht nach und installieren nicht eine Extra-App nur für den einen Podcast. Wenn ihr das Ding nicht von Anfang an dabei habt, dann vertut ihr euch einfach eine gewisse Chance, von Anfang an da Leute mitzunehmen. Von daher guckt, dass ihr das irgendwie hinkriegt. Da gibt es genügend Leute, die euch helfen. Ansonsten stimme ich dem Max von vor drei Jahren zu. Wenn ihr bis hierhin zugehört habt, wenn ihr länger als fünf Minuten über das Thema nachgedacht habt, dann fangt an, Herrgott, noch eins.
Genau, sehr gut. Geht in die Lande und verbreitet Podcast-Liebe. Verkaut Podcast-Liebe. Und tut es regelmäßig. Genau, dann werdet ihr auch gehört. Ich möchte noch ganz kurz was sagen. Natürlich, Mike.
Und zwar hast du mich bei den Podcast-Empfehlungen vergessen. Und die muss ich ja draufhauen, weil wir uns in der Gruppe abgestimmt haben.
Das ist ja furchtwendig.
Er versaut es am Anfang und am Ende.
Das ist eine Erzählte. Das ist eine Klammer, Leute. Eine inhaltliche Klammer. Das ist die hohe Kunst. Die ganz hohe Kunst.
Ich weiß, dass ich damit auch sämtliche Kapitelmarken zerschieße, aber das ist jetzt so. Und es sind dafür auch nur drei Stück. Und ich beschränke mich auf den Bereich Fußball, wobei ich noch kurz unterstützen möchte, was du gesagt hast, der Downside Talk im Football-Bereich finde ich absolut super, Montan. Fußball, und zwar das, was du machst für die 1. Liga, gibt es auch für die 2. neuerdings. Und zwar von Johnny Walsh und Matthew Kerigich. Das nennt mich 2. Bundesliga-Podcast, ist aber auf Englisch. Wer die Hürde bereit ist zu überschreiten, der wird da sehr gut betreut. Die blicken jeweils zurück auf den vergangenen und voraus auf den kommenden Spieltag. Ein weiterer englischer Podcast, den ich höre, ist der Who-Are-Ya-Podcast. Da stellen, ich glaube, die kommen aus Stoke, ist aber relativ egal, auf jeden Fall Leute von der Insel, verschiedene Vereine vor. Sie beschränken sich dabei nicht auf die Insel, sondern es geht auch der FCN-Polizei-Walzberg-für-Oschmer-Thema. Aber halt sehr schön, weil sie dann wirklich zu diesem Ort hinfahren und da mit Leuten von vor Ort sprechen. Warum bist du Fan dieses Vereins? Erklär mal, wie kam es dazu und so weiter. Also wirklich sehr hörenswert und auch da kann man sein Englisch verbessern. Und um einen Fußballpodcast noch mit weiblicher Beteiligung zu erwähnen, gibt es einen weiteren FCN-Polypodcast, der die Besonderheit hat, dass der aufgenommen wird in Toronto, also 7.000 Meilen westlich. Und zwar heißt der Fall in Love with a Girl und wird gemacht von Sean und Samantha. Und die sind halt tatsächlich, man mag es kaum glauben, sein Polyfans und beschäftigen sich da sehr, sehr, sehr mit sehr viel Herzblut mit dem Verein und berichten dann da im Podcast.
Wunderbar, Mike. Und tausendfache Entschuldigung, dass ich... Ich dachte, ich hätte ganz... Es sind einfach zu viele Spuren. Sagen wir es ganz ehrlich, im Grunde hat dieses jetzt inzwischen mehr als vierstündige Experiment gezeigt. Zu viele Spuren, das lässt sich nicht mehr verwalten. Da brennen diese Napsten zumindest bei diesem Moderator durch. Und das ist einfach zu viel.
Ich kann bezeugen, der Moderator hat auch erst nur ein Bier getrunken.
Ja, ich bin nicht mal zum Trinken gekommen. Aber es ist ja auch ein ständiges Gemute. Gemute und Geneibe und so weiter.
Wenn du dehydrierst, kannst du dich auch nicht mehr konzentrieren. Das ist sportwissenschaftlich auch belegt.
Da kann ich aber an der Stelle nochmal die Erfahrung... Es ist ja nicht meine erste lange Podcastaufzeichnung. Ich kann dann auch aus Erfahrung sagen, je weniger, desto besser. Denn der Host kann nicht auf Toilette gehen.
Ja, Prost.
Lass es dir schmecken, Sven. Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt an der Stelle ein Schleifchen drum. Ich danke euch sehr, ihr habt eine unglaubliche Ausdauer bewiesen. Also manchmal rechne ich damit, dass Folgen Eskalin hätte ich eigentlich gar nicht gedacht, dass es so lange wird. Ich hoffe, dass für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen viel Neues mit dabei war, dass vielleicht der und die ein oder andere, die jetzt durch den Preis der Akademie für Fußballkultur hierauf aufmerksam geworden ist, viel, viel Lust hat und wahrscheinlich das hier schon gar nicht mehr hört, sondern irgendwas von den 1000 Dingen, die wir schon genannt haben. Es würde mich sehr freuen, in den Links, in den Show Notes zu dieser Folge wird es alle relevanten Podcasts, die wir genannt haben, nochmal verlinkt geben. Danke auch schon mal dafür an die Vorarbeit, die ihr hier zum Teil schon im Chat geleistet habt. Muss ich nicht mal alles raussuchen. Ich bedanke mich in Anwesenheit, in Abwesenheit bei Anna Stecher von der Kooperativen Berlin. Sie war hier stellvertretend für den Podcast Fußball und Macht und in Abwesenheit danke ich auch nochmal Klaas Reese, dem Ed Sport Kultur von Kolinas Erben und in Anwesenheit. Bedanke ich mich natürlich, damit ich ihn nicht wieder vergesse, sonst hängt er noch morgen früh um 8 Uhr am Telefon. Mike Krückmeier vom Millenton, dem sehr empfehlenswerten FC St. Pauli Podcast. Mike, vielen Dank und Entschuldige bitte. Ich danke euch, dass ihr euch so viel Zeit genommen habt. Ed Mike Krue heißt du auf Twitter, da kann man dir folgen. Und Ed Rüdiger Rudolf heißt Rüdiger Rudolf vom Brennerpass. Rüdiger, danke, dass du hier warst, brummend und nicht brummend und uns nicht nur vom Brennerpass erzählt hast.
Ich danke dir auch und danke auch den lieben, darf ich Kollegen sagen?
Endlich Kollege mit einem Schauspieler. Das ist ein Traum, der jetzt auch für uns erfüllt wurde. Ein Traum war es ebenfalls, dass René Kurfürst mit dabei war, das Ette rüsselt hier auf Twitter vom Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast. René, du alter Podcast-Hauerdingen. Danke, dass du mit im Rasenfunk dabei warst. Hat große Freude gemacht.
Vielen Dank für die Runde. Und ich bin sehr froh, dass ich das jetzt nicht schneiden muss. Und das Codewort für Lars an dieser Stelle ist Tour de France.
Meinst du für Klaas oder für Lars? Ich habe schon Lars verstanden. Ich bin völlig durch. Tour de France ist das Codewort. Wir sind mal sehr gespannt, ob er das noch hören wird. Zudem ganz herzlichen Dank an Oliver Leiste, der natürlich at leisteo auf Twitter auch heißt, von und stellvertretend für 120 Minuten und all seine anderen Podcast-Projekte. Oliver, vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit für den Rasenfunk genommen hast.
Ja, schön, dass ich hier sein durfte. Eine Frage beschäftigt mich noch. Sehen wir uns eigentlich alle in Nürnberg?
Ich werde da sein.
Also mich nicht. Dafür wirst du meine Kollegin und Partnerin Jule treffen.
Ich bin leider nicht da und bereue es jetzt schon.
Ja, wir freuen uns. Dann kann ich euch allen ein Bier ausgeben, hoffentlich auf Kosten der Akademie. Dann mache ich das doppelt gerne dafür, dass ihr euch so viel Zeit genommen habt. Also vielen Dank, lieber Oliver. Und danke dir, lieber Sven-Ed-El-Loco74, stellvertretend für Lottes Abend. Danke, dass du hierher gekommen bist, in die Rasenfunkstudios.
Es war mir eine Ehre, wie immer.
Das freut mich sehr. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann danke ich euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Hört Podcasts, macht Podcasts und habt einfach Spaß an dem, was wir da produzieren hoffentlich. Und gebt Feedback nicht nur jetzt auf diese Folge unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, sondern gerne auch auf die anderen Formate, die ihr so jetzt vielleicht entdeckt habt. Da freuen sich die Macherinnen und Macher sehr. Das kann ich jetzt schon mal bestätigen. Das war es mit dem Update aus der Fußball-Podcast-Landschaft im Jahr 2018. Wir hören uns dann im Jahr 2021. Bin gespannt, über was wir dann sprechen. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.